BEFORE YOU. WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE HEARING A FEW
REMINDERS MASKS ARE REQUIRED IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND IN OTHER
COMMON AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL TESTIMONY CAN BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED OUTSIDE THE CAPITAL
NEAR THE NORTH STEPS AND BY
PHONE NUMBER FOR PHONE
TESTIMONY IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO.
THIS NUMBER IS POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND ALSO
APPEARS ON THE VIDEO FEED ONCE
THE PRIMARY SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HAVE
TESTIFIED I WILL CALL FOR PHONE
TESTING. WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY WITH ONE
BILL PROPOSED FOR CONSENT- ITEM
EIGHT SB TWO AWAIT DOLLY. HE OF
I THINK WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE- SINCE WE HAVE
ONLY THREE MEMBERS- WE'LL START
WITH SENATOR ALAN- ITEM ONE S.
B. FORTY FOUR IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S BEEN ALLEN DAY IN THE
SIMPLY NATURAL RESOURCES HAVE
FOR BILLS- PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
START WHEN YOU'RE READY. THIS
IS INCREASINGLY- ALREADY
FINANCES YOUR COMMITTEES YOU
ALL ARE WORKING HERE. YEAH YEAH.
I WAS SURPRISED THE MEMBERS OF
THE OF THE HOUSE. REPORTER THIS
BILL WILL ESTABLISH EXPEDITED
REVIEW FOR EVEN PROJECTS
REQUIRE THE POOREST RESULT
RELATED BUT- LAWSUITS WITHIN.
TWO TO SEVEN DAYS EXTENT
FEASIBLE. THE SOONER THESE
TRAIN ENVIRONMENTALLY
BENEFICIAL TRANSIT PROJECTS CAN
COMPLETE THE SIGNUP PROCESS AND
ARE BUILT THE FASTER THEY WILL
DISPLACE LESS EFFICIENT
POLLUTION INTENSIVE REGIONAL
TRIPS TAKEN BY PASSENGERS AND
PRIVATE VEHICLES. SO- YOU KNOW
THE PROJECT AT THIS EXPEDITED
REVIEW HAVE TO MEET A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF STUFF A JUDICIAL SAID
CERTAIN CERTAIN- AS A BENCH
MARKS THE FIRST WILL HAVE TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE REGION
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
STRATEGY AND TRANSPORTATION
PLANT OPERATED ZERO EMISSIONS
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
WITHOUT USING OFFSETS AND-
REDUCE OVERALL VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED IN THE QUARTER WITH
THE PROJECT OPERATES SO THE
BILL. IS SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
TO LAST YEAR'S SB SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE BUT- AS YOU MAY
RECALL IT WAS AND THE MOUSE
TALK ABOUT THIS IT WAS
CONTINGENT UPON ANOTHER BILL
PASSING DIDN'T PASS AND SO HERE
WE ARE AGAIN- THE BILL PASSED
THIRTY SEVEN TO ZERO. OUT OF
THE- OF THE SENATE AND- WITHOUT
AYE AYE TODAY I HAVE MICHAEL
TURNER TO HEAR FROM L. A. METRO
AND MICHAEL- PIMENTEL. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU- MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE- OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MICHAEL
TURNER FROM LA METRO AND
MICHAEL PIMENTEL FROM
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION.
YOUR TEAM BURNER PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
MICHAEL TURNER WITH THE- L. A.
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY I CAN
BEING THE SUPPORT OF OUR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS FOR SB FORTY FOUR
AND WE LIKE TO THINK SENATOR
ALAN FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS MEASURE AGAIN AND WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE.
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US AGAIN
ON THIS BILL- THE BILL WOULD
STREAMLINE THE SECRET PROCESS
SPECIFICALLY FOR METRO'S FOUR
PILLAR PROJECTS WE'RE WORKING
AGGRESSIVELY TO DELIVER TRANSIT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THROUGH
OUR AMBITIOUS TWENTY EIGHT BY
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT PLAN TO
HELP THE L. A. COUNTY MEET THE
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS. OF LA
COUNTY'S TEN MILLION RESIDENTS
FOR COLOR PROJECTS OF COURSE
THE GREEN LINE RAIL EXTENSION A
TORRANCE THE WEST SANTA ANA
BRANCH LIKE REAL LINES BE CYCLE
LINE EXTENSION AND THIS PUBLIC
TRANSIT QUARTER PROJECT. THE
FOUR PILLAR PROJECT SERVICE
CLEAN TRANSIT ALTERNATIVES AND
CONNECTORS TO REGIONAL MOBILITY
FOR COMMUTERS THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHICH IS THE
MOST CONGESTED REGION IN THE
NATION WITH SB FORTY FOUR METRO
WILL BE ABLE TO ACCELERATE THE
PROJECT REVIEW PROCESS BY
APPLYING THE SHORTLINE
LITIGATION PROCESS TO THE
TRANSIT PROJECTS ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS. ANY PROCEEDINGS
REGARDING THE JUDICIAL REVIEW
IF SENATOR ALAN MENTION WOULD
HAVE TO BE REQUIRED TO BE
RESOLVED WITHIN TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY DAYS WE UNDERSTAND IT
ENSURING EQUITY IMPROVING AIR
QUALITY AND PROVIDING
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATIONS AND
ROBUST PUBLIC OUTREACH ARE
ESSENTIAL TOOLS TO SUCCESSFUL
TRANSIT PROJECT DELIVERY
THEY'RE ALSO VITAL ELEMENTS IN
IN SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS.
UNFORTUNATELY COSTLY LITIGATION
DELAYS AND PROJECT THROUGH THE
PROJECT ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PUT APPROVAL PROCESS DELAY
PROJECT DELIVERY AND STALL THE
IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENTS IN
BENEFITS THAT THESE PROJECTS
BRING. OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS
HAS PRIORITIZE THESE PROJECTS
AND FUNDING TO ACCELERATE
MOBILITY IMPROVEMENTS IN L. A.
AS WE PREPARE TO HOST THE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC GAMES WHAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE PROJECTS
WERE NOT REQUIRED AS A PART OF
THE BID TO SECURE THE OLYMPIC
GAMES. THEY WILL HELP TO
ALLEVIATE CONGESTION DUE TO THE
GAME'S IMPROVE ACCESS TWO EVENT.
AND VISITORS TO ENJOY ALL THAT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS TO
OFFER. THE FOR PROJECTS- THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE PASSAGE
OF THE BILL ARE NOT ONLY IN OUR
GOAL TO THIS PLAN THEIR KEY TO
MEETING THE REGION'S AIR
QUALITY GOALS. THESE PROJECTS%
WOULD PRODUCE SIGNIFICANT HARM
OF THE BENEFITS OF THE COUNTY
IN THE REGION INCLUDING
CONGESTION REDUCTION REDUCTION
IN VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. AND
CLEAN GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS. ANY EFFORT TO
EXPEDITE THESE PROJECTS TO SB
FORTY FOUR WOULD BRING THE
REGION CLOSER THESE ANTICIPATED
BENEFITS. AND ALSO HELPS THE
STATE ACHIEVE ITS AGGRESSIVE
CLEAN AIR GOALS. ESTABLISHED IN
THE REGIONS THAT SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES STRATEGY WITH
THAT'LL CONCLUDE AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT- MICHAEL
PIMENTEL AND I JUST WANNA
REMIND THE WITNESSES THAT YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. ALL ALL RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE REPUBLICAN
POLITICS. THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES
STATEWIDE. IN PLEASED TO JOIN
YOU TODAY TO VOICE THAT TRANSIT
INDUSTRY SUPPORT FOR SB FORTY
FOUR INDIAN KURTA COMMITTEE TO
PASS THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
NOPE MISTER TURNER NOTED THIS
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH EXPEDITED
MISTREATED. AND JUDICIAL REVIEW
PROCEDURES UNDER SEE WHAT FOR A
NARROW BAND OF ZERO MISSION
FIXED GUIDEWAY TRANSIT
PROJECTS. THE BILL IS INTENDED
TO CONFRONT AN UNFORTUNATE
TRUTH- ONE ALLUDED TO BY MR
TURNER THAT LARGE SCALE TRANSIT
PROJECTS AT KIRBY. BNP AND THAT
REDUCE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
EMISSIONS OFTEN FACE PEOPLE
BASICALLY GAVE HIM THAT FLOWS
PROJECT DELIVERY. NOW THESE
PROJECTS HAVE THE POWER TO
TRANSFORM REGION TO CREATE GOOD
PAYING JOB THE CONSTRUCTION
TRANSIT OPERATIONS AND TO
CATALYZE ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND
THAT'S- PRECISELY WHY
CONGRESSMAN LEGISLATURE POINTS.
I TO INVEST IN THESE PROJECTS
TO JUMPSTART ENHANCE THE
RECOVERY FROM THE PANDEMIC NOW
BEEN ASSOCIATION OF HISTORY
SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO
STREAMLINE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCESS FOR TRANSIT
PROJECTS. INCLUDING IN LAST
YEAR'S SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN AND
AGAIN WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
SB FORTY FOUR TODAY AGAIN. HER
CHORE I THOUGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. UP NEXT WE WILL GO
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND
WE HAVE TO WITNESSES THAT
REGISTERED- ON KATE. NIDA FROM
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA.AND RICHARD
MARCUSSEN FROM THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
ARE WITNESSES FOR THE CALL YOUR
LINE SHOULD BE- OPEN AND YOU
COULD AND FUTURE LINE NOW. A
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS KATE NEED TO
NOW WITH THE JUDICIAL CASH BAIL
AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED. I WANT TO KNOW IF THE
OUTSIDE THAT- JUDICIAL COUNCIL
NOT TAKING A POSITION ON PEOPLE
ON THE PROJECT AT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES OUR POSITION IS
LIMITED TO THE BILL'S IMPACT ON
THE COURT. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE STAFF EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS AND SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS APPRECIATE HEARING
THAT THE AUTHOR IS PLANNING ON
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE STILL
OPPOSE THE BILL HOWEVER BECAUSE
UNTIL IT IS AMENDED TO REMOVE
THE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAY.
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW
PROVISION- THAT PROVISION.
FIRESTICK WHAT CASE- SOMETHING
TO THIS BILL INCLUDING APPEALED
CONCLUDE. TWO HUNDRED SO MANY
DAYS WHICH NOT I'M REASONABLY
SHORT TIMELINE AND PLACES AN
EXTREME BURDEN. ON THE COURT TO
HAVE ALREADY BEEN IMPACT
IMPACTED BY DEPEND PANDEMIC
THIS TIME WHEN WE WILL PUT
THESE CASES AHEAD OF OTHER
CASES WORKS- PLAINTIFFS ARE
FACING EVICTION ARE AT RISK OF
DYING ARE JUVENILES AND SO
FORTH. SO FOR THOSE REASONS-
DID USUALLY HELPFUL. REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS GOOD
MORNING MADAM. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI THIS
IS RICHARD MARCUSSEN WITH THE
WESTERN ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND LIKE THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE HAVE NARAL
OBJECTIONS TO PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL. SB FORTY FOUR MAYBE A
COMPLETELY LEGITIMATE PUBLIC
POLICY BUT IS THE MEDIA HAS
POINTED OUT RECENTLY AUTHORS
WHO WANT TO ACCELERATE HOUSING.
SEARCHES UNDER ALLEN ARE FORCED
TO ACCEPT AMENDMENTS THAT CAN
SUPPORT THE BEST POLICY
INTENTIONS MAKE CONSTRUCTION
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN ACTUALLY
REDUCE EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR OTHERWISE QUALIFIED
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WHO ARE
FORCED OUT OF WORK BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NOT GRADUATED FROM A-
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. THIS IS BECAUSE THE
CONSTRUCTION UNIONS INSIST ON
LANGUAGE LIKE THAT IN SB FORTY
FOUR THAT MANDATES MINIMUM
GRADUATION RATIOS ELIMINATES
CERTIFIED PAYROLL RECORDS IN
CERTAIN CASES AND BARS THE
STATE LABOR COMMISSIONER FROM
PROTECTING CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
ON CERTAIN PROJECTS. AUTHORS
WHO RESIST THESE PROVISIONS
WILL SEE THEIR BILLS FAIL. AND
ARE SOMETIMES PILLORIED BY THE
PROPONENTS OF SKILLED AND
TRAINED AND THERE'S NEVER BEEN
ANY EVIDENCE THAT THIS POLICY
THAT ORIGINATED WITH REFINERY
TURNAROUNDS. ACTUALLY REDUCES
INJURY IMPROVES QUALITY REDUCES
COSTS EVEN COMES SOME
CONSTRUCTION UNIONS QUESTION
SKILLED AND TRAINED WHICH IS
WHY CARPENTRY MASONRY OPERATING
ENGINEERS AND THEIR RELATED
SUBGRAPHS. CAPPED THEIR
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS 30% AND
TEAMSTERS ARE COMPLETELY
EXEMPT. SUPPORTERS ALTERNATELY
SAY THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
EITHER IMPROVE SAFETY OR
INCREASES LOCAL HIRE ONE
LEGISLATOR EVEN DECRIED SING
VEHICLES WITH MEXICAN LICENSE
PLATES AT SOME CONSTRUCTION
SITES BUT THERE'S ZERO EVIDENCE
TO SUPPORT THESE CLAIMS. IT MAY
BEHOOVE THE LEGISLATURE TO
IMPOSE A MORATORIUM ON NEW
SKILLED AND TRAINED MANDATES
UNLESS AND UNTIL THERE IS
EVIDENCE THAT ADDS VALUE TO
CONSTRUCTION. AT THE VERY LEAST
WE SUGGEST THAT YOU STOP NEW
STATUTES THAT BAR THE STATE
LABOR COMMISSIONER FROM
PROTECTING CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU-
NOW WE'RE READY FOR TESTIMONY
FROM ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN.
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
ALL START WITH ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEN NONE OF
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION I
DON'T SEE ANY MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND WE'RE ASKING
WITNESSES TO JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THIS BILL. HOW YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE AND ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. AND WE DO HAVE SEVERAL UP
PHONE LINES THAT HAVE SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE ARE
TAKE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
TO GET. I JUST WANNA BE CLEAR
HERE I APOLOGIZE. FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN COURT OR
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PARDON ME NO PART
FIRST I FIRST A- PERSON IS NINE
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MODERATOR MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE JOURNEYS THAT YEAR WE
HAVE THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
IT IS YET TO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE. SIXTEEN MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AGAIN DURING ENTRY
WHICH UNDER AND WE SPONSORING
LYING HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN SUPPORT AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL RAIL AUTHORITY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS MUCH ALIKE.
ALSO IN SUPPORT. LINE. FORTY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MATT
ROBINSON ALSO WHICH I GOT INTO
SHELTER LACK OF SAN MATEO
COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT
CALTRAIN AND THE MONTEREY
SALINAS TRANSIT DISTRICT THANK
YOU. LINE SEVENTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
FROM THE TELECOM BY LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
SO MUCH. LINE FORTY SEVEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JOSHUA SHOP
FOR THE SOLANO TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. THERE S
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER C. R. TELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS YET ANOTHER
STREAMLINING PROCESS AND YOU'LL
FIND THAT I AM SUPPORTIVE OF.
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
STREAMLINED PROCESS HE'S SO
THAT PROJECTS THAT OUR PUBLIC
BENEFIT WHICH JUST ABOUT
INCLUDES EVERY PROJECT THAT
GETS BUILT OTHERWISE IT
WOULDN'T BE BILL. GETS DONE- I
DO NOT AGREE WITH A LOT OF YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE ANCILLARY
THINGS THAT ARE IN HERE.
HOWEVER I AGREE WITH THE TRYING
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
BECAUSE THERE'S A PROPOSED
PUBLIC THE TRANSIT PROJECTS
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN HERE ARE.
SUBSTANTIALLY IMPORTANT- TO THE
BETTERMENT OF THAT PEOPLE'S
LIVES THAT LIVE IN THOSE AREAS-
THAT ARE AFFECTED BY THE LACK
OF TRANSPORTATION- HOWEVER I
DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO THINK IT'S
A GREEN LIGHT AND I AGREE. I
DID THAT BECAUSE I THINK THIS
SHOULD BE DONE FOR EVERY
PROJECT. BECAUSE FOR ME- WHEN
YOU LOOK AT A COSTCO THAT GETS
BUILT AND THEN HAS TO GO
THROUGH A THREE YEAR LAWSUIT
PROCESS BECAUSE THE SEQUEL-
THERE THE PUBLIC BENEFIT TO
THAT AREA IT THAT'S BEING LOST
OUR JOBS- AIR QUALITY- WELL YOU
KNOW JUST YOU NAME IT- AND YET.
WE KEEP CARVING OUT FOR
SPECIFIC. SPECIFIC GREEN THINGS
BUT WE DON'T CARVE OUT FOR WE
DON'T CREATE A PROCESS THAT IS
ACTUALLY. BENEFICIAL. TODAY AND
BECAUSE OF THAT BECAUSE IT
STREAMLINES THE PROCESS IS
BROKEN. AND AND I APPRECIATE
YOU RECOGNIZING THAT IT IS
BROKING AND BRING IT TO US. AND
THAT WHILE IT IS KINDA
NARROWED- I THINK ESPECIALLY IN
LA'S CASE RIGHT NOW- WE NEED TO
BE FOCUSED ON NOT GETTING THIS
PROJECT DONE SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING. THE SIMPSONS. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
HEY WE DON'T YET HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE WILL VOTE ON THIS- AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME BUT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MY APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THE
TESTIMONY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I
WILL JUST SAY IT TO THE
GENTLEMAN FROM THE CONTRACT
ASSOCIATION AT THESE ARE.
MASSIVE TRANSIT PROJECT IS NOT
A HOUSING. BILL YOU KNOW I
DON'T DISAGREE WITH SOME OF THE
THINGS HE SAID WITH REGARDS TO
THE- YOU KNOW THE BATTLE
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY OVER OVER
AND- YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE THAT. THAT HAS BEEN
ADDED INTO VARIOUS BILLS BUT
THE THESE ARE. AS WAS MENTIONED
BY THE FOLKS MILLION AFTER
THESE ARE THESE ARE BIG TRANSIT
PROJECTS ALL OF THEM ARE BEING
DONE BY PLA'S- SO- YOU KNOW.
I'M NOT SURE THE HIS COMMISSARY
PLIED TO THE KIND OF THINGS
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE
THIS BILL BUT- RESEARCHER YOUR
RECOGNIZING WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- AND-
RESPECT YESTERDAY BUT WHEN THE
TIME COMES. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TODAY SHOVEL THE NEXT YES NEXT
IS ITEM TWO SB EIGHTY THREE
OKAY THANK YOU. HI THIS IS
ANOTHER BILL- THAT- THIS
RECEIVE STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT- OVER IN THE SENATE-
AND I THINK IT'S IT WAS
RECOGNIZED BY THE SENATOR
GROWTH HI I WAS A BILL THAT IS
PERMISSIVE IT PROVIDES A VERY
INTERESTING TOOL TO CITIES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY REALLY STRUGGLING
WITH- WITH ALL THE POLITICS
ASSOCIATED WITH SEA LEVEL RISE
SO LET ME GET INTO THIS- BUT
LET ME START BY AT A VERY
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION AND MY
ACCEPTANCE OF THE NIGHT OF THE
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED THE
ANALYSIS THE ODD MORE
SPECIFICITY. TO HELP US AROUND
OUT THE PROGRAM AND I THINK
THEY ALSO WHAT I REALLY I WAS
TELLING MY STAFF ACTUALLY I'VE
READ OVER THE MEN'S OF THESE
ARE REALLY GOOD AMENDMENTS
BECAUSE THEY- THEY- PAY FORCE.
ANALYSIS YOU KNOW WE ALREADY
HAVE A LIMIT OF IT BUT IT
REALLY FOCUSES IN ON. THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR- INSURING
THAT THIS DOESN'T LOSE ANY
MONEY. FOR THE STATE OR FOR THE
PUBLIC PURSE THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS. THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH BUYING
A PROPERTY AND ALSO. THE EXTENT
TO WHICH- IT'S PART OF A- OF A
OF A OF A LOCAL REGIONAL PLAN
THAT'S COHERENT AND- IS- COME
MORE COHERENTLY ADDRESSING THE
IMPACTS OF SEA LEVEL RISE SO
WE'RE SEEING SEA LEVEL RISE AS
AN ISSUE. I'VE BEEN DOWN THE
STATE OUR LA TIMES THAT A
FASCINATING- SPECIAL SECTION ON
THIS ISSUE- THE L. A. O.
ESTIMATES AROUND EIGHT TO TEN
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
EXISTING PROPERTIES LIKELY TO
BE UNDER WATER BY TWENTY FIFTY.
WHICH IS WILD TO THINK ABOUT
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN PROPERTY
COULD BE AT RISK OF FLOODING.
BY- TWENTY BY. YEAH TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED IS THAT THE AND HOW WAS
IT- THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS- BOUNCING VERY
LIMITED BUDGETS WITH FEW GOOD
OPTIONS WITH THE NEEDS OF
HOMEOWNERS. SO WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING IS THE YOU HAVE AREAS
THAT ARE ALREADY EXPERIENCING
FLOODING THAT THE C. IS
STARTING TO- TO RISE. AND- THE
MORE FIND A COURSE THAT BUYING
OUT LOCAL RESIDENTS RELOCATING
THEM IT'S BEEN VERY
CONTROVERSIAL IN SOME INSTANCES
COST PROHIBITIVE- SO THERE'S A
LOT OF POLITICS IN THESE TOWNS
THOUGH RIGHT THE LOCAL
HOMEOWNERS COME TO THE CITY
COUNCIL THEY SAY YOU GET USED
TO SPEND EVERY WAKING HOUR
DOING EVERYTHING YOU POSSIBLY
CAN SPENDING EVERY LAST DIME OF
THE CITY BUDGET TO PROTECT MY
HOME AND YOU CAN SEE WHY PEOPLE
DO THAT THIS IS THEIR HOME IF
SOMETHING THAT NEED IS
INCREDIBLY MEANINGFUL TO THEM.
AND CITIES ARE NOW FACED WITH
THESE INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
CHOICES WHETHER HAVING TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN BUIDING PUTTING
MORE MONEY INTO A SEA WALL
WHICH KEEPS COLLAPSING- TO
PROTECT IT A STRETCH OF BEACH
OF THE INSPECTOR HOME'S OR YOU
SEE THAT MONEY GO TO THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT OR TO YOU KNOW THE
PARKS OR OR OR OTHER IMPORTANT
LOCAL SERVICES. SO THIS IS THE
THIS IS THE IN FACT THE TIMES
HAD A LITTLE CHART WHERE YOU
COULD FOLLOW THE DIFFICULT
DECISION MAKING OF A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER TRYING TO
BALANCE THE INTENSE LOCAL
POLITICAL NEEDS YOUR BUDGETARY
NEEDS. IT'S SUCH A- SO WHAT
WITH THE IDEA HERE- IS THAT AND
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THAT THE
COST IN LIVES AND TREASURE THE
COULD HAVE BEEN SAVED OF
CALIFORNIA TAKING MORE ACTION
DECADES AGO. AND TO BETTER
MITIGATE AGAINST- THE THREAD OF
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES. WHAT IF
WE CREATE A FIND. A PERMISSIVE.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THE FINANCING
OPTION. TO ALLEVIATE THE RISKS
OF SEA LEVEL RISE WHILE
PROTECTING BOTH PROPERTY OWNERS
AND TAXPAYERS SO THE IDEA IS
IT'S A REVOLVING LOAN FUND. IT
WITH BASICALLY WOULD GO FOR THE
MONEY WOULD GO TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BUY PROPERTIES
THAT WILL BE THREATENED IN IN A
DECADE OR TWO. ARE THEY CAN
ALLOW THE OWNERS TO SELL WHILE
THE HOUSE STILL HAS VALUE. AND
OF COURSE THESE ARE VERY OFTEN
IS VERY ATTRACTIVE PROPERTIES
RIGHT ON THE WATER. AND THEN
THE GOT THE GOVERNMENT ENTITY
CAN RENT OUT THE PROPERTYREPAYING THE LOAN. IN SOME
CASES POTENTIALLY EVEN EARNING
REVENUE. AND OF COURSE WE GET
ONE OF THE KEY AMENDMENTS AT
THE COMMITTEE ACCESS TO TAKE
WAS THAT WE REALLY DO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S- THERE'S THE OTHER
THIS THAT THE T. THIS PROCESS
WILL GENERATE ENOUGH REVENUE TO
REPAY THE LOAN BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT THIS TO BE A NET LOSS. TO
TAXPAYERS MAYBE IN SOME CASES
IT COULD EVEN BE A GAME. SO
THEN WHEN THE PROPERTY IS THAT
IT RISK. OF OF FLOODING FROM
RISING SEA LEVELS IN THE HOUSE
COULD BE DEMOLISHED OR
RELOCATED. WITHOUT LOCAL
RESIDENTS OR TAXPAYERS DURING
THE COST. AND WITHOUT THE
INCREDIBLE POLITICAL UPHEAVAL.
AND THE AND THE IMPOSSIBLE
SOPHIE'S CHOICES. THAT CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE CURRENTLY
BEING ASKED TO MAKE- IN CITIES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE. TOTALLY
PERMISSIVE. AND WE WERE
STRUCTURE IN A WAY THAT IT
WOULD BE EITHER COST NEUTRAL
OR- OR OR HOPEFULLY A
BENEFICIAL. SO I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY JENNIFER SAVAGE WITH THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION IN
ISABELLA GONZALES POTTER WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF ON BY WE WANNA
SEE PERMISSIVE NOT JUST
PERMISSIVE FOR THE CITY LIGHTS.
BUT NO HOMEOWNER WOULD HAVE TO
DO THIS IF THEY DON'T WANT TO
RIGHTS OF A HOMEOWNER DECIDES
THEY WANT TO STICK IT OUT IN
THEIR HOME THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL ACTUALLY NOTHING IN
THIS BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THEM. TO SELL SO WITHOUT A LEFT
TURN TO MY WITNESSES JENNIFER
AND DIES ABOUT. THANK YOU
SENATOR. OF BEFORE WE- HEAR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- I'D LIKE
TO ASK SECRETARY TO CALL ROLE
WE HAVE A QUORUM. NO WE DON'T.
TWO THREE. FIVE FIVE. NEED SIX
OH I THOUGHT WE NEED TO FIVE
OKAY. OKAY OKAY THEN I WILL DO
THAT. OKAY THEN LET'S A
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
THE SORT OF ON TALIBAN IN THE
POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY- IN AN
EFFORT TO BE A SHORT ON TIME
HERE IN AVOID REDUNDANCIES AND
SENATOR ALAN GIVE US THE TICKET
OPENING ALL TRY TO KEEP MY
REMARKS PRETTY SHORT. OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY STRONGLY
SUPPORTS SB EIGHTY THREE- SOME
INTERESTING STATISTICS THAT I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT IS THAT WITH
THE PACIFIC OCEAN PROJECTED TO
RISE NINE FEET IN SOME COASTAL
AREAS OF CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION. TO PROTECT THE ENTIRE
COAST WE ELEVEN DEPEND ON
WHETHER DEVELOPED OR WILD WE
MUST ALSO HELP OUR COMMUNITY
THE LEVY EIGHT THE RISK OF
RISING OCEAN LEVELS WHILE
PROTECTING BOTH PROPERTY OWNERS
AND NATURE. TNCS RECENT SCIENCE
REPORT SHOWS 55% OF CALIFORNIA
COASTAL HABITAT IN JEOPARDY FOR
SEALABLE RIGHT THAT FIFTY FIVE
PERCENT. WE BELIEVE THAT SB
EIGHTY THREE WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO HELP ADDRESS
THE CLIMATE IMPACTS TO HABITAT
IN THE STATE FUNDING COULD BE
PRIORITIZED TO PROPERTIES THAT
PROVIDE MULTI BENEFITS
INCLUDING PROTECTING COASTAL
HABITAT PROTECTING EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE OR PROTECTING
PARKS AND OTHER OPEN SPACES-
CALIFORNIA MUST ACT TO PROTECT
COASTAL COMMUNITIES FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE IN SB EIGHTY
THREE DEMONSTRATES A NEW
APPROACH TO ADDRESS THE
AUTHORIZED- AND ADDS SENATOR
ALLEN HAS NOTED IT HAD ENJOYED
SOME BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. SO WE
pLEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. FOR THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MADAME CHIANG KAI MEMBERS
JENNIFER. CALIFORNIA POLICY
MANAGER FOR THE THIRD
FOUNDATION. SURFRIDER THE
NONPROFIT OR- THAT TO BEACH
ACCESS AND COOK TO PRESERVATION.
AND AS YOU HAVE HEARD THE
CONSEQUENCES OF FAILING TO
ADAPT IF YOU'LL RIDE TO BE
PROFOUNDLY DAMAGING TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY OUR
COASTAL COMMUNITIES. ARE INLAND
COMMUNITIES RESIDENTS RELY ON
THE BEACH TO ESCAPE SUMMER
HEAT. AND TO OUR MARINE
ENVIRONMENT. INTERCRATER STATED
WITH EACH REPORT CALIFORNIA IS
THE ONLY STATE THAT RENDON AND
BECAUSE OF PRESERVATION
PLANNING. SO WHILE THE STATE
INTENTIONS WITHOUT EMPOWERING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO IMPLEMENT
PROACTIVE ADAPTATION WE WILL BE
WITH OUR BEACHES. EVEN THE MOST
PROACTIVE JURISDICTIONS ARE
CURRENTLY FAR BEHIND WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE THIS IS LARGELY A
RESULT OF NOT HAVING ENOUGH
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO PLAN
APPROPRIATELY. AND WHEN YOU ADD
IN THE OFTEN FRAUGHT NTURE OF
LOCAL POLITICS. IT'S EASY TO
SEE HOW CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
LEFT WITH FEW AGREEABLE OPTIONS
REGARDING HOW TO HELP COOK THE
PROPERTY OWNERS THE JACK IF YOU
LOVE A CONTINUE TO RISE. THIS
RESULT IN CONSTANT CONFLICT
BETWEEN STATE GUIDANCE AND WHAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE WILLING
AND ABLE TO DEAL. SB EIGHTY
THREE WITH ALLEVIATE THE
CONTENT BY ESTABLISHING A FUND
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND
INCREASE THEIR ABILITY TO
STRATEGIZE IN WAYS NECESSARY TO
PRESERVING CALIFORNIA POLITICOS
AND MAINTAINING COASTAL ACCESS
EQUITY INTO THE FUTURE. IT'S A
TRULY FORWARD THINKING BILL IN
A TIME WHEN LONG TERM PLANNING
HAS BEEN IN SHORT BY. PROVIDING
A REAL SOLUTION TO THE T. LEVEL
RIGHT CRISIS WE APPRECIATE
SENATOR ALLEN'S LEADERSHIP AND
URGE YOUR ITEM. ON THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY OF. REGISTER AN
OPPOSITE. BUT WILL NOW TAKE.
I'M TED. FROM WITH. IN SO. OR
OPPOSITION- WILL START ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. I DON'T
SEE ANY ANYONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION. THERE ARE
NONE MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE. FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK FOR GOING TO START WITH
LINE. SIXTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS LAUREN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA COLIN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY THREE
THANK YOU. LINE. TWENTY SEVEN.
HI ONE OF THEM YOU DON'T KNOW
WITHOUT A ONE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY THREE.
GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS THIS
IS JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF THE
STORE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE. SIXTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
CARE MEMBERS PREFER TO TALK ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA IN THE PARK THANK YOU.
FINE. SIXTY EIGHT. HI KAREN
MEMBERS WHO SHALL UNDERTAKE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK PLEASE PRESS
ONE MIN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU. AND NOW BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I DON'T SEE ANY OF NOW
I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
ALL YOU DO I'M SO SORRY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OWN INSURANCE WILL
HAVE A QUICK QUESTION YES SIR
DO YOU SEE ANY- LIKELIHOOD THAT
WE CAN LEVERAGE FEDERAL FUNDING
INTO THIS- ACCOUNT. SETTING UP.
YOU KNOW THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I'M NOT SURE
WE THAT I YOU KNOW- THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION I DON'T HAVE A
GOOD ANSWER FOR YOU YOU HAVE A
GOOD ANSWER. WE HAVE OKAY.
HOPEFULLY WE'RE HOPEFUL. WE'RE
HOPEFUL FROM THE STIMULUS FUNDS
IS THAT WITHOUT THE IDEA. NOW
WE'RE ALSO SO WHAT WHY DON'T
WE- WHEN WE HAVE OUR STATUS OF
CRAP AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT OUR
HOPEFULNESS- AS TO THE FEDERAL
FUNDING AT THE IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
YEAH. CAN I HAVE MURATSUCHI YES
YOU VERY MUCH THE CENTER FOR A-
FRANK THIS PHARMACY WE HAVE OUR
SELF BAY CITY COUNCIL THE
GOVERNMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
WONDERFUL BILL. LIKE TO REQUEST
THAT I BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
YEAH- THANK YOU FOR YOUR BILL
ZERO THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS AND THEN GARCIA THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I THINK MY
QUESTION ALLIANCE- NORTH GOING
STREET TO- IN REGARDS TO THE
FUNDING FOR THIS I UNDERSTAND
THE IDEA AND THE CONCEPT- I AM
WARY OF WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
GET THE FUNDS FOR THIS WE ON
THE COASTAL PROPERTIES ARE
QUITE EXPENSIVE EVEN EVEN IF WE
ARE CONCERNED WITH AND BEING.
COVERED WITH MORE OCEAN. SELL I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY BUT I DO HAVE CAUTIONS ON
THE FUNDING SIDE YET. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA- IT JUST THANK
YOU FOR THE BILL- AND I KNOW
THAT THE FUNDING ISSUE
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
FIGURED OUT BUT IT'S GOOD THAT
WE'RE MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION
AND I THINK IT WE THINK WE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT THIS
ALSO FOR WILDFIRE AREAS I HAVE
A CABIN THAT BRING DOWN OF
RECENTLY IN A WILDFIRE- AND I
DON'T THINK I SHOULD BE BILL
AND IT'S LIKE IT WOULD BE GREAT
IF. IF NO ONE WITH THE HAND AND
THE GOVERNMENT TOOK UP MY LAN I
JUST TOOK IT OUT SO I THINK WE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT SMALL
FEATHER IN OTHER AREASLIKE ON
OUR WILDFIRE PRONE AREAS.
SOMETHING CAN. THANK YOU- WELL
I WOULD TO THANK YOU OF FOUR
EIGHT KNOWLEDGE GENE- HOW MUCH
YOU LIKE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE YES THAT THE COMMITTEE
PROPOSED A FAN- BUT BEFORE- I
LET YOU CLOSE I WANNA GO HEAD
AND- HAVE THE SECRETARY TAKE
THE WORLD OKAY THE- ONE.
MEMBERS RIVAS. I'M HERE RIVAS
HERE FLORA. CHAU CHAU HERE
FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA HERE
MATHIS HERE MATHIS HERE MCCARTY.
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI HERE
SHARE THOUGHT. THEY ARE CHAU
HERE STONE WOULD WOULD HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU SO I'M
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENTS- THE- THE YOU
KNOW THE AS YOU KNOW THE
FINANCING OF COURSE IT'S ALL
GONNA BE IT'S CONSIDERED PART
PREPARATION AS I AS I SAY THE
AMENDMENTS- DO CLARIFY THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THIS TO BE-
PROJECTS THAT WILL GENERATE
ENOUGH REVENUE TO REPAY THE
LOANS- YEAH. SO IN ORDER C. AS
COMMENTS ARE PART SPOT ON OF
COURSE IT RAISES THE BROADER
QUESTION WITHIN OUR HOUSING
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHETHER WE
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING MORE
HOUSING IN THE VERY HIGH. FIGHT
WILDFIRES OWNS- BUT THAT'S A
CONVERSATION FOR ANOTHER DAY SO
WITH THAT I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND-
AND YOUR CO AUTHORSHIP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN. RESPECT FOR US
MATHIS. THANK YOU- I WOULD LIKE
DO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM. I
WILL MOTION FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MURATSUCHI SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY Q.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I AM TO
SB EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR ALAN
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THREE OF US
HI RIVERSIDE FLORIDA. CHAU CHAU
HI FRIEDMAN GARCIA. GARCIA I
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I'D SAY
R. TWO NUMBER SO YOU'RE TELLING
NOT VOTING STONE. WOOD WOOD I.
SIX ZERO SIX ZERO WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
OKAY THANK YOU WELL MY NEXT
FILM YES SB THREE FORTY THREE
TO ME THIS IS THE SECOND ALASKA
AS BEFORE THIRTY THREE ANOTHER
STE A BILL THAT RECEIVE SRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. ON THE
ASSEMBLY IS ON THE SENATE SIDE
AND THERE'S NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION THIS IS A BILL THAT-
WILL IMPROVE OUR COASTAL
COMMISSION'S ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE THE
COASTAL ACT AND PROTECT. OUR
COASTAL WETLANDS STREAMS FOR IS
ENDANGERED SPECIES HABITAT
AGRICULTURAL LAND SCENIC VIEW
SHEDS LOW COST RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. AND SO- YOU KNOW
FOLKS MAY RECALL THAT THE
BECAUSE THE COMMISSION
HISTORICALLY WAS LIMITED IN ITS
ABILITY TO ENFORCE I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE I HAVE
ITEM THREE IS SB THREE FOUR
SORRY I WAS DOING FOR THIRTY
THREE OKAY YEAH I WOULD HAVE
PREFERRED TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT THERE'S THROUGH ALL
THIS YES. OKAY ONCE AGAIN
ANOTHER BILL WOULD OFTEN THIS
ALSO HAD STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THE SENATE THREE FORTY
THREE THE TRUTH IN LABELING FOR
RECYCLING MATERIAL RECYCLABLE
MATERIAL SO LET ME START BY
ACCEPTING THE- THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS- AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
STRONG AND DILIGENT WORK ON THE
BILL. ON THE CHANGES THAT WERE
LISTED I REFLECT ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION. AND THEY HELP US TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
INDUSTRY HAS RAISED SO THIS IS
A IS A SIMPLE MEASURE I KNOW I
KNOW WE'RE ALL SUPPOSED TO WARY
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THAT BUT BUT IT
IS IT IS SO THE IDEA IS THAT
WHEN THE CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS
THE MANUFACTURE FOR MAKING
UNTRUTHFUL ENVIRONMENTAL
CLAIMS- SUCH AS RECYCLABLE IF
AN ITEM IS NOT REALLY
RECYCLABLE IN THE REAL WORLD.
I'M SO YOU CANNOT WRITE THE
WORD RECYCLABLE ON YOUR BOTTLE
IF YA IF THE BOTTLES NOT REALLY
RECYCLABLE AND YET- YOUR FOLKS
YOU RIGHT WE'RE NOT ABLE TO PUT
THE WORD RECYCLABLE ROUTINELY
PUT THE RECYCLING SYMBOL ON
THEIR ITEMS ARE BECAUSE THERE'S
NO PROHIBITION. AGAINST THAT SO
THIS BILL EXTENDS THIS
PROHIBITION TO THE FOR THE USE
OF THE CHASING ARROW. SYMBOL
THAT RECYCLING SYMBOL THAT WE
ALL KNOW. IF THE MATERIALS
RECYCLE AND IT IT OFFERS CLEAR
GUIDED ON WHAT IS. CONSTITUTES
HERE'S THE SAD TRUTH MEMBERS.
ARE LESS THAN 15% OF SINGLE USE
PLASTIC IS ACTUALLY RECYCLED.
IN OUR STATE AND WE ACTUALLY
HAVE RELATIVELY HIGH NUMBERS
COMPARED TO OTHER PLACES- NOW
RECYCLING COSTS ARE NOW EXCUSE
EXCEEDING THE SCRAP VALUE OF
THE PLASTIC MITCHELL ITSELF AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE REALLY
IMPORTANT THINGS. THERE IS SO
MUCH. ARE YOU FOLKS JUST
DUTIFULLY PUT ALL THESE ITEMS
IN THE BLUE BINS HOPING THAT
THESE ITEMS WILL BE RECYCLED.
IT'S CALLED WISH CYCLING. AND
SOMETIMES- YOU KNOW THE OTHER
DUTIES THERE'S FOLLOWING
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE ON THEIR ON
THEIR OF. PLASTIC MATERIALS
THEY SEE THE RECYCLING SYMBOL I
USED TO DO THIS ALL THE TIME I
CAN TELL I LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
THIS. MY NEWSPAPER I STILL READ
THE YOU KNOW THE L. A. TIMES IN
AT MY HOME AND THEY COME IN
THIS LITTLE SLEEVE. AND THERE
WAS A RECYCLING SYMBOL ON
THERE. AND I WOULD ALWAYS
DUTIFULLY SEPARATED OUT AND PUT
IT RIGHT IN MY RECYCLING BIN
BECAUSE IT HAD THE RECYCLING
SYMBOL THERE. I WILL TURNS OUT
THAT'S IT THAT'S A TYPE OF
HIGHLY UNRESECTABLE PLASTIC IT
IS TECHNICALLY RECYCLABLE UNDER
THE BEST OF CONDITIONS AT A
THOUSAND DEGREES AND SOME LAB
IN. IN SAN MARINO BUT- BUT YOU
KNOW THE OTHER DAY IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT RECYCLE THEIR
NOT RECYCLED IN THE REAL WORLD
AND IN FACT THOSE NEWSPAPER
SLEEVES AND- SO MANY EXAMPLES
OF THIS. ACTUALLY AN UPCOMING
UP THE PROCESS. THE END UP-
JAMMING UP THE MACHINES THEY
END UP GETTING STUCK INTO THE
PAPER. THEY ACTUALLY END UP
MAKING THE WHOLERECYCLING
SYSTEM MORE. EXPENSIVE AND LESS
EFFICIENT. AND SO. THAT YOU
KNOW. SO FIRST OF ALL IF A IF
THE MATERIAL IS NOT ACTUALLY
RECYCLABLE THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A WHOLE PROCESS. OUT
THE RECYCLING. AT THE SORTING
CENTERS. IF YOU HAVE A BIT OF
ONE OF THE SENATE BEFORE. LET'S
GO I IT'S A IT'S A I OPENING
EXPERIENCE. AT THE ITEM ACTION
HAS TO BE. PHYSICALLY REMOVED
FROM THE CONVEYOR BELT OUT THE
RECYCLING FACILITY AND THEN OF
COURSE CARTED AWAY. TO A
LANDFILL. I THE EXTRA THIS IS
EXTRA WORK IT INCREASED THE
RECRUITERS WASTE RATES IT. IT
THE COST OF THE PROCESS TRULY
MICHAEL MATERIAL. IT'S ALSO
COURSE CONTAMINATED. THE- THE
EXISTING RECYCLE MUCH OF ONE
REASONS WHY CHINA. DECIDED TO
END- THE IMPORTATION OF A
RECYCLING MATERIAL ESPECIALLY
IN THE AREA PAPER FOR EXAMPLE
IS IT SO MUCH PLASTIC. WAS
GETTING STUCK IN THE PAPER
VEILS- THAT. THAT THE PAPER THE
VALUE OF THOSE PAPER BALLOTS
WAS JUST RENDERED- IS SUCH THAT
IT JUST WASN'T. WORTH THEIR
THEIR RECEIVING THEM ANYMORE.
AND HERE'S THE THING IT'S ABOUT
IT IS ALREADY HITTING YOUR-
CONSTITUENTS. POCKETBOOKS A
SURVEY RELEASED THIS YEAR BY
THE CALIFORNIA CITIES FOUND
THAT MORE THAN SEVEN OF TEN
CITIES ANTICIPATE INCREASING
WASTE COLLECTION RATES BY AS
MUCH AS 20% MEMBERS. TO COVER
THE COST OF MANAGING THE
ADDITIONAL WASTE SIX COUNTY
SACRAMENTO JUST RAISE THEIR
RATES FOR TRASH COLLECTION I
BELIEVE BY LITTLE OVER TEN
DOLLARS NOW ON TOP OF AN
ALREADY. AND IS SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT TEN DOLLARS A MONTH SO
THE STRAIN ON LOCAL RECYCLING
CONSUMERS MISTAKENLY BELIEVE
THAT THE CHASING EURO SYMBOL IT
OFTEN IN CIRCLES THE PLASTIC
RESIN IDENTIFICATION CODE.
MEANS THAT THE PRODUCT IS
RECYCLABLE. HI SO. YOU KNOW. WE
KNOW THAT THAT RECYCLING IS
CONFUSING I'M THERE'S OF THERE
WAS A STUDY THAT WAS TAKEN BY
THE CONSUMER BRANDS ASSOCIATION
THAT THAT FINDS IT MORE. THEY
GIVE IT MERICAN FIND RECYCLING
KNOWING HOW TO RECYCLE WHAT TO
RECYCLE MORE CONFUSING THAN
BUILDING IEA FURNITURE. DOING
THEIR TAXES PLAYING THE STOCK
MARKET OR UNDERSTANDING THEIR
SPOUSE. SO THERE WE ARE WE WANT
TO WE WANT TO CONFORM. THE
RULES. SO THAT IF YOU CAN'T SAY
THAT THE ITEMS RECYCLE IF YOU
CAN'T PRINT THAT IF YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED UNDER OUR- UNDER OUR
RULES TO PRINT PRINT TO PRINT
THAT YOUR ITEM IS RECYCLABLE
BECAUSE IS NOT TRULY RECYCLE IN
THE REAL WORLD YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO SLAP. THE CHASING EURO
SYMBOL THERE. ON TO THAT ITEM.
SO I WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE
HEIDI SANBORN FROM THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL. WHO
ALSO CHAIRS THE STATEWIDE
RECYCLING COMMISSION AND ALSO
MARKET PRAYER. WHO'S HERE FROM
REPUBLIC SERVICES YOU CAN GIVE.
THAT THE GUY ON THE GROUND
EXPERIENCE OF A WASTE HAULER
WHO DEALS. WITH ALL OF THIS.
MESS SO LET'S START WITH. WHAT
PEOPLE. WOULD KNOW THANK IT
WILL GO HEAD START WITH MARK
SINCE HE'S HERE IN THE IN THE
ROOM. ALL RIGHT- MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE US
SENATOR ALAN- WE WANT TO THANK
CENTER ALLEN FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD. AND APPRECIATE
HIS EFFORTS TO MAKE RECYCLING
MORE EFFECTIVE. REPUBLIC
SERVICES- SUPPORTS SB THREE
FORTY THREE A MEASURE THAT IS
AS MUCH ABOUT TRUTH IN
ADVERTISING. AS IT IS ABOUT
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S
RECYCLING SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA'S
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE IS ONE
OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT IN THE WORLD BUT IN
SPITE OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BEING INVESTED. INTO THE SYSTEM
AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO IMPROVE
RECYCLING CONTAMINATION REMAINS
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT AND
EXPENSIVE OBSTACLES.
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS HAVE
BEEN MADE AN EXTENSIVE MANUAL
SORT LINES OPTICAL SORTER
SCREEN SHREDDER'S BLOWERS AND
OTHER ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND THEIR
LOCAL HAULERS SPEND HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY
EDUCATING CONSUMERS. ON WHAT IS
RECYCLABLE IN AN EFFORT TO
IMPROVE RECYCLING RATES AND
REDUCE CONTAMINATION RECYCLING
COSTS. WITH THOSE DOLLARS ARE
WASTED IF PACKAGING- MATERIAL
INCLUDING MARKINGS THAT FALSELY
CLAIM THOSE PACKAGES OR
MATERIALS ARE RECYCLABLE. FALSE
CLAIMS OF RECYCLABILITY CONFUSE
CONSUMERS WHO ALREADY STRUGGLE
IDENTIFYING CORRECTLY WHAT
SHOULD BE PLACED IN THE
RECYCLING BIN I'M SURE ALL OF
YOU HAVE YOUR OWN EXPERIENCE-
AS WELL AS EXPERIENCE WITHIN
YOUR FAMILIES. SENATE BILL FIVE
THREE FORTY THREE IS FINAL
MENTALLY ABOUT TRUTH IN
ADVERTISING DON'T CLAIM YOUR
PACKAGE OR MATERIAL IS
RECYCLABLE ON THERE UNLESS
THERE IS AN ACTUAL RECYCLABLE
RECYCLING MARKET FOR THE
MATERIAL. AND IT CAN BE READILY
AND EFFECTIVELY REMOVED FROM
THE WASTE STREAM. CENTER ALLEN
TOOK MY EXAMPLE IN TERMS OF
PLASTIC FILM- THOSE ARE
REPEATED WITH OTHER KINDS OF
CONTAINERS AND SOLID WASTE THAT
CLAIM TO BE RECYCLING BUT IN
FACT OR NOT. SB THREE FORTY
THREE CENTS AN EFFECTIVE IN
CLEAR STANDARD FOR
RECYCLABILITY THE WILL INCREASE
RECYCLING EFFICIENCIES IMPROVE
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IN
RECYCLING AND WILL REDUCE
RECYCLING RATES FOR RATE PAYERS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND
RECYCLING. WE THANK YOU CENTER
ALLEN AND WE URGE I DON'T.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE HEIDI
SANBORN ON THE LINE MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR HIGH MISS SAMPARK. THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
HEIDI SANBORN AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL A NONPROFIT THAT
ADVOCATES FOR CIRCULAR ECONOMY
AND A CO SPONSOR OF A THREE
THREE FOUR THREE. I ALSO HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS
CHAIR OF THE STATEWIDE
COMMISSION ON RECYCLING MARKETS
AND CURBSIDE RECYCLING A GROUP
OF SEVENTEEN DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS TO REPRESENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WASTE HAULERS AN
NGO. BUT IF CLASS WAS PROVIDING
ADVICE THE STATE ON HOW TO
REDUCE CONTAMINATION IN OUR
RECYCLING SYSTEM. THE
COMMISSION RELEASED THE
PRELIMINARY REPORT LAST
DECEMBER WITH NINETEEN
UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE OF WHICH
RECOMMENDS TRUTHFUL LABELING TO
REDUCE CONSUMER CONFUSION AND
THE RESULTING CONTAMINATION.
THE CHICKEN THERE- SYMBOL IS
UNIVERSALLY UNDERSTOOD TO
SYMBOLIZE RECYCLABILITY THE
COMPANIES ARE CURRENTLY PUTTING
THE SYMBOL ON TOPICS THAT
CANNOT BE RECYCLED. THIS
CREATES CONFUSION AND LYFT
WHICH CYCLING RESULTING IN
CONTAMINATION IN THE SYSTEM AND
INCREASED. COSTS THAT ARE BORNE
BY RATEPAYERS. ACCORDING TO
CONSUMER SO. PRESENTED REUSE.
AND CONFUSED REPORT ON THE FOR
FIRST I U. S. RESPONSE SAID
THAT RECYCLING IS NOT CONFUSING.
CONSUMERS WANT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING BUT THEY FEEL LIKE THEY
WHEN THEY LEARNED THAT SOME
PRODUCTS THE PACKAGING
VERIFICATION ELIGIBLE AND ARE
NOT RECYCLABLE AND THEY GET MAD
AT GOVERNMENT FOR ALLOWING THE
COMPANIES USE THE FOOTPATH
DECEPTIVE LABELING. I THINK
THREE FOUR THREE WILL STOP
MISLABELING AND ALLOW CONSUMERS
TO MAKE INFORMED PURCHASING
DECISIONS BASED ON THE
RESPECTABILITY OF THE ITEMS
THEY PURCHASE. LASTLY WE ALL
AGREE THAT NATIONAL HARMONIZE
RULES ON LABELING WOULD BE
BEST. HOWEVER CALIFORNIA SHOULD
NOT BE HELD BACK BY OTHER
STATES THAT ALLOW PEOPLE USING
AND MISLEADING LABELING.
CALIFORNIA'S DEMAND AND DESERVE
THE TRUTH AND CALIFORNIA
MUDSLIDE AND WE HOPE TO SET THE
STANDARD FOR THE NATION. THAT'S
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION A
NATIONAL SEARCH ACTION COUNCIL
COMMITTED TO HELPING INDUSTRY
CREATE HARMONIZATION. BUT WE
ALL THE FIRE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I'M NEXT WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES REGISTERED TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE LAUREN
AGUILAR FROM AMERICAN AND THE
FLEXIBLE PACKAGING ASSOCIATION
AND SHANNON CRAWFORD FROM THE
PLASTICS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
MODERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR THEM. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SHANNON
CRAWFORD AND I'M WITH THE
PLASTICS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
WE REPRESENT LIKE THE ENTIRE
SUPPLY CHAIN FROM PLASTIC
MANUFACTURING IN THE UNITED
STATES WHICH COVERS OVER SIXTY
ONE THOUSAND COPIES IN
CALIFORNIA. ABILITIES PRIMARY
FOCUS OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
FIFTEEN. MEMBERS ARE INTENT ON
USING RECYCLED CONTENT IN
CREATING AND MARKET A LOT LESS
MATERIAL GOING TO LANDFILL. I
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERNS IT'S ESTATE THREE
FORTY THREE BECAUSE ALTHOUGH
UNINTENDED IT WILL RESULT IN
LESS RECYCLING AND. MATERIAL
FILLING THE LAND. PLEASE HAS
STARTED AND CONVERSATION ON THE
RIGHT NOT GONNA. CARD OR THE
REST. THE CURRENT STANDARD
DICTATE NICO SHOULD BE IN HIGH
TRYING. DESPITE IN. ON BONNELL
BRIDGES THINK YOU HOURS. I'M
FOR. THIRTY EIGHT SO WHAT PART
OF THE CODE BE PLACED INSIDE
THREE CHASING. CREATING
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
CONSUMER CONFUSION. I THINK
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING EFFORTS
AT LEAST THIRTY. TO FOLLOW
CALIFORNIA'S LEAD. AN UPDATE
CURRENT. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHORED WHICH ALLOW
MEMBERS. HI FI UPDATE THEM ALL.
UNDER SOME PARTICULAR AMENDMENT
THEY ARE VERY CONCERNED
REGARDING THE- LANGUAGE OF THIS%
LEGISLATURE. WELL THE THIRD
SUPPORT TO REDUCE CONTAMINATION
WE CANNOT SUPPORT THREE THREE
BECAUSE THE CRITERIA OUTLINED%
TO DETERMINE RECYCLABILITY IS
SEVERELY RESTRICTED. USING THAT
CRITERIA ONLY PEACHY IN HDPE
BOTTLES WOULD BE ACCEPTED AFTER
CYCLE ACROSS EIGHT. PTP ONE
PACKAGE SO MUCH OF CALIFORNIA'S
FRESH PRODUCE WOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED RECYCLABLE AND
NEITHER WOULD PROBABLY PROBABLY
MUCHAS MATERIAL QUALITIES WHICH
MAKE IT CONFIRM RENDON
PROVIDING. IF YOU THINK YOU ARE.
YEAH OMMITTEE WE PASSED AB
FOURTH EIGHT. REQUIRED MUCH
MICHAEL. CONTACT FORM HOWEVER
THE BEFORE YOU GET IN THOSE
NUMBER THANK AND IT WOULD ALL
BE. MAKING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF AB FOUR. ALL WE DON'T. CAN
ONLY BE ACHIEVED FINANCES UNDER
AND- REPORTS OUR IF I JUST BUT
MAY IT NEXT MONTH. TO DEVELOP
MARKET MATURE NOT RESPECTFUL
DAY ONE. CURRENT WRITTEN SB
THREE POINT THREE ONE OFTEN
MORTGAGE THAN WE SOMETHING
TWENTY FIVE HOWEVER WE WILL
FORWARD TO CONTINUED WORK WITH
SENATOR WENT BACK ON. MAKE THE
WORK AND HELPING NOT HIT IT THE
FACT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BORN
ACTOR AND I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING AMERICAN WHICH IS
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE FOR
PACKAGING AND THE ENVIRONMENT
AND FTA THE FLEXIBLE PACKAGING
ASIAN BOTH APPROPRIATIONS
REPRESENT PACKAGING MATERIAL
SUPPLIERS PACKAGING PRODUCERS
AND CONSUMERS THAT COMPANIES I
AM TESTIFYING TODAY IS
CONCERNED BUT AT THE THREE
FORTY THREE. MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE WORKING TO INCREASE
THE RECYCLING IN THE REUSE OF
THEIR PACKAGING WHAT YOU KNOW
WITH THE GOAL OF THE AUTHOR
GOLDIS COMMITTEE ANIMAL
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO WANT MORE
PACKAGES TO BE RECYCLED BUT AT
THE END OF THE FIFTEEN EIGHTY
THREE COMMISSION LIST OF
RECYCLABLE ONLY FIFTEEN
MATERIALS MAY SELECT WHICH
CONSISTS OF EIGHT PAPER
MATERIAL TO TOUCH THE GLASS YOU
TYPE OF METAL DETECTOR PLASTICS
AND ONE TYPE OF CULT CLASSIC.
BASED ON THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
OF SB THREE FORTY THREE WEEKS
BACK OUR FACULTY REGENT SIMILAR
AN EXTREMELY LIMITING WHAT
IT'LL HAVE RESOUNDING IMPACT ON
THE ABILITY OF THE STATE TO
REACH THEIR 75% DIVERSION GOALS
AND HINDER THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE. CIRCULAR ECONOMY
SOLUTIONS PACKAGING. CURRENTLY
STATES WERE. THAT AGAIN. CODE
FIRST PLASTIC. THE LOCATE
INSIDE SHE EUROPE AND ALL. AT
THREE THREE FORTY WOULD MAKE
UNLAWFUL FOR MATURE NOT ON THE
RECYCLE IT HAPPENS. WHICH WOULD
FORCE TO THE OUTCOME WITH STATE
IN IN THE END MANDATING
CALIFORNIA ONLY PACKAGING
PRODUCTS. SO WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING- WE HAVE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH DOCTOR
DOCTOR TO SEND THE EFFECTIVE
DATE OF THE BILL IN ORDER FOR
INDUSTRY TO WORK ON GETTING
OTHER STATES LATE LAWS CHANGE.
BY MEMBERS WON'T HAVE
CONFLICTING PACKAGING
REQUIREMENTS WOULD YOU WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR THOSE AMENDMENTS
ARE LAID OUT OUT THIS IS A
POSITIVE CHANGES AND WE KNOW
THERE ARE MORE CHANGES TO COME
TO GET. TO CREATE A SOLUTION
THAT WILL POP CONTAMINATION IN
THE CURBSIDE CAN HELP MARKET
YOUR- CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT
AND I LOOK FORWARD. TO THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATION DROP OFF.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO
TESTIMONY FROM WITNESSES. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- WILL BE
TAKING NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM. OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M ALEXIS CHáVEZ WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE WE
ARE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HEY ANY WITNESSES IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION I SEE
NONE OF THE MODERATOR KEEP
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK MADAM CHAIR.
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. I'M GONNA GO TO LINE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
TIFFANY MARC ON BEHALF OF THE
OCEAN CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FOUR THREE. LINE SIXTY
FIVE. HI THIS IS LAUREN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORTER
SB THREE FORTY THREE THANK YOU.
LINE. EIGHTY THREE. HI JAMIE
GOT ON BEHALF OF MY STORE AND
SUPPORT. BY. FORTY NINE. THANK
YOU TURN NUMBER THREE IF YOU
HAVE CRAPPIE BUT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
TRANSPORT SHE- NINE SEVENTY
ONE. MAKES ONE SEVENTY WONDER
WHY THIS OPEN. IF. HELLO BY
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND PARDON ME WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO LINE EIGHTY SEVEN. THE
MORNING CARE NUMBERS PERSONAL
KID OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL AND STOP WAIT IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY FOUR THREE
THANK YOU. FINE. NINETY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING- GENEVIEVE AVEDON
ON BEHALF OF THE ELEVEN CLEAN
SEAS LOBBYING COALITION MEMBERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY THREE THANK YOU. LINE
NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS JORDAN WELLS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND VARIOUS
STUFF IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FOUR THREE THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
THE COOKING OF ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS THE COMPLETION OF THE
PET FOOD INSTITUTE WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT FACTORS TAKEN- BUT
PART THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY
EIGHT. THE MORNING CARE NUMBERS
FOR JIM MCKAY ON BEHALF OF
SEVENTH GENERATION AND RETHINK
WASTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE NINETY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEEON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. LINE. FIFTY FIVE. FINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU THIS IS CATHERINE DOG
THE ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT SOMEWHERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY
FOUR. I NEED TO SHARE WITH ME
HM A CREATIVE INNOVATION CENTER
FOR SUSTAINABILITY WE BUILT A
RECYCLING CHALLENGE ART
INSTALLATION AND WE ARE VERY
MUCH IN STRONG SUPPORT BECAUSE
84% THOUGHT THAT QUESTION WRONG
ON THE CHASING ARROWS EVERYBODY
THOUGHT ANYTHING WITH THE
CHASING ERA CAN BE RECYCLED. SO
WE ARE VERY MUCH IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
FOURTEEN GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JOHN TO THE FLOTATION OF
HOME A PARTS MANUFACTURER
LEADER OPPOSED OR COMMENDED
THANK YOU. LINE. SEVENTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THIS IS ME
NOW LEYVA ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF THOUSAND OAKS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. BY NINETY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING JERRY VETS AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS NEIL AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE SURFRIDER FOUNDATION WE
AREN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FOUR THREE THANK YOUNG.
LINE. NINETY NINE. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MICHAEL RATNER ON
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY SOUTH
PLAN LEGISLATIVE ALLIANCE AND
THREE FIFTY THOUGHT THEY WALKED
ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWENTY THREE. THANK LINE. ONE
HUNDRED. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER THE CHAIR NUMBER
EXCUSE ME DON CAPS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO
WITHIN A PUBLIC DOCUMENT A
POSITION WE DO APPRECIATE THEM
ON THE PLATFORM OF FOR TO
CONTINUE. TO WORK WITH THE OP
RESPONSES YEAH. LINE. TWENTY
TWO. THIS IS JAN DEL A
REGISTERED CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL CHEMICAL ENGINEER
AND FOUNDER OF THE LAST BEACH
CLEAN UP I SUPPORT SB THREE
FORTY THREE BECAUSE IT WILL
BRING THE INNOVATION WE NEED TO
GET TO TRULY SUSTAINABLE
SOLUTIONS THANK YOU. FINE ONE
ZERO THREE ONE HUNDRED GREAT.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CHERYL
AUGER AND I BEAT THE BAN SINGLE
USE PLASTIC GROUP AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. WE
FORTY THREE THE TRUTH IN
RECYCLING RECYCLABLE LABELING
DEL. BUYING. NINETY SIX. HI MY
NAME IS BRANDON CONTRARY TO
LONG BEACH AND I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER SB TWO FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU. FINE. THIRTY NINE.
BY THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND WE'RE GOING TO INVITE
ONCE AGAIN ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK FOR AGAINST THIS
LEGISLATION TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO AND WE HAD A
COUPLE MORE WHO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE.
SEVENTY ONE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR JOHNSON CLAIMED THAT THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO IMPORT. LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN. HI MY
NAME IS JULIE MILLETT AND WITH
RICHARD WATSON ASSOCIATES AND
I'M STRONG SUPPORT. IN JUST A
MOMENT. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ALISON
SLEEK WITH ZERO WASTE SAN DIEGO
AND THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCE
RECOVERY ASSOCIATION CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY THREE TRUTH IN LABELING.
AND ONCE AGAIN ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO COMMENT ENFORCEMENT
SUPPORT OR AGAINST THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU- NEXT WILL TAKE QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
I THINK ACTUALLY JUST A COMMENT
AND IF THE BILL HASN'T BEEN
WILLING TO MOVE THE BILL I DO
APPRECIATE IT WORK I HAVE A LOT
OF INTEREST IN THE DEFINITION
OF RECYCLING THESE LABELS ARE
MISLEADING. AND I WANT TO
INCREASE OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU I KNOW YOU
HAVE AN OPEN OFFICE AND I
APPRECIATE THE IMMENSELY DAN I
DO BELIEVE. OF REAL CONCERNS
CAN BE ADDRESSED AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THERE WAS A COMMENT
ABOUT THIS BILL LEADING TO MORE
STEPPING LANDFILL THE REALITIES
AT ALL MOST OF THE STUFF IS
ALREADY BEING LANDFILLS OR
BEING BURNED ARE BEING SHIPPED
OUT OR PRETENDING RECYCLING.
OUT THERE AND SO THAT'S A FALSE
NARRATIVE THAT WE NEED TO GET
BEYOND IT WOULD REALLY WANT TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM AND SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK I'M HOPEFUL
THAT WE CAN GET THERE. AND I'LL
BE TRACKING THIS ALONG THE WAY
BUT AT THINKING JUST AGAIN WANT
TO STRONGLY ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO
HAVE A REAL DISCUSSION OF ABOUT
THE SITUATION THAT WE HAVE OUT
THERE 90% OF STUFF IS NOT BE
RECYCLED CAN'T BE RECYCLED AND-
A CAT. IF WE HAVE WE WILL HAVE
TO KNOWLEDGE SHE IT WOULD HAVE
A MARKET OR DIFFICULTY DOES NOT
FIT WITHIN OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
CLEAN ENERGY OR LIKE CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS IT'S NOT
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE COULD USE
AND WE NEED TO BE TAKING ALL
THAT INTO ACCOUNT AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S RECYCLABLE
AND HAVING A REAL CONVERSATION
WITH. THE. COMMUNITY MEMBERS
OUT THERE. THANK YOU. YES YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- I I'VE
FASCINATED BY THE OPPOSITION
ARGUMENT HERE A SOME OF THEM
AND- I KNOW YOU'RE WRKING WITH
THEM IN A CRISPY SHEET THAT-
YEAH I WAS I AM ALWAYS DILIGENT
ABOUT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OKAY.
HOW HOW WHERE THINGS ARE
SUPPOSED TO GO IN AND TRY TO DO
THE RIGHT THING AND THE
REALIZATION THAT THAT A LOT OF
THESE PLASTICS ARE SIMPLY NOT
RECYCLABLE. IS REALLY REALLY
FRUSTRATING FOR PEOPLE TRYING
TO DO THE RIGHT THING. I GUESS
WHAT I FOUND INTERESTING ABOUT
THE OPPOSITION ARGUMENT WAS
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO LABEL
SOMETHING DIFFERENT FOR
CALIFORNIA. THEN OTHER STATES
AND I WOULD JUST SAY WHY DON'T
YOU JUST DO THE RIGHT THING AND
LABEL IT LIKE WE DO IN
CALIFORNIA AND STOP BEING
DISINGENUOUS WITH OTHER STATES.
GO TO ONE SYSTEM WE'RE GONNA
WITH THIS IS GOING TO BE WELL
VETTED WE KNOW WHAT CAN BE
RECYCLED NOT WHEN WE JUST DO
ONE SYSTEM. AND HAVE EVERYBODY
ADOPTED THEN YOU WON'T HAVE TO
FIGHT LEGISLATION IN EVERY
STATE. JUST BITE THE BULLET AND
DO IT RIGHT THANKS AND I WOULD
LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR THROUGH
THIS BILL NOTHING. YES
MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU I WANT TO
ECHO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOODS
COMMENTS- ANOTHER EXAMPLE FOR
CALIFORNIA SHOULD LEAD THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY IN TERMS OF.
TRUTH AND RECYCLING- YOU KNOW
THIS IDEA OF WISHFUL RECYCLING
IS A CONSTANT- THE SUBJECT OF
DEBATE BETWEEN MYSELF AND MY
WIFE. YOU KNOW SHE'S A HOME
WHERE WE'RE ALWAYS TALKING
ABOUT THE YOU KNOW HER FAVORITE
WORD IS RECYCLE RECYCLE
ANALYSTS JUST A- YOU KNOW A-
PUT THIS IN THE RECYCLING BIN
WHERE YOU KNOW I. AM AFRAID I
AM ALWAYS JOKING THAT SHE'S
GOING TO PUT ME IN THE
RECYCLING BIN SUNDAY. BUT YEAH.
YOU'RE MORE COMPOST. IT'S WHAT
AND- ACTUALLY GREAT BILL AGAIN
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS FAR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY OUR TALK.
SORRY IT ON THE I THINK
RECYCLING IS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE BIGGER CHALLENGES WE HAVE
NATION. AND PART OF IT IS
BECAUSE OUR APPROACH USED TO
BE. THE STAFF WE DON'T WANT TO
RECYCLE OR DON'T WANT TO
DEVELOP THE TECHNOLOGY RECYCLE.
WE JUST SHIPPED OTHER NATIONS
AND HOPE THAT THEY WOULD DO
SOMETHING WITH IT- AND THEY DID
THEY PUT IT IN THE OCEAN SOON
THEN FLOATED BACK ON THE OTHER.
THAT'S RIGHT- SO WE'VE KIND OF
LEARNED FROM THAT BUT- IN
ORDER. FOR ME LOOKING THAT
ENTIRE RECYCLING THING AND I'M
GLAD TO SEE THE WASTE INDUSTRY
IS FINALLY REPRESENTED. IN IN
THIS CONVERSATION BECAUSE IN
THE PAST WE'VE DONE SOME
LEGISLATION. THAT THEY WERE
ABSOLUTELY EXCLUDED FROM AND
NOW WE HAVE LEGISLATION THAT
WE'RE HAVING A HARD TIME- IN
ACTING BECAUSE THEY ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF IT AND WE JUST
DON'T HAVE. THE CAPACITY. OR
THE- TECHNOLOGY TO DOA
CONFLICT WHAT WE WANTED TO
ACCOMPLISH. BUT ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS IS. SO YOU KNOW THE
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE THIS
PACKAGING YOU KNOW THAT THE
LABELING REQUIREMENTS AND
THINGS. IS THE ISSUE THAT IT'S
SIMPLY NOT. ARE RECYCLABLE OR
REUSABLE OR IS IT THAT. THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S REQUIRED IS
NOT NECESSARILY- YEAH IS COST
EFFECTIVE AND THEREFORE WE
DON'T USE IT- BECAUSE OTHER
STATES MAY FIND IT IS COST
EFFECTIVE FOR THEM AND THEY ARE
USING IT AND THEY DO HAVE A WAY
OF TAKING SOME OF THE THINGS WE
CONSIDER NOT TO BE RECYCLABLE.
AND RECYCLING AND RE USING
THOSE MATERIALS AND BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL OF ARE ALSO
IN CALIFORNIA IF WE'RE GOING TO
SEPARATE OURSELVES FROM
EVERYONE ELSE- THERE'S A COST
TO DOING THAT AND THAT COST IS
ADDED ON TO THE COST OF. LIVING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
ALREADY HIGHER THAN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PLACES. AND THAT COST
IS BORN- ESPECIALLY BY. YEAH
YEAH YOU COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ARE- PREDOMINANTLY POOR. AND
THEREFORE DON'T REALLY HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO KEEP SPENDING MORE
AND MORE MORE ON ON ON ON THEIR
ON THEIR FOOD. SUPPLIES SO YOU
KNOW THOSE ARE A COUPLE THINGS
THAT CONCERN ME IS IT MAYBE YOU
CAN ADDRESS THE FIRST ONE
ABOUT- WHAT OTHER STATES ARE
DOING. THAT WE MAY NOT BE
DOING- SO WE CAN'T WE CONSIDER
SOMETHING RECYCLABLE NOT
RECYCLABLE WHILE THEY DO. YEAH
SO. AND THEN I'D LOVE IT IF YOU
COULD COULD. YOU HAVE REPEAT
THAT THAT. THAT EQUITY QUESTION
YES AT THE END BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW THAT I. FULLER ABOUT THE
FIRST QUESTION. I'M SO. THAT WE
YOUR CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY DOES
HAVE ONE OF THE BEST SYSTEMS-
IT'S A COMBINATION OF SEVERAL
FACTORS IN. LARGELY THE SECOND
WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS
OF. COST EFFECTIVENESS- AND
THEN OF COURSE AND MARKETS
RIGHT SO THAT THEY GO HAND IN
HAND IF YOU CAN'T FIND IN A
MARKET TO SELL THE PRODUCTS
AND- YOU COULD SPEND VERY
LITTLE ON RECYCLING AND IT
STILL ISN'T GOING TO PENCIL
OUT. RIGHT SO YOU'VE GOT IT YOU
GOT IT YOU GOT TO STRIKE A
BALANCE HERE. AND IN THE END OF
THE DAY- THE MOST OF THE ITEMS
THAT HAVE THE RECYCLING SYMBOL
WITH THE THREE THREE SEVEN.
NUMBER IN THE MIDDLE. MOST OF
THEM ARE TECHNICALLY RECYCLABLE
UNDER UNDER PERFECT CONDITIONS-
BUT FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
IT'S JUST THEY ARE NOT BEING
RECYCLED- IT IT IT'S ULTIMATELY
IT'S AS YOU SAY IT'S A
COMBINATION OF. OF COST
EFFECTIVENESS TECHNOLOGY AND
MARKETS. I'M YEAH THE SORTING
SYSTEM. OBVIOUSLY IF WE HAD
SOMETHING MORE COMPREHENSIVE I
MEAN YOU KNOW FOLKS MAY KNOW
THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH A
NUMBER OF YOU ONE ON UP ON A
BROADER PLAY IN THIS AREA WITH
SB FIFTY FOUR. FIVE AND THE
IDEAS WITH THAT BILL THAT WE
WOULD HAVE JUST. MORE
SUSTAINABLE PRODUCTS IN THE
SYSTEM WRIT LARGE AND THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY HELP TO. TO
CHANGE OUR SYSTEM SAYS THAT
THERE. IS SUCH THAT WE WOULDN'T
HAVE. QUITE THE SAME SORTING.
AND RESTRUCTURING I CHALLENGES
THAT THEY CURRENTLY MAKE SO
MUCH OF RECYCLING COPS COST
PROHIBITIVE- BUT WE DO HAVE ONE
OF THE BEST SYSTEMS IN THE
COUNTRY- YOU KNOW. THE I
HAVEN'T. BEEN PRESENTED WITH A
CASE WHERE THERE'S ANOTHER
STATE THAT HAPPENS TO HAVE A
VERY EFFECTIVE RECYCLING SYSTEM
FOR A PARTICULAR RESIN TYPE.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE. THAT THIS
WOULD JAM UP. I'M I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO IF THERE IS A CASE OF
LIKE THAT MAYBE WE CAN FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO ENSURE THAT.
BECAUSE I THINK I WANT TO DO IS
JAM UP A GOOD. RECYCLING SYSTEM
THAT MIGHT EXIST IN ANOTHER
STATE MAYBE THERE'S A WAY WE
COULD. YOU TWEAK THAT TWEET THE
BILL TO ACCOMMODATE THAT WE DO
HAVE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL IN
ITS ITS ALLUDED TO ON PAGE TWO
OF THE ANALYSIS WHICH- INVOLVES
THESE THE- YOU KNOW IF A
PRODUCER. CAN COME FORWARD.
WITH THAT WITH SOME SORT OF
PLAN- IF THEY IF THEY FEEL AS
THOUGH- YOU KNOW THAT THERE
THERE IS AN EMERGING MARKET FOR
EXAMPLE IN ONE OF THESE OTHER
RESIN TYPES. THAT HASN'T BEEN
COVERED- BY THE BILL THEY CAN
COME FOR WITH THE PLAN TO WORK
WITH CAL RECYCLE TO GET. TO GET
IT INCLUDED- SO THERE IS
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE OFFER BUT
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THAT THE YEAR THE- THE ITEMS
ARE REALLY BEING RECYCLED I
MEAN BECAUSE ONLY- GARCIA'S
ABSOLUTE RIGHT THIS IDEA THAT
SOMEHOW THIS IS GOING TO LEAD
TO MORE LANDFILLING. THE FACT
IS ALL THIS ALL THIS THAT IS
GOING TO LANDFILL ANYWAY AND IF
ANYTHING ALL IT'S DOING IS
MAKING IT LESS LIKELY. FOR THE
ONES AND TWOS THAT REALLY ARE
RECYCLABLE. THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GETTING PROPERLY SORTED AND
RECYCLED. AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
SAD REALITY AND DONE ONE OF THE
THINGS ABOUT RECYCLING YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU GO TO A RECYCLING
CENTER WHEN YOU GO TO ADOPT.
YOU REALIZED THAT THE YOU KNOW
YOU CAN SPEND SO MUCH TIME.
JUST YOU'RE PERFECTLY CLEANING
UP THEY'RE PEOPLE WHO WASH ALL
THEIR AYE. BEFORE THEY PUT IN
THE RECYCLING. TO THE CHANCE
RECYCLE. IN AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING TO DO BUT- YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU GO TO THIS WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU GO AND SEE THE SYSTEM WRIT
LARGE YOU SEE HOW IT'S ALL. O
THE CONVEYOR BELT TOGETHER. AND
THERE'S JUST. THESE THESE
MACHINES AND MAGNETS AND PEOPLE
SORTING AND IT'S A IT'S A BALK
SYSTEM- AND- YOU KNOW. IT'S IT
IS TRUE THERE WILL PROBABLY BE
A COUPLE LITTLE ITEMS THAT WILL
NOT GET RECYCLED THAT WE'RE
GONNA GET RECYCLED UNDER- IF AS
A RESULT THIS BILL PASSING BUT
THE FACT OF MATTER IS THE
SYSTEM IS SO MASSIVE ITSELF
MACRO. ON ALL THOSE ITEMS THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE
THREE THREE SEVENS ARE NOT
GETTING RECYCLED AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY MAKING IT HARDER TO
RECYCLE THE ONES AND TWOS IF WE
HAVE IF WE ARE IF OUR GOAL IS.
ZERO WASTE AND RECYCLING
EVERYTHING THEN THE
TECHNOLOGIES FOR THOSE HAVE TO
BE EMPLOYED IN OPEN WHEN
THERE'S NO MARKET FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY. THAT'S WHEN
GOVERNMENT HAS TO STEP IN IF
THAT'S THE IF IT'S IF IT'S THAT
IMPORTANT FOR THE- PUBLIC. TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT I DO I WE
NEED TO STOP SKIRTING AROUND
THAT PART. WELL IN THAT POLICY
HAS TO BE DEALT WITH SOME I
APPRECIATE YOU ANSWERING THE
QUESTION YOU DID ANSWER THAT
ONE QUESTION WHICH IS YES
THERE'S A LOT OF RECYCLE STUFF
THAT WE JUST. CHOOSE NOT TO.
ADD BASIC WHAT I WILL SAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS. TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN. RIGHT IF WE DO
WANNA RECYCLE EVERYTHING. THE
PRODUCERS SHOULD BE SHIFTING TO
THE HIGHLY RECYCLABLE RESIN
TYPES RIGHT. SO THERE ARE LOTS
AND LOTS OF PRODUCTS THAT COULD
JUST AS EASILY BE MADE WITH A
THREE AS WITH THE ONE. AND
THERE ARE EXAMPLES OF PRODUCERS
WHO HAVE SHIFTED FROM A ONE TWO
OR THREE. SIMPLY FOR AESTHETIC
REASONS. AND THAT DECISION.
RENDERS THAT ITEM NON
RECYCLABLE JUST LIKE THAT. WE
SHOULD BE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN. TO INTO TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE TO ENCOURAGE
PRODUCERS. WHO ARE IN THE
PLASTIC SPACE TO BE. PRODUCING
THEIR PRODUCTS USING THE ONES
AND TWOS. WHICH ARE HIGHLY
RECYCLABLE AND- OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S A BIG PART OF THE GOAL
OF FIFTY FOUR TO BE HONEST SB
FIFTY FOUR BUT- BUT TO THE YOU
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS.
IMPOSING SOME TRUTH IN
LABELING. IF PRODUCERS DO CARE
ABOUT REAL RECYCLABILITY IN AND
SHOWING THAT FACE TO THE
PUBLIC. I TO THE EXTENT THEY
CAN DAY WELL UNDER THIS BILL
START. USING MORE THE ONES AND
TWOS RATHER THAN THE NON
RECYCLABLE PLASTICS IS THERE A
PRODUCT COST TO THEM. IT
TOTALLY DEPENDS ON THE PRODUCT
IT TOTALLY DEPENDS ON THE
PRODUCT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLOOR
SOMETIMES NO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- CENTER I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY SAFE TO SAY WHEN YOU
FIRST GOT ELECTED THAT YOU
WOULDN'T JUST GO DOWN RECYCLING
PROBABLY WASN'T THE REASON I
NOW FROM HOUSE I KNOW YOU HAVE.
RUINED MY LIFE ABSOLUTELY
BECOME RUSSIA AND I THINK IT'S
KIND OF COOL- BECAUSE IT IS
SUCH A HUGE PROBLEM AND YOU
HAVE DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB OF
TRYING TO FIND BALANCE. SO I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE- TO SAY
THAT TO YOU PERSONALLY BECAUSE
I DO BELIEVE THAT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS ON MULTIPLE TRIPS
TALK ABOUT THIS AMAZING TOPIC I
AM CURIOUS THOUGH LIKE ON THE
LIMITED RESIN A COUPLE TIMES
YOU KNOW WHAT IT TAKES TO TAKE
A QUARTER COULD NOT RECYCLE
PRODUCT WE KNOW THAT WE CAN
RECYCLE PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING
IF WE REDUCE IT DOWN BACK DOWN
TO. YOU KNOW PUREST FORM
INTERESTED WE CAN INJECT THAT
AGAIN AND MAKE A PRODUCT OUT OF
THAT AGAIN. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT HAVE A TON
OF THOSE FACILITIES AVAILABLE
TO DO THIS. AND THIS IS ONE
THING THAT I AM VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT IS AS WE REMOVE ALL THE
STUFF FROM THE STREAM THAT I
COMPLETELY AGREE THAT WE NEED
TO. WE DO NOT HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
ACTUALLY DEAL WITH THIS TO TAKE
THESE QUOTE UNQUOTE BECAUSE WE
ALL KNOW THAT PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING IS RECYCLABLE TO A
CERTAIN DEGREE WE CAN REDUCE
THAT DOWN TO A PETROLEUM
PRODUCT. AND REUSE IT AGAIN WE
DO NOT HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
DO THAT WHICH IS WHY WE SHIP IT
OVERSEAS AND LET THEM DEAL WITH
IT. SO I AM CURIOUS WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON. TRYING TO
BUILD UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
WITHIN OUR STATE. TO DEAL WITH
THIS BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT PART OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO FIX- I
ACTUALLY AGREE- THERE THERE
ISN'T INFRASTRUCTURE CHALLENGE-
I GUESS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
BECOMES. TO WHAT EXTENT
ESPECIALLY FOR THE FOR THE
TECHNICALLY RECYCLABLE BUT VERY
HARD TO RECYCLE PRODUCTS TO
WHAT EXTENT IS IT WORTH. REALLY
DOUBLING DOWN ON INVESTING IN
THAT PARTICULAR TYPE OF
STRUCTURE AS OPPOSED TO
ENCOURAGING US PRODUCERS TO
MOVE TO MORE RECYCLABLE
PRODUCTS SO THAT'S ANOTHER PART
OF THE COST BENEFIT BECAUSE
THERE ARE AS I SAY. WELL YOU'RE
RIGHT EVERYTHING TO SOME EXTENT
IS RECYCLABLE LEAST THE ONES
WITH THIS YOU KNOW THE
RECYCLING SYMBOLS ON THEM. SOME
ARE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE TO
RECYCLE. THAN OTHERS AND SO
SHOULD WE BE MORE YAK SHIFTING
PEOPLE TOWARD THE MORE
RECYCLABLE STUFF. OUT TO THE
EXTENT FEASIBLE- BUT YOUR UPS
RIGHT THE RESEARCH IS A BIG
PART OF THIS I THINK YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE THOUGHTS
I THINK AS WE- ARE BUT WITH
BILLS LIKE THIS BUT CERTAINLY-
CERTAINLY WITH SB FIFTY FOUR.
AB TEN EIGHTY- THE IDEA HAS
BEEN TO TRY TO CREATE AN
ATMOSPHERE. WHERE THERE'S A
REAL INCENTIVE. ACTUALLY
PRODUCE THEIR PRODUCTS WITH THE
MIND TOWARD RECYCLING. AND
AGAIN THE COLLECTION PROCESS IN
THE SORTING PROCESS WITH THE
MIND TOWARD RECYCLING. I'M SO
YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S A- AND I
WILL SAY THERE ARE A LOT OF
PLACES AROUND THE WORLD WITH
THE FREELY TAKING MORE
AGGRESSIVE ACTION IN THIS AREA
WHERE THE- WHERE THE PRODUCERS.
HAVE CREATED. COME HOLISTIC
SYSTEMS. AND BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THEIR OWN PRODUCTS THEY'RE ABLE
TO- TO BUILD. A COLLECTION
SORTING SYSTEM AND AN
ULTIMATELY RECYCLING SYSTEM
THAT THAT IS MORE COST
EFFECTIVE. THAN THE SYSTEM THAT
WE HAVE. SO BUT YOU KNOW I KNOW
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
CONVERSATION IS HAPPENING IN A
ROBUST MANNER- ON BOTH BOTH
SIDES OF OUR BUILDING. AND IF
IT IS ACTUALLY AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF THE STORY- BUT THE
PRODUCERS HAVE TO BE AT THE
TABLE AND THEY HAVE TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION. I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH THAT I THINK YOU
KNOW I JUST I WAS USING MY
BACKGROUND AND COMING FROM THE
OUTSIDE WORLD. YOU THIS
CHARACTERISES THE STICK
APPROACH SEEMS TO REALLY WORK.
AND I YOU KNOW IF WE CAN
ENCOURAGE THE PRODUCERS THE
MANUFACTURE OF THESE PRODUCTS
AND COME ALONG LIKE A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP TO BUILD
THESE KIND OF INSTRUCTORS THAT
ARE REQUIRED TO DO THIS. YES IT
IS A TREMENDOUS COST TO RECYCLE
SOME OF THE HARDER- PRODUCTS
YOU KNOW WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT IF THE STATE IS GOING TO
MAKE THIS A PRIORITY THEY WERE
GOING TO DROP THESE MANDATES.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO PARTNER
WITH OUR INDUSTRIES- AT A
STATE. LEVEL TO GET THIS THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
FACILITIES UP AND RUNNING AS
QUICK AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
OTHERWISE. WE'RE GONNA KEEP
FIGHTING THE SAME BATTLE AND WE
CAN KEEP WONDERING WHY
NOTHING'S REALLY CHANGED AND
PUTTING IT ALL ON THE BACK OF
INDUSTRY FOR THE INDUSTRY TO
DEAL WITH IT. I DON'T THINK IS
THE RIGHT. WAY BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY BUT THE COST OF
LIVING ISSUE. I MEAN THE OTHER
DAY IF INDUSTRY HAS TO PAY X.
AMOUNT DOLLARS MORE FREE
PACKAGE TO PACKAGE SOMETHING
THAT MY COMMUNITY BUYS- THAT IS
PROBLEMATIC O I APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS IN THIS AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO IT AS IT MOVES
FORWARD. MY ITS OWNER IT BUT IF
I MAY IT IS ALREADY ACOSTA
LIVING ISSUE AND IT'S HITTING
OUR CONSTITUENTS RIGHT NOW. I
AS I MENTIONED SEVENTY
SOMETHING LIKE SEVENTY PERCENT-
A NEW A NEARLY THREE QUARTERS
OF CITIES ARE ABOUT TO INCREASE
THEIR RATES FOR WASTE
COLLECTION. AT LOTS OF
JURISDICTIONS ALREADY HAVE BY
QUITE A BIT OUR OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE ALREADY PAYING
A DID A DID AN INORDINATE
AMOUNT OF MONEY. TO BANDAID
OVER OUR BROKEN SYSTEM- ITSELF.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING TO KEEP IN
MIND TOO WHEN PEOPLE KEEP ON
THE PRODUCERS I SAY THOUGH THIS
MAY INCREASE THE COST OF ITEMS-
I'M- INTO. THE THAT'S TRUE BUT
BUT OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
ALREADY PAYING. AND THEIR PAY
MORE AND MORE. ARE. ON THE WAY
ON THE WASTE COLLECTION RATE
SIDE. ANY OTHER. FROM MEMBERS
OKAY. I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
SENATOR ALAN FOR BRINGING THIS.
BILL FORWARD AND YOUR CONTINUED
WORK. ON THE RECYCLING OF
POLICY. ISSUE AREA I KNOW
YOU'RE VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT IT
YOU'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL- I
THINK. THAT THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE THE CLARITY THAT
CONSUMERS NEED TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS RECYCLABLE AND WHAT
ISN'T. I KNOW IN MY HOUSEHOLD.
WE HAVE SEVERAL WISHFUL
RECYCLERS UNFORTUNATELY THAT.
WANT EVERYTHING TO BE
RECYCLABLE BUT THIS WILL HELP.
THEM EVERYONE THAT'S- WITH THE
HAS A GOOD INTENTION RIGHT TO
RECYCLE. OF THEIR IT WOULD HELP
THEM. WITH THIS CLARITY. ALSO
IT JUST. WE HAVE A I KNOW IN
CURBSIDE RECYCLING WE HAVE A
LOT OF CONTAMINATION- YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT THE INTENTION OF THE
CONSUMER BUT- IT HAPPENS- AND I
THINK THAT YOUR BILL WILL HELP.
CLARIFY THIS AND HELP US ALL.
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS RECYCLABLE-
SO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL. AND ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL. C. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE NO I JUST APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION AND I AM REALLY
OUR DOORS REMAINS WIDE OPEN TO
ANY MEMBER WHO WANTS TO. WORK
WITH US STAFF- AS WE AS WE TRY
TO GET THIS RIGHT AND THIS IS
PART OF A BROADER PLACE THERE'S
A LOT OF BILLS IN THE PLASTIC
SPACE THIS YEAR AND- OBVIOUSLY
YOU KNOW I CONTINUE TO BE
REALLY PASSION ABOUT. OUR
BROADER PLAY WITH SB FIFTY FOUR
THAT'S IN THE MIX IS ABOUT
MEASURES THERE'S A LOT
HAPPENING IN THE SPACE AND I DO
I REALLY OPENLY WELCOME. AND
ALL MY COLLEAGUES- TO WORK WITH
ME AND I AND I ALSO WHAT WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU. AS YOU
OF PURSUE YOUR OWN A POLICY
PRIORITIES IN THIS AREA SO I
WITH THAT VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION AND RESPECT FOR
US AND I HAVE A- THANK YOU. I
HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA. SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SU CHI. ON
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUTISH. SECRETARY
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I
DON'T THREE SB THREE FORTY
THREE BY SENATOR ALAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS IS MANDATORY
FOR TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLORIDA. FLOOR NOT VOTING CHAU
CHAU FIVE FRIEDMAN R. C. S. FOR
CSI MATHIS. MATHIS NOT VOTING
FOR CARDI MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I SAY OUR TOTAL NUMBER SEATTLE
NOT VOTING. STONE STONE I WOULD
WOULD I. THANK YOU MA'AM SIX
ZERO SIX ZERO BUT WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
NOW YOUR FINAL BILL FOR TODAY
SB FOUR THIRTY THREE I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
INTELLIGENCE I HERE I AM THIS
IS- HOPEFULLY WON'T SEE MUCH
MORE MANY OF. SO- I THINK THAT
SHOULD INDICATE WERE WERE NOT
GETTING THAT'S- YEAH OKAY. ALL
RIGHT WELL I MEAN I'VE I'VE
READ IT AND PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE
READY YEAH WE YOU KNOW WE DID
HAVE A STRONG BIPARTISAN VOTE
OVER IN THE ASSEMBLY ON THE
SENATE SIDE BY FOR THIS BILL I
BASICALLY THIS THIS- YOU KNOW-
THE- SO. SO THE CODE THE
BECAUSE THE COMMISSION IS
TASKED WITH- ENFORCING THE
COASTAL ACT- YOU. ORIGINALLY
THEY ONLY GAVE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THE RIGHT TO ENFORCE
THE ACT. THEN SENATOR ATKINS I
GUESS I SAID THAT TIME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ATKINS RAN A
BILL THAT WOULD- GIVE. THE
COASTAL ACT BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION THE RIGHT TO ENFORCE
ACCESS VIOLATIONS. I'M
INTERESTINGLY THAT DRAMATICALLY
DECREASED THE COST OF
LITIGATION AND- AND DISPUTES.
AND THEY ENDED UP RESOLVING A
LOT OF DISPUTES MUCH MORE
QUICKLY AND THIS IS BASICALLY
THIS BASICALLY EXTENDS THE BILL
TO INCLUDE- ALL VIOLATIONS OF
THE COASTAL ACT. I BELIEVE BILL
THAN A LOT OF PROTECTIONS WE
WORK CLOSELY- YOU KNOW WITH
THEM. AT THE CHERRY THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE EFFECTS PRESENTS
A COMMUNITY THAT OFTENTIMES.
HAS CONFLICT WITH THE BECAUSE
THE COMMISSION WE BUILT IN SOME
SOME MORE PROTECTIONS FOR FOLKS
WE PUT IN SOME- SOME LONGER
TIME LINES. ARE GRACE PERIOD
IT'S ADDRESS- BUT BUT
ULTIMATELY THIS IS ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT OUR COASTAL ACT IS-
IS EFFECTIVE. AND IT'S ALSO
ABOUT- YOU KNOW IT'S ALSO ABOUT
ABOUT IMPROVING EFFICIENCY AND
LOWERING COSTS- OVER THE
COMMISSION. I HAVE WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO SUPPORT SPEAK OF THE
BILL. SPEAKING FOR THE BILL AYE
SIR CHRISTY FROM THE COASTAL
COMMISSION ALSO DANIEL WILSON
FROM UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN.
K. AND WE'RE READY FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- MODERATOR
Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR
THE WITNESSES. EDERLE YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS I'M CHARACTER HE
WITH A CALIFORNIA OF THE
COMMISSION WHICH IS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT SB PORT
THIRTY THREE GAINING AT
INTENSELY AUTHORITY AT THE TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE COMMISSION
IT'S IN OUR FIVE YEAR STRATEGIC
PLAN IT WAS IN THE PREVIOUS
PLAN AND SEPARATE BUT TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION OUR MONTHLY
MEETINGS. THANK YOU TO
RECRUITMENT TOOL FOR DETERRING
VIOLATIONS WHICH IS THE
COMMISSION'S PRIMARY GOAL FOR
PURSUING THIS POLICY WENT VIRAL
AGENCY WORKER THE POTENTIAL FOR
FIND AMOUNT DAILY IS A POWERFUL
INCENTIVE FOR CURING THEM AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE YOU NEED TO
GET THE PRODUCES COPPER THE
STATE WHICH IS QUITE LITERALLY
EVERY STATE REGULATORY AGENCY
ALREADY. HAS ADMINISTRATIVE AND
WE FORTY. BUT THE COMMISSION.
FIVE BACK TWENTY TEN WE HAD A-
OF ONE THOUSAND HUNDRED TWENTY
OPENS. THAT NUMBER IS AN
BALLOONED TO ALMOST TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED AND IT'S GROWING
EVERY YEAR BECAUSE IT TAKES
SUCH A LONG TIME. TO RESOLVE
THE VIOLATIONS IF THERE'S NO
FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCE FOR SLOW
WALKING AT. IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE ALLOWED ADMIN
PENALTIES FOR CALLS LIKE
VIOLATIONS INVOLVING PUBLIC
pBALANCED APPROACH WHEREBY FIND
COULD ONLY BE IMPOSED BY A VOTE
OF THE FULL COMMISSION IN A
PUBLIC HEARING. DALY FINES ARE
CAPPED AT FIVE YEARS EVEN FOR
VIOLATIONS THAT HAVE PERSISTED
FOR MUCH LONGER. AND IF YOU CAN
BE AVOIDED BY RESOLVING THE
VOLUNTARILY AND MINOR
AMENDMENTS VIOLATIONS ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO PENALTIES AT ALL.
ROCKFEST WORKS WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO RESOLVE 95% OF THE ACTUAL
CASES WE ADDRESS VOLUNTARILY
WITH NO FINE. AVERAGE TIME IS
DROPPED FROM ALMOST THREE YEARS
THE THREE MONTHS MORE THAN A
QUARTER ARE RESOLVED NOW IN
LESS THAN THIRTY DAYS. THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW THE COMMISSION
TO MAKE SIMILAR PROGRESS ON ALL
OTHER TYPES OF VIOLATIONS AND
BETTER PROTECT VULNERABLE
POLITICALLY SOURCES. ARE
IMPORTANT PROCEDURES HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENTLY UPHELD BY THE
COURT ALL THE WAY TO THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
NUMBER ANY WHAT IS ONLY AS
EFFECTIVE AS THE ABILITY TO
ENFORCE IT THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S DANIEL WILSON
AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE THIRTY TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS
OF UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN THAT
WE REPRESENT ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ARIZONA OUR
MEMBERS HOTEL GAS AND CLEAN
ROOMS IN COASTAL RESORTS THAT
ATTRACT VISITORS FROM AROUND
THE WORLD THIS IS WHY WE FIGHT
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE LIKE OUR
MEMBERS CAN ALSO AFFORD TO
VISIT THE COAST AND ENJOY ITS
PRECIOUS RESOURCES. IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WORKERS ON THE SHORE
HOTEL IN SANTA MONICA TESTIFIED
BEFORE THE CLIP THE COMMISSION
APPLICABLE OR INFORMING THEM OF
POTENTIAL COULD BLACK
VIOLATIONS AT THEIR WORKPLACE
DESPITE THE FACT THAT SHORE
HOTEL WAS APPROVED BY THE
COMMISSION TO BE IN AFFORDABLE
HOTEL BECAUSE IT DESTROYED TO
EXISTING MOTEL THE OWNERS BUILT
AS A LUXURY HOTEL IN SET
ARGUABLY ONE OF THE MOST
EGREGIOUS VIOLATIONS OF THE
CODE BLACK THE PUBLIC WITH
DEPRIVED OF PROMISE AND
DESPERATELY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR NEARLY A
DECADE. AND TWENTY NINETEEN THE
COOKBOOK COMMISSION LEVIED A
HISTORIC FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
FINE AGAINST THE HOTEL AND YOU
TO OUR ADVOCACY ALONG WITH OUR
ALLIES REQUIRED THE HOTEL TO
REPLACE THE AFFORDABLE
COMBINATIONS THAT HAD BEEN
LOCKED ON SITE WORKING FAMILIES
LIKE THOSE OF OUR MEMBERS WILL
NOW GET THE CHANCE THEY DESERVE
TO VISIT COASTAL COMMUNITIES
LIKE THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA
IT IS ONLY BECAUSE OF THE
COMMISSION'S ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTY AUTHORITY THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO HOLD THE SHORE
HOTEL ACCOUNTABLE. OUR MEMBERS
KNOW BETTER THAN ANYONE THAT
WITHOUT MEANINGFUL TOLD THEM OF
ENFORCEMENT CRITICAL LAWS LIKE
THE COUPLE ACT CANNOT BE
EFFECTIVE IF WE WANT TO PROTECT
OUR BLOOD BE EGYPT AND
SENSITIVE HABITAT FROM BAD
ACTORS AND ECONOMIC FORCES THAT
DRIVE BENCH WE NEED TO GIVE THE
COASTAL COMMISSION THE TOOL TO
TRULY PROTECT COULD ACCESS FOR
ALL WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT. SB
FOUR THIRTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NOW. WE ARE
READY. FOR IT DID. WITNESSES%
AND- OR ALL- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESS IN THE HEARING ROOM.
CASEY NINE. I DON'T SEE ANY AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION-
MODERATOR CAME PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THIS LEGISLATION PER THE
INSTRUCTIONS OF THE CHAIRPERSON.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WELL NOW GO TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN. HI QUOTE I MEAN I
KNOW WHAT AUDUBON CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. LINE FORTY NINE. CAN
YOU TURN NUMBERS NIKITA CLOUDY
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL SUPPORT CHANGE.
NINE EIGHTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
ON BEHALF OF A FOREIGN WORK.
LINE. ONE FOURTEEN. PRINT OUT
SOME WITH YOUR COULD
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. LINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS PARTS THAT THE
MAKER FOR GREAT JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT. LINE. ONE OH SIX. RYAN
GARY MYERS ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION
COMMITTEE OF WEST MARIN IN
SUPPORT. AND THE FINAL CALL FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE HAD
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU. I'M NOW ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
I'M ALMOST LOS TO COMMENT ON
THIS GIVEN THAT HAS NO
OPPOSITION SORT OF WHERE IT IS
BUT I REMEMBER WHEN WE PUT. THE
FIRST ADMINISTRATIVE COUNTY
BILL THROUGH. AND THE HORROR
STORIES ABOUT HOW THIS GUY WAS
GOING TO FALL AND YET THE
ARGUMENT WAS. EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED IS IT REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF PENALTIES YEAH
CLEANED UP THE ACCESS ISSUES.
THE PERFORMANCE HAS BEEN
EXACTLY WHAT WAS CAPS TO THE
TIME. AND NOW YOU HAVE A
BUILDING HOW POSITION TO DO
WITH THAT WITH TONI ATKINS BILL
NEEDED TO HAVE DONE YEARS AGO
BUT IT WAS A FIGHT JUST TO GET
THAT PIECE OF IT. SO I COMMEND
YOU GETTING THIS DONE IT'S LONG
PAST TIME. THAT WE WOULD CLEAN
UP THIS PART OF THEIR
AUTHORITY. AND I JUST. THINK
IT'S FABULOUS THAT THIS IS HERE
AND IT THAT YOU'RE GETTING THIS
DONE. SO I'D LIKE TO MOVE HER.
THANKS YEAH I THINK WE I
BELIEVE WE ARE TO HAVE A MOTION
BUT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU AYE- I
ALSO WAS HERE WHEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THAN A SIMPLE MATTER
ATKINS BROUGHT THE BILL FORWARD
AND I REMEMBER- THE STRONG
OPPOSITION- FROM. ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WERE CONCERNED ABOUT A
STATE AND AGENCY THAT WOULD BE
ON ACCOUNTABLE AND HAVING THIS
NEW POWER TO LEVY SANCTIONS AND
YOU TO GO FROM A VERY
CONTROVERSIAL BILL TO- TO
HAVING NO OPPOSITION I THINK
IT'S JUST TESTAMENT TO THE FACT
THAT THE PROCESS HAS WORKED
THAT IN FACT BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION HAS EXERCISED ITS
POWER RESPONSIBLY AND HAS NOT
ABUSED IT CONTRARY TO. THE
INITIAL CONCERNS WHEN THE WHEN
THE PROPOSAL WAS FIRST MADE IN
SO. I WOULD. YOU TO SAY THAT
THIS IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF A-
OF- IMPAIRING THE STATE AGENCY-
AND IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY TO
ENFORCE OUR R. COSTA PROJECTION
WALLS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- CENTER I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO GO WITH THIS- AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK I DO
HAVE- MY OWN CONCERNS ABOUT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION ESPECIALLY
SINCE- THERE ARE PENDING
LAWSUITS- WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
OCEANIA DOING WRITERS CLAIMS-
WE WITH THE FRIENDS OF THE
OCEANIC TONES AND WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THAT SITUATION I DO-
DOES RAISE CONCERNS- FONG. OVER
USE OF POWER FROM THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. AND WHAT THEY DO SO
I AM HESITANT ON YOUR BILL
TODAY- BUT I DO WANT TO COMMEND
YOU ON YOUR WORK FOR NOT HAVING
ANY FORMAL OPPOSITION ON THE
SOFA WITH THOSE REASON I'M
GONNA STAY OFF YOUR BILL- THERE
ARE AREAS OF THE COASTLINE THAT
ARE. CONSIDERED THE- GO TO
AREAS FOR THOSE OF US IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY EIGHTY POINT
WHEN THERE ARE CONCERNS AND
THERE'S OPEN CASES AND THINGS
GOING ON IT IT MAKES ME WONDER
WHAT EXACTLY IS GOING ON THAT
WE DON'T SEE- HAPPENING. BUT I
DO UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
GETTING THESE THINGS DONE AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW CUT THROUGH
SOME OF THEIR OWN RED TAPING
AND MAKE THINGS MORE EFFICIENT.
IT DOES. BRING A FEW RED FLAGS
FOR ME TO THINK OF GIVING. MORE
POWER TO AN AGENCY. I MEAN I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AYE
AYE AYE YEAH I THINK ULTIMATELY
THIS IS ABOUT ACTUALLY MAKING
SURE FOLKS FROM YOUR DISTRICT.
CAN CAN COME TO THE COAST AND
ENJOY BECAUSE IN THAT THAT IT'S
NOT JUST THAT. THE DEMAND OF
THE- OF THE OTHER FOLKS WHO
ACTUALLY LIVE RIGHT THERE- YOU
KNOW ON THE WATER SAID SO-
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ULTIMATELY
ABOUT I DON'T I DON'T KNOW THAT
I MEAN I. UNDERSTAND I KNOW A
BIT ABOUT THE IS GOING TO DO IS
DEBATE AND- I ON'T KNOW THAT
THIS BILL NECESSARILY
IMPLICATES THAT BUT- YOU KNOW.
I KNOW THAT'S A- THAT'S A- OKAY
REVVED UP TOPIC ON ITS OWN SO-
BUT I DON'T I DON'T KNOW THAT
IT NECESSARILY AND IMPLICATES
THIS BILL. K. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE TO BELIEVE. YEAH I'D
APPRECIATE A ONE COMMENTS AND-
YOU KNOW. WE WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WITH WITH FOLKS WHO
HAVE ISSUES ARE IF ANYTHING WE
CAN CLARIFY THE BILL MAYBE THEY
CAN ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- BUT WITH THAT-
RESPECT RESTAURANT OF. THANK
YOU WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORES SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I DON'T FOR SB FOUR
THIRTY THIRTY FIVE SENATOR ALAN.
MEMBERS RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLORA
FLORA I'D CHAU. FRIEDMAN GARCIA.
MATHIS MATHIS NOT VOTING
MCCARTY RIGHT TO TREAT WELL TWO
G. I.'S AIRTEL HI SANTA AYE
STONE. STONE I WOULD WOOD I
THANK YOU MEMBERS APPRECIATE
YOUR DILIGENCE THIS MORNING
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SIX ZERO.
SIX ZERO WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. AB NEXT WE
HAVE SENATOR TO LETTER WITH SB
SIX FOUR THREE MOVE THE BILL.
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING
JERRY THIS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
THREE. SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
THREE PASSED THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION AND
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
TO PREPARE A STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENT OF THE FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FUEL
PRODUCTION NEEDED. TO SUPPORT
THE ADOPTION OF ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF ROAD
VEHICLES. HYDROGEN FUEL CELLS
ARE AN IDEAL ALTERNATIVE FUEL
SOLUTION TO ELECTRIFY MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY COMMERCIAL
VEHICLES. AND THESE VEHICLES
ARE NECESSARY COMPONENT TO
ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
AND AIR QUALITY GOALS. HOWEVER
THERE EXISTS THE KNOWLEDGE GAP
REGARDED THE HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS REQUIRED
FOR CALIFORNIA TO MEET ITS
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOALS. STATE
AGENCIES ENERGY UTILITIES AND
THE LEGISLATURE WAX SPECIFIC
KNOWLEDGE OF THE AMOUNT OF
HYDROGEN FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND HYDROGEN FUEL PRODUCTION
NEEDED TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN AIR GOALS. SENATE BILL
SIX FORTY THREE WILL HELP
BRIDGE THE KNOWLEDGE GAP AND
ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO ADEQUATELY
PLAN AND IMPLEMENT HYDROGEN
FUEL CELLS AS AN ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY SOURCE THE ASSESSMENT
REQUIRED BY THIS BILL WILL
FOCUS ON. THREE ITEMS FOR ITEMS
PRODUCTION AND DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE DISPENSING AND
DISTRIBUTION EQUIPMENT STORAGE
EQUIPMENT SUPPORTING HARDWARE
AND SOFTWARE. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY AREAS OF
COLLABORATION ACROSS HYDROGEN
SECTORS FOR EXAMPLE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN ONCE AGAIN
PRODUCTION STORAGE AND
DISTRIBUTION. WITH THE
INFORMATION FROM THIS
ASSESSMENT CALIFORNIA WILL BE
ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
AND MOVE OUT OUR STATE WIDE.
KNOWLEDGE ACROSS THE BOARD WHEN
IT COMES TO CLEAN AIR ENERGY
AND ITS FUTURE THIS BILL WILL
RECEIVE AND HAVE RECEIVED I'M
SORRY THIS BILL HAD RECEIVED NO
NO VOTE AND BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
AND WITH ME ON THE PHONE IS
WILL TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS
ROCKSTAND BETTER- HI MANDY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
WESTERN STATES HYDROGEN
ALLIANCE. THANK YOU MODERATOR
THANK YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I APOLOGIZE I THINK YOU
CAN ARGUE OTHER THANK YOU CHAIR
DOESN'T HAVE ANY MEMBER OF YOUR
TIME MY NAME IS LOCKED IN A
BACK BODY AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE WESTERN STATES
HYDRO LINES. OF A FORMER
ENGINEER AT A STATE AGENCY
CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCIES-
CLEANING IN ARCHITECTING OUR
ENERGY LANDSCAPE IS HIGHLY
ADVANTAGEOUS- TECHNOLOGY IS
RAPIDLY CHANGING AND MORE MORE
SYNERGIES ARE DISCOVERED TO
DROP THE STATE COMPLEX ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. SUPPLY AND NEED.
I SIX FOURTH THOUSAND BACK WE
THAT BY ANDERSON THAT HAS PAR
OF THE POLICE WHEN IT COMES TO.
ELECTRIFYING TRUCK BUSTED
AIRDROPS HARBOR CRAP
LOCOMOTIVES OPERATED CLINTON AS
WELL AS EIGHTEEN IN GREAT
RESILIENCE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU. AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION- SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE. WHICH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION- ARE THERE ANY IN
THE HEARING ROOM. I DON'T SEE
ANY DON'T SEE ANY OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION. A MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE AT LEAST ONE PERSON TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. PRESS ONE AND ZERO. GOING
TO GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JANET
TALKED FOR THREE FIFTY DOLLARS
VALLEY AND WE WISH TO WITHDRAW
OUR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANKS VERY MUCH. THE FINAL
CALL FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO. I'M SURE NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU I'M NEXT MOVE
TO QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THERE ARE NONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- YES ONCE
AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MURATSUCHI
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
TRANSPORTATION. SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON
ITEM FIVE SB SIX FORTY THREE BY
SENATE ARCHULETA MEMBERS RIVAS
I RIVERSIDE FLORA. FLORA I CHAU.
FRIEDMAN GARCIA MATHIS HI
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
HIGH ROAD TO GI SO YOUR CHILD
HI SO YOUR T<c.cyan> STONE STONE I</c>
WOULD. WOULD I. SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
UP FOR ONE OF YOUR MANAGER
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU. C.
NEXT WE HAVE ITEM SIX SB ONE
PRESENTED BY OF SENATOR LAYERED
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- I'M PRESENTING US
SENATE BILL ONE ON BEHALF OF
THE SENATE PRO TEMPTODAY THING
AND- I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I'LL BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE RECOMMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. I THINK IF
I COULD MAYBE BEGAN. IT IN A
PERSONAL WAY WHEN I WAS A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE- I
INTRODUCED WHAT WAS I THINK THE
FIRST BILL IN THE LEGISLATURE
ON THE SUBJECT OF SEA LEVEL
RISE. AND WHEN I DID THAT IT
WAS DESIGNED TO ADD TO GENERAL
PLANS ACROSS THE STATE FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES ALONG THE
COAST OF PLANNING MEASURE FOR
DOING SEA LEVEL RISE AND WHEN I
GOT TO THE SENATE BOB WHICH OF
COURSE WAS ON REASONABLE. AT
THE TIME- THEY BASICALLY SAID
HALF THE STAKEHOLDER SAID IF
YOU DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
BASELINE WE WON'T MOVE THIS
BILL ALONG AND THE OTHER HALF
OF THE STAKEHOLDER SAID WE WANT
TO SPECIFIC BASELINE OR ELSE
THIS BILL WAS IT MEANINGFUL I
COULDN'T MOVE THE BILL OUT OF
THE SENATE. AND THEN YOU FAST
FOR TWO OR THREE YEARS AND I'M
NATURAL RESOURCES SECRETARY IN
CHARGE OF THE FIRST SCIENCE
STUDY ON SEA LEVEL RISE WHICH
ALLOWED US TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION TO SET A BASELINE.
AND WE DID THAT AND THE OTHER
THING THAT WAS INTERESTING. IS
WHEN WE- HAVE THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL MEETING. TO
ACCEPT THAT SCIENTIFIC STUDY ON
SEA LEVEL RISE IT WAS GAVELED
TO ORDER AT NINE O'CLOCK WHEN
THE TSUNAMI HIT THE CALIFORNIA
COAST AT EIGHT AM THAT MORNING
COMING FROM JAPAN. WHICH
ACCENTUATED THE EXACT ISSUES OF
SEA LEVEL RISE- BECAUSE- IT IS
NOT JUST THE RISING SEASON IT'S
BEEN EIGHT TO NINE INCHES SINCE
THE OF THE INDUSTRIAL
REVOLUTION IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S
THE EXTREME OF THAT THE EXTREME
EVENT REALLY DRIVES IT HOME.
AND THE OTHER PIECE OF IT IS
THE CALIFORNIA COAST IS VERY
DIFFERENT. SO IN THAT TSUNAMI-
THERE WERE TWO PORTS THAT
REALLY TOOK A MAJOR HIT
CRESCENT CITY IN DEL NORTE
COUNTY. AND SANTA CRUZ IN MY
HOME CITY. AND TWO COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT AREAS AND SO WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS SEA
LEVEL RISE YOU HAVE SOME AREAS
LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLINS
DISTRICT WHERE. IN PACIFICA
APARTMENT BUILDINGS HAVE BEEN
FALLING INTO THE SEA BECAUSE OF
SANDY SOILS AND OTHER DISTRICTS
THAT THAT SOME OF US REPRESENT
THAT HAVE ROCKY PROMONTORY
SORRY OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
WHICH HAS MARSHES AND PRESENTS
HOLD DIFFERENT ISSUES. AND SO
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU
ADDRESS IT AND THIS BILL IS THE
NEXT STEP IN THAT CONTINUE ON.
BECAUSE SB ONE ESTABLISHES FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN CALIFORNIA
LAW NEW PLANNING IMPLEMENTATION
AND PUBLIC AGENCY COORDINATION
REQUIREMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACT OF SEA LEVEL RISE.
REQUIRES THE COASTAL COMMISSION
TO ADOPT AND PERIODICALLY
UPDATE STANDARDS TO USE AND
LOCAL AND REGIONAL COASTAL
PLANNING IN ORDER TO. IDENTIFY
ASSESS AND MITIGATE C. LEVEL
RISE. IT ESTABLISHES A NEW
CROSS GOVERNMENT COLLABORATIVE
WITHIN THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL. TO ENSURE THE IMPACTS
OF SEA LEVEL RISE ARE
ANTICIPATED IN A DRESS BEYOND
SIMPLY ENVIRONMENTAL
DEPARTMENTS BUT ALSO BY OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AGENCIES. AND FINALLY IT
ESTABLISHES NEW FUNDING.
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
IN THE ANNUAL BUDGET FOR STATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO PLAN. FOR AND MITIGATE SEA
LEVEL RISE BUT SEPARATELY IT
EXPANDS THE EXISTING-
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GRANT
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED FROM SEA LEVEL RISE.
HAVE A VOICE IN ACTIONS THAT
THE GOVERNMENT TAKES TO ADDRESS
THE CHALLENGE. AND SO- IT'S
TEMPTING TO SEE SEA LEVEL RISE
IS JUST ANOTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUE BUT IN REALITY IT CUTS
ACROSS MANY AREAS FROM
TRANSPORTATION THE COMMERCE AND
RECREATION- YEAH- IN MANY OF
THE DISTRICTS OF PEOPLE SITTING
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND IN MY
DSTRICT- THE SEA LEVEL RISE
AND CLIFF EROSION. WELL THE PRO
TEM'S DISTRICT IT'S REALLY EVEN
KILLED STROLLERS WALKING ON THE
BEACH IT'S CUT OFF KEY RAIL
TRANSPORTATION AND AS MR STONE
MIGHT KNOW- I WAS ON THE CITY
COUNCIL MAYOR IN SANTA CRUZ AND
WE DESIGNED THE LIGHT HOUSE
FIELD. STATE BEACH AND WE
ALIENATED ONE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT POLITICAL
CONSTITUENTS AND SANTA CRUZ TO
SURFERS BECAUSE WE WANTED TO
MOVE TO ST BACK A LITTLE BIT
FROM THE OCEAN. AND WE DID IN
THE END AND THERE A COUPLE OF
PLACES WHERE THE OCEAN AS HE
RODE UP TO THE STREET THAT WE
MOVE BACKED OVER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AGO SO THAT YOU CAN SEE.
IT IN ONE LIFE HOW THAT HAPPENS
AND SO SB ONE PRESENTS THIS
COMMITTEE IN CALIFORNIA WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO GET OUT FRONT
OF THIS IMPORTANT- OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IN OUR MAGNIFICENT
STATE. AND I WOULD RESPECT AND
I'VE FOUGHT. OKAY THANK YOU. WE
ARE READY. TO HEAR FROM
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL- WE HAVE UP TO WITNESSES-
BY TELEPHONE MODERATOR Q.
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
SERRA A MEANS THAT DAY THE
COASTAL COMMISSIONER AND
JENNIFER SAVAGE FROM THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION. GOOD
MORNING MADAME CHIANG COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JENNIFER SAVAGE
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER FOR
THE THIRD BETTER FOUNDATION TO
HARM SEALABLE RIFLE DUE TO
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ACADEMY IN
OCEAN RIGHT THAT CAN MAKE CLEAR
IN THE STATE- REPORT. IF WE DO
NOT TAKE QUICK ACTION WE WILL
DO THAT BEACHES AND HEALTH
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES ATTEND
OUR ECONOMY AND ALLOW SOME OF
THE MOST BIO DIVERSE COASTLINE
IN THE WORLD TO DISAPPEAR. IN
PRACTICAL TERMS THIS MEANS THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS CAN GET THE DIRTY
WORK RECREATE ADMIRING OTHER
WHAT I FIND JUST A MOMENT OUR
TREASURE COAST LINE WILL NO
LONGER HAVE BEACH IS TO GO TO.
IT MEANS THAT THOSE WITH THE
FEWEST OPTIONS WILL SEPARATE
THE MOST DISLOCATION AND BY
INCREASING BIODIVERSITY AT THE
COOK TO ECOSYSTEMS MANAGEMENT
HELP YOU LEVEL RISE WILL WASH
AWAY OUR COUNTY BEACHES AND
DOWN A ROCKY REEF. SOMETHING WE
CANNOT LET HAPPEN IF WE ARE TO
MEET OUR GOAL OF PROTECTING
BIODIVERSITY TO THIRTY BY
THIRTY AFTER. WE NEED SB ONE
NOW THE BILL BUILT ON THE
PRINCIPLE OF TREND LINES TAKE
ACTION SIGNED BY SEVENTEEN
STATE AGENCIES MISSIONS FACULTY
LEVEL RIGHTS ISSUES ON THE
FRONT LINES USING PROVEN
INSTITUTIONS OF COOKERY COURSES
MANAGEMENT AND PROVIDE
DESPERATELY NEEDED ANNUAL
FUNDING TO LOCAL REGIONAL AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND
COMMUNITIES FACING EXISTENTIAL
ADAPTATION CHALLENGES. THE
LONGER WE FOR CO AND ASKING A
PLANNING GOVERNANCE AND
PHYSICAL ADAPTATIONS NECESSARY
TO RESPOND TO RISING SEAS AND
MORE EXPENSIVE THAT ADAPTATION
WILL BECOME SB ONE GIVES US A
SHOT IT STATING OUR BEACHES.
BUILDING ON CUTS TO ACCESS
EQUITY CONSERVING BIODIVERSITY
PARKING ACOSTA CONNIE INTO THE
FUTURE IN SHORT THE BILL WOULD
ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S NOT
DEFINING AND DEMOCRATIC BASE
OUR CODE IS PROTECTED LIKE THE
TREASURY DEBT. FOR ALL THE
REASONS TODAY WE ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE ON SB. ONE THANK YOU.
SIX WITNESS. GOOD MORNING. YES
GOOD MORNING MY NAME MY NAME IS
TERRY EVAN AT I'M ON TO HAVE TO
AT ONE TWO. I THE IMPACT IT
RIGHT ON IN A AND FOR NEED
LEGAL AND POLICY REFORM FORGET
YEARS SINCE I FIRST OF AS
DURING LAW SCHOOL NOW I THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING ON THE
CALIFORNIA COAST OKAY AND THAT
WAS THE OBSERVE COASTAL CLIMATE
I NEEDS HI OUT ON THE BASIS
THAT. WE KNOW IMPACT I'M NOT
HAPPEN. ANGER AT THE FAR OFF
TURN RIGHT INTO TWENTY FIFTY
AND TWENTY ONE HUNDRED MIGHT
IMPLY. BUT INSIDE ED
PREDICTABLE EMERGENCIES
ASSOCIATED WITH EXTREME WEATHER
AND ULTRA HIGH TIDE EVENTS. I
WANT TO SPEAK TODAY IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT THE IMPACT
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY OF THEM HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM COASTAL
AREAS THROUGH STATE SANCTIONED
EMINENT DOMAIN. RELEGATED TO
AREAS VULNERABLE TO FLOODING
THE REDLINING AND FEDERAL
HOUSING PROJECTS AND ELEVEN
LARGELY PARK FOR AREAS AND CAN
ACT OF COASTAL AREAS. BY PUBLIC
TRANSPORT BIKING OR WALKING.
SEALEVEL RISE AND STATE ACTION
OR INACTION INCLUDING WHAT THE
COMMITTEE DOES TODAY. WILL
PERPETUATE INEQUITIES AND
DISPARITIES ARCTIC THAT IF WE
DO NOT KNOW FOR IT WOULD
COMPREHENSIVE REFORMS LIKE THAT
AND I SEE ONE. LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS AND THOSE WHO LIVE IN
RENTAL UNITS AND PLACES LIKE TO
LOOK AT THAT IMPORT WHY NIIMI
I'M MORE LIKELY TO BE DISPLACED
BY FLOODING RELATED IMPACTS AS
COMPARED TO PROPERTY OWNERS
BECAUSE THEY LACKED THE FUNDS
AN ABILITY. TO REBUILD AND HAVE
LESS CONTROL OVER THEIR SAFETY
AND OFTEN HAVE LIMITED ACCESS
TO INSURANCE. IN AREAS
VULNERABLE TO SEA LEVEL RISE
LIKE THEM FUTURE- AND LONG
BACH. HE WALKED FURTHER REDUCE
ACCESS TO PUBLIC TRUST
RESOURCES AND COASTAL
RECREATION AREA. ALL RESIDENTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE RESIDENTS
LIVING AND LAND. THE MAY ACT
THAT THE BEACH RARELY AND BUY
POT BIKING OR WALKING. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT SB ONE
DOES NOT CREATE NEW OR
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY FOR THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. IT SIMPLY
CLARIFIES AND CODIFIES OUR
EXISTING AUTHORITY OVER COASTAL
HAZARDS BY SPECIFYING THE LEVEL
RIGHT CAPTURED IN THE COASTAL
ACT. AND IN DOING SO
ESTABLISHING NEW FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES TO PARTNER TO
ADDRESS THE LEVEL RIGHTS. AT
THE ONE ENACT THE FIRST
COMPREHENSIVE PEOPLE RIGHT
PROGRAM IN STATE GOVERNMENT AND
ESTABLISH ITS FUNDING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COMMUNITIES TO
PLANT CORN MEDICATE SEALEVEL
RISE. IT WOULD MAKE UP TO ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL ADAPTATION
IMPROPER PREPAREDNESS WORK.
THIS FUNDING IS ESSENTIAL FOR
THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND OUR
PARTNER AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO MAKE THEIR COMMUNITIES
MORE RESILIENT TO FEEL ALL
RIGHT. WE KNOW THAT ONE DOLLAR
SPENT TODAY. NEXT YEAR THE
FOLLOWING AN ADAPTATION OF
PREPAREDNESS. CAN SAVE A SIX
DOLLARS ON EMERGENCY RESPONSE
DOWN THE LINE. SB ONE WOULD
ALSO EXPLICITLY ADDS THE LEVEL
RISE TO THE EPA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GRANT PROGRAM SENDING
CRITICALLY NEEDED FUNDS TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
EVERY YEAR THAT WE CANNOT KICK
**** RAMP UP OF YOUR- AND YOUR
OVER YET TIME THANK YOU IN MY
LAP THAT. THANK EVERY YEAR THAT
WE DO NOT TAKE ACTION TO
PREPARE STATE PRETTY ALL RIGHT
MEANS THE FAT OF OPPORTUNITIES
AND CHOICES LAW. AND WE KNOW
THAT THESE LOSSES WILL BE FELT
MOST SHARPLY BY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THAT NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I'M WE DON'T HAVE
ANY I WITNESSES REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL NOW OPEN IT
UP FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
THE HEARING ROOM C. NINE THERE
ARE NONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION- A MODERATOR
Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THIS
LEGISLATION PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE ONE FOURTEEN. HELLO BROWN
AND ALSO YOUR CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING NATALIE LAST MONDAY
OPPORTUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND IT'S MEANT FOR
WHICH NOT OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
COURT. LINE FORTY FIVE. MORE
THAN ONE PAIR REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY THREE.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE GO ON BEHALF
OF THE FALL INTO FOUR. LINE.
ONE THIRTY. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS THEIR DOLPHIN HAPPILY
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT OF
SB ONE. LINE ONE THIRTEEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THE SENATE OVER AND TELL US
WHAT THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY NINE. THE MORNING
CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA KARATE WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
ONE. LINE. TWENTY SEVEN. HI
COMMITTEE ON- WITHOUT OUR
HELPLESSNESS AFFORDABLE SHE'S.
LINE ONE TWO ONE. JOHN SINCLAIR
ABOUT THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO AND
OF THIS. ONE LINE. ONE TWENTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING JUST
AMERICA'S SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP WE HAVE A
SUPPORT AMENDED PETITION FOR
THE REASONS OUTLINED IN OUR
LETTER THANK YOU. LINE. FIFTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBER SHARON GUNS ALL THIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF CARLSBAD
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE THANK YOU.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS
IS THE FINAL CALL FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SB ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU NEXT WILL MOVE TO QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE HAVE
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MISSION. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T
SIX SB ONE BY SENATOR ATKINS
MEMBERS RIVAS I RIVERSIDE
FLORA. FLORA I CHILD. FRIEDMAN
GARCIA. MATHIS MATHIS NOT
VOTING RT WHERE TO CHANGE WELL
TO GI SAY ARE CHAU. SO THEY ARE
NOT VOTING STONE. STONE I WOULD
I. FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS
THAT ARE NOT PRESENT I'M NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO SKIP OF TO ITEM
ELEVEN SINCE SENATOR LAYERED IS
ALREADY HERE THIS IS HIS BILL
SB SIX NINETEEN SO TO BE CLEAR
WE ARE NOW HEARING SB SIX
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
THANKS FOR CALLING THE DATING
OF THAT AND I WOULD LIKE TO
STAY I THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME AND MY STAFF ON THIS
PROPOSAL. I THINK I JUST ARE
WILL BE MORE APPRECIATED AFTER
THAT MOTION. HUH THANK WE WERE
TRYING TO DO TWO THINGS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLIONS IN THE
BUDGET WE'RE WORKING ON ON HOW
TO DEAL WITH PENALTIES AND THIS
YEAR ARE WE SUPPORT THE GENERAL
EFFORT TO MOVE TO THIS I WOULD
ASK FOR AN IPHONE. THANK YOU-
YOU HAVE ONE WITNESS-
REGISTEREDIN SUPPORT- DO WE
HAVE CAN BURKE MEN FROM THE
CITY OF BURBANK PUBLIC WORKS ON
THE LINE. RIGHT AWAY HE GOT
THANK YOU WHICH THAT THIS LOOKS
GOOD YES. YES WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND- PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO TWO
MINUTES. MISTER BERKMAN ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. YES THANK YOU-
GOOD MORNINGMADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN BURKE
WHEN PUBLIC WORKS DIRECTOR FOR
THE CITY BURBANK REPRESENTING
BURBANK AS WELL AS THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES AND IT CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. FIRST OFF
THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED AND
ALL YOUR STAFF ON THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL. AND FOR TRYING TO HELP
CITIES ESTABLISH REASONABLE AND
PRACTICAL IMPLEMENTATION
STANDARDS AND TIMELINES. FOR
THE STATE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE REGULATION. WITHOUT
QUESTION CITIES ARE COMMITTED
TO ACHIEVING THE STATE
GREENHOUSE GAS AND ORGANIC
WASTE DIVERSION GOALS BUT WE DO
NEED ADDITIONAL TIME AND
FLEXIBILITY TO COMPLY WITH THE
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION
REGULATIONS. AS FACTORS SUCH AS
THE TIMING OF OR WHEN THE
REGULATIONS WERE FINALIZED LAST
NOVEMBER. THE IMPACT OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
THE LACK OF STATE FUNDING OF
MADE IMPLEMENTATION AND MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT. SB SIX NINETEEN
WILL PROVIDE PROCESS FOR CITIES
TO WORK WITH CAL RECYCLE TO GET
WHEN YOU'RE RELIEF FROM
PENALTIES. IF THEY HAVE MADE
REASONABLE EFFORTS TO COMPLY.
BUT NOT MET THE JNUARY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO
IMPLEMENTATION DEADLINE. IN
BURBANK WE ARE WORKING ON
STARTING A FOOD WASTE PROGRAM.
IN OUR DOWNTOWN AND
ESTABLISHING A COMPOST FACILITY
AT OUR LANDFILL. BUT THERE'S
MUCH MORE WORK TO BE DONE.
ISSUES INCLUDE ESTABLISHING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ACTUALLY MOVE
EVERY SEAFOOD WASTE. AS WELL
SETTING BASELINES FOR THE
GENERATORS LIKE RESTAURANTS
WERE JUST STARTING O GET BACK
TO. PRE CODE LEVEL OPERATIONS.
AS WELL AS SETTING UP EFFECTIVE
PUBLIC OUTREACH PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE CONSTITUENTS KNOW WHAT
IS COMING. AND HOW TO COMPLY.
TO BE CLEAR SB SIX NINETEEN IS
NOT ROLLING BACK AND REPEALING
THE STATE'S ORGANIC WASTE
DIVERSION REGULATIONS AND THE
BILL HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
REVISED SINCE. SINCE ITS
ORIGINAL INTRODUCTION TO
ADDRESS OPPOSITION CONCERNS. IT
IS A GOOD MODIFICATION OF
PUBLIC POLICY THAT MAKES SENSE.
AND WILL STILL KEEP THE
ULTIMATE GOAL INTACT THAT
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU I'M
NEXT WE HAVE ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. MIZUHO YEN YEN YEP.
SHE ON THE LINE. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND HE IS VERY
YES I HAVE TWO MINUTES GOOD
MORNING. YEP EIGHT COMING UP ON
HERE I GO TO CITY COUNCILS TO
TALK ABOUT PLASTIC BANS. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I STARTED TO
HEAR ABOUT SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. INCREASINGLY IT GOT MY
ATTENTION ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
LACK OF REASONABLE EFFORTS.
THANK YOU ROOM I HAVE TALKED TO
JURISDICTIONS FROM NORTH
CULTURE SO CALL FROM COAST TO
INLAND INCLUDING SOME OF THOSE
THAT SAID YOUR SUPPORT LETTERS
FOR SB SIX NINETEEN. IT'S SAD
THAT I HEAR VERY LITTLE FROM
LOCAL POLITICIANS ABOUT
RESCUING FOOD FOR THE HUNGRY.
MUCH MORE OFTEN ICT POLITICAL
FEAR ABOUT THE RACING
COLLECTION HE- FOR INSTANCE
ALONG THE STATE'S WEALTHIEST
CITY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH RACING
CHIU DOLLAR FIFTY CENTS A
MONTH. FOR HEALTH HELP. YET
ACCORDING TO LA TIMES THE
TYPICAL AMERICAN ADULT WICKS
ABOUT THE SWEET DOLLAR FIFTY
CENTS WORTH OF FOOD EVERYDAY.
SO SENATOR NEARED WHAT IS A
REASONABLE AFFRIC IT'S SUBJECT
HERE IS A PLACEHOLDER FOR
POLITICS. AND POLITICS ACTUALLY
DOES NOT SOLVE FOOD INSECURITY
WHAT CLIMATE CHANGE. COMMITTEE
MEMBER CHRIS VOTED NO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE
ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM SEEN
NONE- I DON'T SEE ANY OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN IN
Q. OUR FIRST LINE WILL BE RIGHT
NOW ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ON THE ASSEMBLY DOES ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY'S UNPLUG
CONTENT HAPPENED BAY CUPERTINO
WALNUT CREEK CHINO HILLS TUSTIN
AND THE CITY OF SANTA CLARA ALL
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING I'M JOHN KENNEDY
WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORTED SB SIX NINETEEN ALL
HOPE YOU INDULGE ME TO SAY JUST
A FEW SENTENCES ABOUT THE BILL
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT THE NEW
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REGULATION- BUT SOME OF THOSE
COMPONENTS INCLUDING. WE'RE
ONLY TAKING ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND ASKING. FOR YOU
TO JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU OVER
TWENTY ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING IT'S PAUL YOU'RE A
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN NAPA AND MADERA
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BURKE
CRYSTAL YOU DON'T HAVE TO STOP
WASTE AFTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY SUBWAY SENSATION OF
NORTH AMERICA LED THE TASK
FORCE I HAVE A SUPPORT IN
CONTENT POSITION ON THE MEASURE
WE THINK THE SENATE ALL
COMMENTS MEASURES FAR THE YOUNG.
THANK YOU I WANT THREE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THERE
ABOUT TO LEAVE CITIES AND OF
THE SIX ONE NINE ONE I THINK
CENTER LAY INSTEAD ALL THE WORK
ON THE- THANK YOU MIGHT WONDER.
TWO GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CAPTAIN BERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND BANKING CENTER THERE FOR
HIS WORK ON THAT. THANK YOU ONE
ONE THIRTY EIGHT TRANSCRIBER.
ONE CALL MONDAY AFTER A
CALIFORNIA WE'RE CURRENTLY IN A
NEUTRAL POSITIONLIKE BETWEEN
ONE OR MORE DOGS ON THE BEACH
MARKETS LIKE RUSSIA OR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK. THANK YOU.
THANK I'M FIFTY THREE GOING.
GOOD MORNING THAT CHAIR MEMBERS
SHARING ON BEHALF OF THIS OF
CORONA INTO OF SB SIX ONE NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CITY OF BURBANK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK.
THANK YOU AROUND ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHEN
MEMBERS STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF
OF C. R. AND ARE INCORPORATED
IN SUPPORT WITH THE MINISTERS
DESCRIBED IN OUR SUBMITTED
LETTER. THANK YOU I ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHRISTINE GUERRERO WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DIVISION OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AT
THE PORT SB SIX ONE NINE. THANK
YOU I WON TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING COREY JONES
MANAGEMENT ANALYST FOR THE CITY
OF MENIFEE ANDSUPPORT SB. SIX
NINETEEN. THANK YOU I'M GOING
OUT TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MANAGER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BALKANS OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF LAKE
WOULD TORRANCE RANCHO CUCAMONGA
CAMERI- GLENDORA DIAMOND BAR
BARS THOUGH INDUSTRY PARAMOUNT
SIGNAL HILL AND IRWINDALE ALL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- MISTER SHARON MEMBER
AT MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ENGINE MINETTI WITH- ON BEHALF
OF ENERGY- WE'RE REGISTERING
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL WE WOULD
VERY MUCH LIKE TO SEE THE BILL
AMENDED- SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS
RECOMMENDED IN THE AN OUTFIT
THAT WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YASSER ARAFAT AT
THE BILL PROGRESS. THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE FORTY
EIGHTH PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TERM MEMBERS BRIDGET
MCHALE B. HAPPENS RETHINK BASED
ON THE VISION OF SUPPORT
CONCEPT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BYE ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY. ONE FOUR NINE. AND I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT WILL OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
C. ARE TOLD BY. SENATOR LARRY
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL AND WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF CITIES I
KNOW THEY WERE. DESPERATELY
TRYING TO ADDRESS- THIS THIS IS
THE UNDERLYING BILL- EARLY ON-
BECAUSE OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF IT AND ITS EFFECT ON CITIES-
AND ALSO THAT THE OTHER.
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED- IT AND
I'M JUST I WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND ALSO LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. ON
THIS ON THIS BILL AND BECAUSE I
SUPPORT WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
BUT IT ALSO FALLS WOEFULLY
SHORT OF ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES THAT THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE HAS- LAID UPON ON ON THE
CITY'S- YEAH THERE ARE ISSUES
WITH PROCARE THAT PROCUREMENT.
OF THE ORGANIC MATERIAL- THAT
HAVE. HAVE YET TO BE EVEN
DISCUSSED. AND ALSO THE
MANDATORY COLLECTION- FOR
REMOTE LOOK AT JURISDICTIONS OR
CITIES THAT. ARE OUT IN THE
MIDDLE OF NOWHERE- THE LIFE
BEING ONE OF THOSE CITIES. FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO COMPLY WITH
THE ELEMENTS OF THIS ACTUALLY
PUSHES THEM INTO AN AREA WHERE
THERE BEING LESS
ENVIRONMENTALLY. AND
RESPONSIBLE THAN IF THEY WERE
TO BE COMPLYING WITH THIS SO
THOSE ARE OTHER THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE REPORTING
TIMELINES ARE TOTALLY
UNREALISTIC FOR THIS BILL- I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK WE'VE LEARNED A LESSON
AND ONE OF THE BILLS WERE GONNA
HERE IN A LITTLE BIT. WHICH IS
SB FIVE NINETY SIX THE PERFECT
EXAMPLE. OF ENGAGING THE-
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN-
EARLY ON IN OFTEN- TO GET THEIR
INPUT ON WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN'T. BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THIS
PROGRAM WORKS. AND AND SO I
THINK- THERE'S A LESSON TO BE
LEARNED THERE. AND I HOPE THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
PROBLEM BECAUSE- WE CAN DELAY
THE IMPLEMENTATION A LITTLE BIT
WITH THIS BILL. ARE SOME OF THE
ELEMENTS OF IT. BUT IF WE DON'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE OTHER
STUFF WE'RE GONNA BE RIGHT BACK
HERE AGAIN NEXT YEAR TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THE EXACT SAME
PROBLEMS- SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU TOOK THIS
ON. AND AND WORKED WITH THE
LEAGUE AND ADDRESS THIS ISSUE-
WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO ON IT
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE AND IN
TRYING TO SUPPORT WHATEVER IT
IS THAT. YOU WOULD LIKE TO DO
IN THE FUTURE CONTINUE TO DO
AND- YEAH TO ADDRESS THIS IT
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT. I THANK YOU CENTER
LAYER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- I MY HOME COUNTY
CINEMA COUNTY HAD A ROBUST-
COMPOST FACILITY- AT THE
LANDFILL THAT OPERATED FOR OVER
A DECADE- WE HAVE- IT WAS SHUT
DOWN THERE WERE LAWSUITS
NEIGHBORS DIDN'T LIKE IT- WE
HAVE A CONTINUED GROWING
PROBLEM WITH ORGANIC WASTE YOU
CAN'T COMPOST AT ALL AT HOME
YOU KEEP AND YET WERE UNDER
UNDER SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES.
JUST THIS MONTH NEGOTIATIONS
FELL THROUGH FOR ANOTHER
FACILITY TO BE OPENED UP
THROUGH FINANCING SO- SO THESE
YOU KNOW THERE ARE CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT ARE ABSOLUTE
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
CITING THESE FACILITIES IS
CHALLENGING- BUILDING THEM IS
COSTLY- WE WANT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND WE'RE WE'VE BEEN
TRYING SINCE YOU KNOW SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN WHEN
LAWSUIT SHUT DOWN AT THE
EXISTING FACILITIES SO I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. I AM ALSO IT'S A SHAME
IT'S TAKEN FOUR YEARS FOR THE
RAGS TO COME OUT I THINK- BUT
THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER ISSUE-
BUT I APPRECIATE PROJECT WORK
ON THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES I
THINK- THE COMMENTS GAVE TWO
DISTINCT OUR PERSPECTIVES THE
END OF THE GREAT THING IS THAT
WHEN I STARTED DOING THIS BILL
IT HAS MORPHED IN A COUPLE OF
WAYS ONE IS TO DEAL JUST WITH
THE PENALTIES SO THAT CITIES
CAN STILL MAKE THE REASONABLE
AFFECTED THOSE THAT HAVE
INVESTED THEIR INVESTMENT IS
STILL GOOD IN THEIR INVESTMENT
IS STILL VALID. AND I OR
WHETHER IT WAS PART OF THIS
EFFORT BUT NOT THE FACT THAT
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS HAS GONE INTO THE
BUDGET TO DO THIS WILL MAKE A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE AND WE
ARE STILL WORKING ON SOME OF
THESE ISSUES AND WILL TAKE
AMENDMENTS IN APPROPRIATIONS IF
WE NEED TO DO OR FURTHER ON
DOWN THE LINE. AND THERE MAY
EVEN BE A NEED TO DO SOMETHING
IF THE BUDGET- IS ADOPTED
WITHOUT LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER
BILL TO DEAL WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT BUDGET
FUNDING AND SO WE WILL USE THIS
BILL TO ADDRESS ALL THOSE
ISSUES ARE PER SHARE. AGAIN
TAKING ME- THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORISTS SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SU CHI THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM ELEVEN SB SIX NINETEEN
BY SENATOR LAYERED MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA
I CHAU. FRIEDMAN GARCIA AYE
GARCIA AYE MATHIS AYE MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI WELL TO I'D OUR
TOTAL KERR SAY OUR TWO EYES
STONE STONE I WOULD I WOULD I
NINE ZERO THANK YOU MADAME
CHIANG ZERO APPLES OUT BELIEVE
IT OPENED FOR MEMBERS THAT ARE
NOT PRESENT THANK YOU SENATOR.
NOW WILL GO BACK TO FILE ORDER.
WE'RE ON ITEM SEVEN- SB FIVE
NINETY SIX BY IT SENATOR BACK
BECKER WELCOME TO NATURAL
RESOURCES. THANK YOU JERRY THIS
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GIMMICK EMISSIONS
AND THE CEMENT AND CONCRETE
SECTORS IN CALIFORNIA. CONCRETE
AND CEMENT ARE VITAL FOR OUR
ECONOMY IN FACT YOU ARE HERE TO
MASON STEP RECENT STUDY
ESTIMATED A CONCRETE ACCOUNTS
FOR HALF THE WEIGHT OF
EVERYTHING EVER MADE BY
HUMANITY. IN OUR HISTORY. I'M
FORTY IS ALSO A MAJOR SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GASES ACCOUNTED FOR
SEVEN PERCENT. OF CARBON
EMISSIONS GLOBALLY. AND THE
SECOND LEADING. SOURCE OF
INDUSTRIAL MISSIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. MOOSE'S MISSIONS
RUN 90% ACTUALLY COME FROM
MAKING CEMENT WHICH IS THE GLUE
THAT HOLDS CONCRETE TOGETHER.
AND SINCE WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE INCREASING OUR USE OF
CONCRETE CEMENT NOT DECREASING.
ITS IMPORT WE FIGURED HOW TO
TRANSITION- Q. MAKING IT WITH
FAR LESS IMPACT ON OUR CLIMATE.
GOOD NEWS IS THAT TECHNOLOGIES
AND PROCESSES NOW EXIST FOR
ACHIEVING LARGE REDUCTIONS IN
EMISSIONS FROM CEMENT
PRODUCTION. IN THE TO HAVE NOT
BEEN DEPLOYED AT SCALE BECAUSE
WE HAVE HAD THE RIGHT POLICIES
IN PLACE TO BOTH ENCOURAGE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS AND
INCREASED DEMAND FOR LOW CARBON
BUILDING PRODUCTS OF THIS BILL
IS REALLY ABOUT ENCOURAGING
THOSE EMISSIONS. ARE BACK WITH
ANOTHER BILL WHICH IS OF THE
DEMAND THE DEMAND SIDE FOR LOW
CARBON. BUILDING PRODUCTS.
EVERY WORD IN THIS BILL WE
FOUND THIS MINISTRY TO BE A
VERY WILLING PARTNER IN
ACHIEVING THESE GOALS. AS LONG
AS THEY CAN CREATE SUPPORTIVE
POLICY ENVIRONMENT AND ADDRESS.
BARRIERS THAT EXIST TODAY.
EXACTLY CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CEMENT ASSOCIATION PUBLISHES ON
PAPER IN MARCH. FROM INJURIES
COMMITMENT ACHIEVING CARBON
NEUTRALITY. BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE AND IDENTIFYING OBSTACLES.
SO THIS BILL AIMS TO CREATE THE
RIGHT SUPPORT OF A POLICY
ENVIRONMENT. TO ACHIEVE THAT
GOAL OF CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. AND IT DROVE
THE STRATEGY FOR THE KEEPING
THESE TARGETS WELL PROTECTING
PRODUCERS. WHO DO SO FROM
UNFAIR COMPETITION FROM OUT OF
STATE PRODUCERS WILL NOT BE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME RULES. THAT
THE COMMITTEE- IN YOUR STEPS
OPPOSED AMENDMENT TO CLARIFY
THE CARD MAY ADJUST THE INTERIM
TARGETS DURING THE TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT MID TERM CHECK AND
NOT JUST PROPOSED TO AMEND
THEM. AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THAT AMENDMENT. WE'VE TO
WITNESSES THIS MORNING. AT TWO
AM THEIR SUPPORT HOURS JACKSON
AN EXPERT FROM ENERGY C. AND
TOM TATE'S EXACT DIRECTOR OF A
CALIFORNIA FATHER SMITH SOCIUS.
THANK YOU WERE READY FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR OUR WITNESSES. AND
WHAT I WANNA REMIND WITNESSES
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. GOOD MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS ALEX JACKSON ON
BEHALF OF ENERGY C. RECONNOITER
THIS BILL IS ABOUT CREATING A
POLICY ENVIRONMENT CONDUCIVE TO
SHRINKING AND ULTIMATELY
ELIMINATING AMOUNTS CARBON
FOOTPRINT. THAT IS AN URGENT
TASK CONCRETE IS THE MOST
WIDELY CONSUMED MATERIAL ON
EARTH AS A SENATOR NOTED CEMENT
PRODUCTION ALONE CONTRIBUTES
ABOUT 8% GLOBAL CO TWO OUTPUT.
CEMEX FIGHT TO CALIFORNIA'S
EMISSIONS PIPES MARC THAT IS
OUR LARGEST INDUSTRIAL SOURCE
OF CARBON POLLUTION AFTER OIL
AND GAS AND OF COURSE
GREENHOUSE GASES NO NO BORDER
WE WILL REST MISSING OUR
TARGETS IN A MEETING POLITICAL
TO ESCALATING CLIMATE IMPACTS
WE CONTINUE. TO OVERLOOK THE
SECTOR. WE HAVE A COULD.
INDUSTRY PARLANCE WE HAVE A
CLEAR SO. THE BUILT OFF SUCCESS
MODEL CALIFORNIA HAS EMPLOYED
TO JUMPSTART INNOVATION IN
OTHER SECTORS. BY SEVENTEEN THE
GOLD CRITERIA IN LAYING OUT A
PROCESS. WELL FORTY ROOM FOR
AIR BEING STAKEHOLDERS TO
PROVIDE INPUT ON THE BEST
PASSPORT THROUGH WILL MAKE.
THANKFULLY THAT PASSPORT IS
COMING INTO FOCUS IMPROVED
EFFICIENCY FUEL SEARCHING.
INCREASED USE OF LESS POLLUTING
EMISSIONS MATERIALS CAN ALL
PROVIDE NEAR TERM PRODUCTION.
WHILE FIGHTING INNOVATIONS IN
TRANSFORM THE CARBON MANAGEMENT
TECHNOLOGIES HOLD. THE PROMISE
TO ACHIEVE NET ZERO. PROBABLY
NEEDED TO DEPLOYED THE COUNTRY
WE HAVE LEFT FOR IT CLIMB. THAT
IS WHAT FIVE NINE EXTRA. IT'S A
FAIR AMOUNT TARGETS TO PROVIDE
THE NEEDED CERTAINTY AND
ECONOMIC INCENTIVES TO
JUMPSTART INVESTMENT. ENSURES
IMPORTS ARE COVERED TO PROVIDE
A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD AND A
PRIORITIZE ACTIONS THAT SERVE
OTHER ESSENTIAL GOALS. SUCH AS
IMPROVING LOCAL AIR QUALITY.
LEVERAGING FEDERAL INCENTIVES
TO SUPPORT ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
EVERYBODY HERE IS ALSO A
FRAMEWORK THAT THE INDUSTRY IS
READY TO EMBRACE AND INVEST IN
THE MAKE CALIFORNIANS LOCALLY
TO INCREASE DEMAND. KIND OF A
SIGNIFICANT AND SHE MEANT AND
ONE THAT IN OUR VIEW. AMERICAN
IDOL TODAY THANKS. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WITNESS IS IN THE-
ROOM. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TOM TO EAT
SOME OF THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA CEMENT
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPLY THE
CEMENT OUR MEMBERS SUPPLY THE
CEMENT FOR CALIFORNIA THEY
CONTINUE TO BE COLLABORATIVE
WITH CARB IN REACHING THE
STATE'S EMISSIONS GOALS. I WANT
TO THANK THE COMPLEMENT OF THE
CENTER BACKER HIS STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL FOR BEING
VERY OPEN AT TO PRODUCTIVE AND
HELPFUL DIALOGUE IN CREATING A
BILL HERE THAT REACHES A
CRITICAL. POINTS OF AGREEMENT
ON HOW WE MOVE FORWARD. AND IN
THAT LIGHT WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND SEE IT BEING A GREAT
ASSISTANCE TO US IN REACHING
OUR CARBON NEUTRALITY GOALS FOR
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO WE WILL NOW TAKE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION- PLEASE JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. OF ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEN NOT. AS THERE ARE NONE IN
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE NINETY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AT TEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
ABOUT FIFTEEN IN CUBA MARK
TWAIN ONE FIFTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MELISSA ROMERO AT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE ENTER. ONE
CALL. ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RUN ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS JANET **** SUPPORT
THREE FIFTY VALLEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT ALONG WITH THEIR KIND
NAY NO CLIMATE COALITION.
FINANCIAL INTERFACE CLIMATE
ACTION AND THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RYAN WHAT YOU PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS PAUL
BECAUSE ALL THE ZOMBIE ON THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WE HADN'T
OPPOSE POSITION BUT WITH THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS WE ARE NOT
NEUTRAL WITH WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR WORKING
WITH US. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BYE ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SIR MEMBERS
CUTTING UP WITH EACH YEAR
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF
SB FIVE NINETY SIX ON BEHALF OF
EACH USE TWO THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED BUSINESS MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE NINE.
FIND ONE OF SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AARON RODRIGUEZ THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. RIGHT
ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IRANIANS DO SO THE WEIDEMANN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF BLUE PLANET
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU RUN ONE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO OUT. HI THIS
IS BROOKE HODGE ON BEHALF OF MY
MOST PARK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR A
COMMITTEE THIS IS MICHAEL
ROCKSMITH ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY SOUTH PLANNED LEGISLATIVE
A LINE. AND ALSO THREE FIFTY
SOUTH BAY LOS ANGELES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIX FIVE
NINETY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WINDOWS
SHELL WITH A KILLER COMMONALITY
DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN SUNNYDALE
DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE S. B. FIVE
NINETY SIX. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS BILL MURPHY ON BEHALF
OF ELDERS CLIMATE ACTIONS NOR
CAL AND SOQUEL CHAPTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT WILL MOVED TO QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ALL START
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATOR I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
HARD WORKING IN EXPRESSLY MORE
SO FOR WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY- HERE TOO OFTEN THAN
NOT WE SEE A LOT OF LEGISLATION
THAT COMES UP WITH NEW
REGULATIONS AND NEW THINGS.
AND- WE DON'T ALWAYS SEE
INDUSTRY SUPPORTING THE
REGULATIONS THAT WERE PUTTING
ON THEM AND WHEN WE DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT AND THAT WE
SUPPORT THAT BECAUSE A LOT OF
TIMES I KNOW THE MEMBERS ON MY
SIDE OF THE AISLE OR LIKE WHERE
THE INDUSTRY GUYS AT WHAT'S
GOING ON. IN SO I THINK IT'S
WORTH WHILE TO KNOW YOUR HARD
WORK IN GETTING THE INDUSTRY TO
SUPPORT THIS- WE DO THIS A LOT
OF THE AGRICULTURAL SIDE- WHERE
A LOT OF MY WILL HOUSE AND
BACKGROUND IS IN IN WHATEVER
INDUSTRY SAYING HEY WE NEED
YOUR HELP HERE THIS IS WHAT WE
THINK WE CAN DO MOVING FORWARD
IN THE LEGISLATOR. FOLLOWS THAT
AND LISTENS TO THAT IT'S WORTH
NOTING AND WORTH RECOGNIZING
AND FOR THAT REASON I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL. MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SOME REFERENCE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORIDA. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR A CENTER AND I ALSO JUST
KIND ON ECHO THE COMMENTS OF-
MY COLLEAGUES. I THINK THIS IS
THE- THE WAY OF THE FUTURE FOR
INDUSTRIES WORKING TOGETHER
WITH OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITIES. TO DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE SUSTAINABLE
FOR EVERYBODY RIGHT. AND THIS
IS SO EXCITING TO ME I MEAN YES
COMING FROM AND I BACKGROUND
WE'VE DONE THIS A LOT. WHEN I
SPOKE WITH THE INDUSTRY THE
SIEMENS FOCUSED ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. I WAS
INCREDIBLY ENCOURAGED THAT THEY
WERE COMING TO THE TABLE THEY
WERE BEING PROACTIVE HAVE A
GREAT SO DO CARRIED LEGISLATION
FOR THEM. SO I'M EXCITED TO
SUPPORT THIS AND I THINK TO ALL
THE OTHER INDUSTRIES OUT THERE.
TAKE NOTE. BECAUSE THIS IS THE
PATHWAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER I WANTED TO WELCOME YOU
TO THE ASSEMBLY SIDE I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS IS ONE OF YOUR
FIRST BILLS ON TO BE PRESENTING
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE BUT- I'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO. WORKING WITH
YOU ON ON THIS AND MANY OTHER
IMPORTANT BILLS THAT YOU'RE
WORKING ON- I WANT TO. JOIN A
THE BIPARTISAN APPRECIATION FOR
YOU WORKING WITH THE-
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CEMENT
ASSOCIATION. AND I KNOW I NOTED
THAT- IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THAT- THE ASSOCIATION PUBLISHED
A PAPER IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR
AFFIRMING THE INDUSTRY'S
COMMITMENT TO ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. AND AND SO LIKE I AGAIN I
WOULD TO ECHO MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES IN THE- AND-
THANKING THE ASSOCIATION FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP AND THEIR
COMMITMENT TO. GET TO THIS
IMPORTANT GOAL. I HAD A
QUESTION. V. COMMITTEE AND ALSO
IT'S ALSO TALKS ABOUT HOW.
THERE WAS A- TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORT CALIFORNIA CEMENT
INDUSTRY FAILING TO FAILING THE
CLIMATE CHALLENGE. WORD
INDICATED THAT- THE CALIFORNIA
CEMENT INDUSTRY. HAD THE SECOND
HIGHEST CO TWO EMISSIONS
INTENSITY AMONG THE COUNTRIES
STUDIED. 57% HIGHER THAN THAT
OF THE CEMENT INDUSTRY IN
CHINA- DUE IN PART TO A HIGHER
CLINKER TO CEMENT RACIAL I WAS
WONDERING WHAT- WHAT CHINA IS
DOING THAT WE'RE NOT DOING. I
CAN SPEAK TO. I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THE RATIO ITSELF- I WOULD SAY
YOU KNOW THE ENERGY INTENSITY
COMES FROM TWO PARTS ONE IS THE
BUT 40% IS JUST BECAUSE VERY
ENERGY INTENSIVE TO MAKE SO
WHAT DO WE USE THAT AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT ACTUALLY COUNTS
FOR CHINA'S USE OF COAL IN MOST
CASES TO MAKE- THEIR CEMENT.
AND IT'S 60% IS THE PROCESS
EMISSIONS SUCH AS THE
PROSECUTION'S FOR MAKING A
CEMENT AND THAT'S WHERE THE
INNOVATION REALLY CAN COME IN
IF YOU CAPTURE THAT CAN RESTORE
THAT IN WILL BE ENCOURAGING
THAT- IN THIS BILL SO- I CAN'T
COME IN THE STUDY I DON'T KNOW
IF THE WITNESSES ANY COMMENTS
ON THAT BUT ICAN'T SAY I THINK
THIS WILL MAKE US THE LEADER
AND I'M VERY CONFIDENT THAT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEVEN COMMENT
ON. WITNESS CERTAINLY. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND. THAT REPORT THAT WAS
RELEASED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
PROVIDED SOME VERY MISLEADING
INFORMATION AND UNEQUAL
PERFORMANCE ARE UNABLE
COMPARISONS TO THE TYPES OF
CEMENT THAT'S PRODUCED IN CHINA
VERSUS THE UNITED STATES. WE DO
THINGS DIFFERENTLY HERE WE
ALLOW THE CONCRETE PRODUCERS
THAT BY CEMENT. TO ADD
ADDITIONAL PRODUCTS TO REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN TO CALIFORNIA OR OTHER
STATES SO IT'S REALLY TWO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PRODUCTION.
SO IT'S AN UNFAIR COMPARISON
ARE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
MEMBERS SAY ARE TOP RIGHT I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING EVERYBODY
HAS SAID ABOUT WORKING TOGETHER
WITH THE INDUSTRY AND HOW MUCH
EASIER THAT WITH THAT WORKS-
AND IT ALSO IS BENEFICIAL TO
ACTUALLY ACHIEVING SOME OF
THESE GOALS WHETHER PEOPLE
AGREE WITH THEM OR NOT- THOSE
ARE THE GOALS AND- AND SO THE
DAY I APPLAUD YOU FOR WORKING
WITH THEM TO DO THAT- YOU KNOW
ONE OF MY CONCERNS ALSO AND I
THINK EVERYBODY SHOULD BE
CONCERNED IS. IS TO AN AND I
WOULD EXPECT THE CEMENT
INDUSTRY WILL WILL HAVE A KEEN
EYE TOWARD JUST AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO WORK WITH
THEM IS IN IN OUR EFFORTS TO
CREATE A MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY CEMENT WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE BUILDINGS LIKE
THIS STATE OVERHEAD WHEN WE'RE
HAVING EARTHQUAKES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT- YOU SEE THE- THE
EFFECTS OF SUB STANDARD CEMENT-
PRODUCTS IN OTHER COUNTRIES
WHEN THEY DO HAVE- DISASTERS
THEY ARE MUCH LESS- RESILIENT
THAN WE ARE. AND AND MUCH MORE
LETHAL AND SO- AND I THINK THIS
APPROACH ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE
THAT INPUT AND BE ABLE TO-
BALANCE THAT OUT WITHOUT HAVING
A ONE SIDED APPROACH THAT LATER
ON WE FIND OUT- WE'VE JUST
WEAKENED THE INTEGRITY OF THE
CEMENT PRODUCT AND- BEYOND-
WHAT IS SAFE FOR OUR OUR
PUBLICATIONS AT THE END OF THE
DAY THAT SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC
IS OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A BILL
INTENDED SUPPORTED. TODAY
BECAUSE OF THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE SENATOR BAKER YOU.
BY A- FROM THE COMMITTEE. ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. SURE NOT JUST AT
THE LAST MOMENT WHEN WE COME
BACK WITH A CONCRETE BILL
YOU'LL SEE. GENERALLY THE STATE
PROCUREMENT PIECE OF IT.
RUSSIAN MOVING FROM EXACTLY
WHAT'S IN IT TO THE PERFORMANCE
SPECIFICATIONS THAT'S REALLY
WHAT'S IMPORTANT SO WE WANNA
MAKE SURE. THAT THE PERFORMANCE
OF THE SPECIFICATIONS ARE CLEAR
AND THE SAFETY IS NOT
COMPROMISED ANYWAY SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. OVERALL IT'S
JUST EXTREMELY. PLEASED WITH A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AS WE WORK
TO. DECARBONISE ONE OF THE
HARDEST TO DECARBONISE
INDUSTRIES AND AS CALIFORNIA
GOES HOW GOES SO GOES THE
COUNTRY. AND I THINK THIS WILL
HAVE GLOBAL IMPACTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I RESPECTFULLY
QUESTION I VOTE. THANK YOU- I
DON'T HAVE A MOTION FOR THE
AGENTS OR DID I HAVE I'M SORRY.
HI OKAY MATHIS. SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLY. FLORA OF THE MOTION.
WHICH IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON ITEM SEVEN SB
FIVE NINETY SIX BY SENATOR-BECKER MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVAS
FIVE FLORA. FLORA I'D CHAU.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA.
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I SAY ARE TOO HIGH
C. A. R. TôI STONE STONE I
WOULD. TEN ZERO AND- YOU HAVE A
RENDON. BY LATE NIGHT SB. EIGHT
OH FOUR. I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN I
DON'T FILE NINE A SENSE OF
SENATOR GLAZERS S. B. EIGHT
ZERO FOUR. SECOND THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. LET ME
JUST THANK AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE
WONDERFUL ASSEMBLY CO AUTHORS
OF THIS MEASURE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
POWER QUE HAN LEVINE MULLIN
QUIRK AND ANALYTICS ALL COME
TOGETHER TO PROPOSE THIS BILL
THAT WOULD CREATE A NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CENTER TO TRAIN
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IN FORESTRY IN
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WE ALL
KNOW THE DESTRUCTION OF. THAT
WITH EXPERIENCE IN THE FIRE
SEASON OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS AND OUT OF THAT- THOSE
CATASTROPHES IN THE SENATE WE
FORMED A WORKING GROUP ON
WILDFIRES- AND I TRIED TO
IDENTIFIED. DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
COLLECTIVELY AND THIS BILL IS
ONE OF THOSE BILLS THAT HAVE
COME OUT OF THAT WORKING GROUP
OF PACKAGE- IT'S PROPOSED AT
THE CENTER- BE A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. AND IT WOULD
ACCOMPLISH THOSE GOALS OF
EXPANDING OUR WORKFORCE. AND
IMPLEMENTING A VEGETATION
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT PLAN- I AM.
HAPPY TO ANSWER A DETAILED
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL I DO
HAVE A WITNESS HERE TO TESTIFY-
THAT IS GARCIA FROM THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONAUT VOTE.
AND WE'RE READY FOR THE WITNESS
AND SUPPORT MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE. YES I
WANTED OPEN. THANK YOU HI CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MICHELLE GARCIA I AS A
PROGRAM COORDINATOR FOR VENTURA
TRAINING CENTER WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHT- SB EIGHT
ZERO FOUR. A. R. C. WORKS TO
END MASS INCARCERATION IN
CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE OUR
COMPUTING COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE
HEALTHY AND WHOLE A. R. C.
EMPOWERS FORMERLY AND CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO THRIVE
BY PROVIDING A SUPPORT NETWORK
COMPREHENSIVE REENTRY SERVICES
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO ADVOCATE
FOR POLICY CHANGE THERE ARE
GRASSROOTS POLICY AT THIS
ADVOCACY WE ARE DEDICATED TO
THAT TRANSFORMING THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM SO THAT IT IS
MARCH AUSTIN EQUAL FOR ALL
PEOPLE. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AREAS HE JOINED THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
ALSO KNOWN AS CAL FIRE I
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION TO DEVELOP AND
ENHANCE FIREFIGHTING TRAINING
AND CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
ADVENTURER TRAINING CENTER ALSO
KNOWN AS BTC PARTICIPANTS AT
BTC FORMER OFFENDERS ON PAROLE
WHO HAVE RECENTLY BEEN PART OF
A TRAINED TO FIRE FIGHTING
WORKFORCE HOUSED IN FIRE CAMPS
ARE INSTITUTIONAL FIRE HOUSES
OPERATED BY CAL FIRE AND CDCR.
I HAVE DEVOTED MY LIFE TO
SUPPORT THE CURRENT AND
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED AFTER
SERVING TIME MYSELF WHERE I
EVENTUALLY PAROLED AS IN
INCARCERATED FIREFIGHTER. IN
MALIBU CALIFORNIA. DUE TO THE
FACT BREAKING WORK AT BEING
SURFACED MY CAN. I IN THE CAR
FIREFIGHTER I WAS ABLE TO FIND
A FOUNDATION MY HEALING AFTER
BEING DEEPLY TRAUMATIZED AND
PRESIDENT WHERE I WAS STRIPPED
OF MY DIGNITY REMOVE FROM THE
LIFE OF MY FOUR CHILDREN. AND
LEFT WITH YEARS OF SHAME AND
FEAR COMPETENCE TO MANEUVER
THROUGH. THIS FOUNDATION CAME
FROM MY LIVING OUT MY IMMENSE
PROTECTING THE SAME COMMUNITIES
I ONCE BROUGHT HARM TO. SENATE
NOT BUILT FOR HEALING
ESPECIALLY FOR WOMEN SO
CHOOSING TO COMPLETE MY TEN
YEAR FOUR YEAR. TENURE FOUR
MONTH PRISON SENTENCE EMPIRE
CAMP SEEM LIKE THE ONLY LOGICAL
CHANCE OF KEEPING MYSELF
SOMEWHAT SANE AND MOSTLY
IMPORTANT MY FAMILY TOGETHER.
SIMILAR TO MY EXPERIENCE OF
FIRE CAMP THE PARTICIPANTS AT
BTC ARE ABLE TO FIND THEIR
HIGHER SELVES. THEY SPEND
ENDLESS HOURS WORKING SIDE BY
SIDE WITH CAL FIRE. AND
CAPTAINS CONTINUOUSLY REMINDING
THEM OF THEIR VALUE AND WORTH
BEFORE LONG THEY PICK UP THE
SAME TOPICS AND WORK ETHICS AND
THEY BEGIN TO SEE THE
SIMILARITIES INSTEAD OF THE
DIFFERENCES. AFTER A FEW MONTHS
YOU SEE THE MEN WALK A LITTLE
TALLER SPEAK MORE CONFIDENTLY
AND DIGGING DEEPER INTO HEALING
THEIR OWN TRAUMA. FOR
THEMSELVES BUT ALSO FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. AGAIN THE CURRENT.
YEAH WE'RE OVER YEAH THANK YOU
AWARE OF IT SECOND CHANCE IS
SOMETHING YOU CAN'T TRACER
DOCUMENT S. B. EIGHT OH FOUR
REPRESENT ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE AMPLE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED TO BREAK
THIS CYCLE OF RECIDIVISM. BY
ALL AND OFFERING ADDITIONAL
PASSED AWAY STEP THE FILLING
CAREERS AND FORESTRY AND
BUDGETARY MANAGEMENT. IT'S FOR
THESE REASONS THREE URGE YOU TO
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION TO
WILL NOW TAKE. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OF DO WE HAVE ANY
IN THE HEARING ROOM I BELIEVE
WE DO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT OF SENATOR GLAZERS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I DON'T
SEE ANY AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
LOCATION- A MODERATOR KEY
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF S. B. EIGHT OH
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ABOUT
TWO IN Q. WILL GO TO ONE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GLAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ALEX TOWARDS ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN FOREST
FOUNDATION OF TRANSPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MANAGER MEMBERS AS FUND UNIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND SOCIAL
CHANGE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- CENTER OVER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN THE
SPACE- VITAL PROGRAM AND I'D
LOVE. CO AUTHOR ON THIS
LEGISLATION MOVING FORWARD TO
HELP YOU SHOW SOME BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY
ARE TOUGH. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF HAD
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WORKING
ALONGSIDE SOME OF THESE OTHER
MAY CREWS. AND THEY ARE
INVALUABLE TO THE EFFORT- AND
IT IS ALSO INVALUABLE TO THEM-
IS A- DEVELOP. AND BECOME MORE
BETTER LEADERS YEAH EVEN
AMONGST THEMSELVES- PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS ARE MUCH NEEDED WE
NEED WE NEED TO WORK WE NEED A
CRUISE TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT
THERE AND DO SOME OF THE WORK
THAT WE ARE IDENTIFYING THAT
NEEDS DONE TO MITIGATE- SOME OF
OUR- FIRE ISSUES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I THINK IT'S GOOD FOR
EVERYONE AND- I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING IT WOULD LIKELY HAD
A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THEY WERE MCCARTY. YES
THANK YOU I KNOW THIS IS A LOVE
FEST HERE AND I THINK THIS IS
A- GREAT WORK IN A FEW YEARS
AGO I BOUGHT IT BECAUSE TO I
BOUGHT ONE A MATHIS. IS
CONSTITUENTS UP HERE- WAS- IN
IN MADE IN STATE PRISON AND AS
A INMATE HE FOUGHT FIRES RIGHT
WHEN E GOT OUT HE WAS ON.
PAROLE FOR THREE OR THREE TO
SOMETHING YOU'RE A THREE TO
FIVE YEARS. AND HE COULDN'T GO
FIGHT FIRES WITH THE
CONSERVATION CORPS. AND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE NOT
BECOME A STATISTIC AS FAR THE
RECIDIVISM AND HELP SO WE DID.
WORK ON TO LAWS THAT I AUTHORED
TO ALLOW PEOPLE ON PAROLE AND
PROBATION. TO PARTICIPATE BUT
THIS GOES A STEP FURTHER AND
PROVIDES MORE TRAINING AND SO.
I THINK IT'S- RIGHT ON IT RIGHT
JUST AS FAR AS HELPING PEOPLE
RE INTEGRATE BACK INTO. SOCIETY
BUT ALSO DEAL WITH AN ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE ON THE-
PREVENTING- FIRES IN DEALING
WITH OUR- OUR TIMBER INDUSTRY
SO- THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I WILL TAKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY IS A TERRIFIC A
SUMMARY AS MY CLOTHES AND THANK
THAT WOULD FIT COLLEAGUES ON
THE PANEL WILL ALSO OFFERED. TO
CO AUTHOR IT IT'S A- PROJECT
THAT VERY MUCH THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONAUT ABOUT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO PUBLIC SAFETY SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON ITEM
NINE SB EIGHT OH FOUR GLAZER.
MEMBERS RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLORA.
CHAU FRIEDMAN I GARCIA. MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY I THANK YOU
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO
G. I.'S HERE TO SAY ARSENAL
EYES STONE. SO I WOULD. SEVEN
ZERO SEVEN ZERO LEAVE THAT OPEN
TRANSITIONAL TO ALL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. NEXT WE HAVE A FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN SENATOR
GONZALEZ SB SEVEN TWO SIX.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND START WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I GOOD MORNING- MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SAID TODAY IN
PRESENTING SENATE BILL SEVENTY
SIX WHICH MAKES THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM MORE
EQUITY FOCUSED I WILL COOK WILL
CHOIR COLLABORATIVE INTERAGENCY
PLANNING TO EFFICIENTLY PROMOTE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. SB TWO SEVEN TWO
SIX WITH VANCE EQUITY BY
SPECIFYING THAT AT LEAST 50% OF
FUTURE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
DOLLARS BENEFIT INDIVIDUALS.
AND DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
REQUIRING DIRECT INVESTMENTS IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES AS WELL. SB
SEVENTY SIX ALSO ADDS MARKET
STABILITY BY PRIORITIZING MULTI
YEAR PROJECTS FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING- IT ALSO
PLANS FOR THE FUTURE OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION BY CREATING A
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
STRATEGY WHICH WILL IDENTIFY
AND DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO
ACHIEVE EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
GOALS. IT WILL TAKE A BROAD
LOOK AT OUR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS
INCLUDING BMT REJECT REDUCTION
TRANSIT AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY IS MEREDITH
ALEXANDER REPRESENTING CAL
START AND BILL MCGOVERN THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR THANK
YOU THANK YOU- WHY DON'T WE
START WITH MR MCGOVERN SINCE
HE'S PRESENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM AS OUR FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL IF THAT'S
YOUR PLEASURE MADAM CHAIR OF A
CAL STAR IS THE SPONSOR SO I
DEFER TO THEM EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE ON THE PHONE. OKAY GO
AHEAD. SIR WE WILL SPEND START
WITH. MEREDITH ALEXANDER. FROM
CAL START MODERATED MORNING
OPEN UP THE LINE YES THANK.
PLEASE GO AHEAD MORNING CHAIR
RIVAS AND NUMBERS. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY GREAT. ALEXANDER HERE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CAL START-
WE ARE THE SPONSOR AND SB SEVEN
TWENTY SIX AND WE WISH TO THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND ALSO OF COURSE
THE AUTHOR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
WHO HAVE WORKED HARD ON THE
POLICY A PLOW CAL STARTED A
MEMBER BASED NONPROFIT WITH
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MEMBER COMPANIES DEDICATED TO
TRANSFORMING THE TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY THAT INCLUDE VEHICLE
MANUFACTURED ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY PROVIDERS. PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE FLEETS AND MORE AND
THE ENERGY COMMISSION CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM HAS
REALLY BEEN A CRITICAL ELEMENT
OF OUR STATE TRANSPORTATION
CLIMATE PROGRAMS AND IT IS A
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL PROGRAM THAT
HELPED TO ADVANCE ADVANCED
VEHICLE AND KILLING
TECHNOLOGIES HOWEVER THE STATE
HAS PASSED MANY LANDMARK
CLIMATE LICENSE TO PROGRAM A
STRETCH OF FABLESS I'M A
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO WITH A DOCTOR
AND BUSINESSMAN DATES FOR
VEHICLES AND THAT SET VERY.
SPECIFIC EMISSIONS REDUCTION
TARGET. SO TO REFLECT THE
REALITIES IT REALLY MAKE SENSE
TO MODIFY THE STATUE THAT GUY
THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT-
REFLECT OUR GOAL. AS WELL AS
TECHNOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENTS AND
MARKET TRENDS THIS BILL DOES
JUST THAT. FOR EXAMPLE WE KNOW
WE NEED TO RAPIDLY SCALE UP
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY THEIR EMISSION
VEHICLES PATROL BEGAN COMING TO
MARKET REALLY QUICKLY DUE TO
THE ADVANCE CLEAN. FOR ALL. BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
STILL MAINTAINS NINE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE FUNDING AND
IS. TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL. MORE
RECENT AMENDMENTS TAKEN ON THE
BILL ADDRESSED THENEED TO
ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. BY
ENSURING THAT HALF OF PROGRAM
FUNDS WILL BENEFIT THESE
COMMUNITIES THREE THINGS LIKE
REPLACING POLLUTING DIESEL
VEHICLES ARE FOCUSING ON
CHARGING FOR APARTMENT DWELLERS
AMONG OTHER THINGS. IT FOR
THESE REASONS THAT WE ARE VERY
HAPPY TO SPONSOR THE BILL WE'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ASSEMBLY
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE
FURTHER ENHANCEMENTS TO IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE
RESPECTFULLY. RESPECTFULLY
AFTER I THAT. NEXT WITNESS
THANKS MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BILL
MCGAVIN WITH THE COAST FOR
CLEAN AIR AND ALSO TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF OUR PARTNERS IN
THE CHARGE AHEAD CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN. COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE.
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL- ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION. AND WE
REALLY WANT TO THANK CENTER
GONZALEZ AND ALSO CAL STAR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE EQUITY
GUARANTEES. THAT WOULD ASSURE.
THAT THIS FUNDING WILL BENEFIT
OUR DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES BECAUSE- ALL
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO HAVE
QUEEN TRANSPORTATION. AND CLEAN
AIR AND- THE CENTRE GONZALEZ IS
BEEN A CHAMPION IN TRYING TO
CLEAN UP THE AIR PARTICULAR
FROM GOODS MOVEMENT. ALL WHICH
IS THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF AIR
POLLUTION IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THIS BILL WOULD HELP TO GET
THOSE REDUCTIONS IN BOTH AIR
POLLUTION AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. COMING FROM THE
MOVEMENT OF GOODS AND THE
MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO- WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY AND STRONG SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION UP THERESA COOK FROM
THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION. AND MARGOT PARKES
FROM THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU BOTH
LINES ARE OPEN. THANK YOU CARE
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE TERESA
COOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
OUR MEMBERS CONSISTENT FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS HYDROGEN FUEL
PRODUCERS AND HYDROGEN FUEL
RETAILERS AND WE HAVE CURRENTLY
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ONNINETY SEVEN TWENTY
FACT. WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT BUT OUT
THREATEN HYDROGEN FUELING
CONTINUES TO BE OMITTED FROM
THE NEW SECTION THREE WHICH
DIRECTS THE EASY- SPENDING ON
THE WHOLE THE CHANGES TO THAT
PROGRAM WITHOUT CONSIDERATION
FOR HOW HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE
SUPPORTED RISKS OUR COLLECTIVE
ABILITY TO ENSURE EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAD ACCESS TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE. AND WITH A
GREATER FINANCIAL BURDEN ON THE
STATE AND REPAIRS IF WE
CONTINUE DOWN THE ROAD OF
RELYING ON A SINGLE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY FOR
THOSE REASONS WE CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE THE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU- OPERATIONS
CONCERT. I'M IN THE MOOD
ALRIGHT THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MORNING AND MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HARD PARTS
THAT THE WESTERN CAPE
DISAPPOINTMENT EDUCATION AND
ALSO GOING INTO THE GAME WITH
NEW COLORS AND MARK MENDED
TECHNICIAN ON ATHLETE SEVEN
TWENTY SIX AND WE ONLY AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR- ON THE INTENT
AND THE BELL THAT COMPREHENSIVE
IN ALIPAY- THAT AND A
TRANSPORTATION PLAN. IT'S
CRITICAL NEED OUR STATE'S
CLINICAL THIS IS- CERTAINLY
WITHOUT WITHOUT ARGUMENT AND
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THE WAY THE
BILL CURRENTLY DRAFTED DOESN'T
QUITE ACHIEVE THAT OUTCOME-
FIRST ORDERED IN IN THE BELUM
CALLING FOR NEW TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOAL
THERE IS- SIGNIFICANT OVERLAP
BETWEEN AND NEW GOAL AND
INVESTING REGULATIONS AS ABOUT
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM WHICH
REQUIRES EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
FROM ALL SECTORS. AT LOCAL LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD WHICH-
MANDATE IMPROVEMENT- AND
REDUCTIONS OF CARBON INTENSITY
THANK YOU ALL AND WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT ADDING A NEW
GOAL WILL ONLY POTENTIALLY
FURTHER COMPLICATE THE STATE
CARBON GOLD AS IT RELATES
TRANSPORTATION AND HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO INCREASE CRAP
WITHOUT REALLY DELIVERING ANY
MEASURABLE BENEFITS AND I THINK
THAT THAT HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED
I'M IN THE AUDITOR'S RECENT
REPORT WHERE THEY CALLED INTO
QUESTION SOME OF THE BENEFITS
BEING GENERATED. BY THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
OVERSEEN BY THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD WE WOULD CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE- THE ANALYSIS AND HOW
KIND AND THAT- I DON'T REPORT
TO BE CONSIDERED PRIOR Q. AND
CHANGES IN POLICY THAT CAN
RESULT IN CHANGES AND.
EXPENDITURE FOR THAT PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY IT'S CRAP. I THINK
IT'S BY THE AND MEANING ALL
MENT BY AUTHORED AIR QUALITY.
ARE HONE- IMPRO GREEN OUR ERIC.
AND ANY TO BE PART THE PLAN TO
BUILD OKAY VERY HEAVILY ON PART.
I THINK. YOU NOW THAT THAT AND
I THAT WHILE IS CERTAINLY POWER
BEING OF THE AUTHORS OCT AND
THE- TO MAKE THIS TECHNO
NEUTRAL BELT THAT THERE ARE
CHANGE THAT NEED. TO ALLOW THEM
EXISTING TECHNOLOGY TODAY TO
HELP MAKE AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO. CONTINUING TO WORK ON THOSE
CHIU PROPONENTS OF THE BELT-
AND THINK. THE AUTHOR AND-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BUT AT
THAT- DO YOU WORK IN- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW TAKE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL- PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL- DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
THE HEARING ROOM. I DON'T SEE
ANY I DON'T SEE ANY AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR. WHICH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. IF YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AFFECTS THE SEVEN TO
SIX PLEASE PRESS WARNED THAT
DAY ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT LINES IN Q. WILL GO
TO LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE ONE SEVEN ONE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
AS THE LEAST SHOT ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CALL YOU'RE A BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BRING ONE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NOT YOUR
MOM ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT I'M SURE MEMBERS
JOHN MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION WITHIN OPPOSE
IMPOSSIBLE POSITION THANK.
THANK YOU BRING ONE SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING BRITAIN K. REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS A. B. B. ABC
COMPANIES EMPLOY POWER ANAHEIM
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK ANTELOPE
VALLEY TRANSIT AUTHORITY A
RIFLE BALLARD POWER SYSTEMS
CHANGE ENERGY HE NOW GREENPOWER
MOTOR COMPANY JB POINDEXTER AND
CO MOMENTUM DYNAMICS
CORPORATION. MOTIV POWER
SYSTEMS NICOLAIDES CORPORATION
BUT I'M JUST I'M SIXTEEN X.
MOTOR CARS PROTERRA ELECTRIC
SUNLINE TRANSIT AGENCY THE LION
ELECTRICO. THE LOS ENERGY AND.
VOLVO GROUP NORTH AMERICA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M ONE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE BILL
MURPHY BEHALF ELDERS I SO CAL
IN NOR CAL CHAPTER. IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE OF SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AARON
RODRIGUEZ UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY THIS IS
BREANNA PANETTA ON BEHALF OF
THE LECTURE TO BE A CALL
CHARGING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SIR NUMBER OF
MILES MILLER ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STEPHEN THE MANAGER ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN TWO SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AT. ONE SEVEN TWO. I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME I THINK YOU
WILL OPEN IT UP TO QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE'LL
START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
CENTER MAYBE BUT MY QUESTION IS
KIND OF LEAN TO WHY THERE ISN'T
LANGUAGE THAT REALLY SHOWS
YOU'RE YOU'RE ACTUALLY TRYING
TO SET THIS UP FOR A
DIVERSIFIED CLEAN ENERGY
PORTFOLIO. BECAUSE WE IT WE'VE
ALL SEEN THE IN IN A LOT OF US
GOT GOING BACK TO THE DAYS
WHERE WE ALL HASHED OUT CAP AND
TRADE IN WE SET A LOT OF THESE
GOALS WE MADE DECISIONS WITH
THE INDUSTRY SAYING HEY THIS IS%
THE GOAL THIS IS WHERE WE WANT
YOU TO ACHIEVE. AND LET'S MOVE
FORWARD AND WORK TO THAT SOCIAL
NGUYEN THE LANGUAGE. START
TALKING ABOUT WELL LET'S SET A
NEW GOAL. IT'S QUESTIONS COME
UP WHEN THE LANGUAGE IS A VERY
SPECIFIC A. AS WE'VE HEARD FROM
THE OPPOSITION. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE HYDROGEN FUEL FUTURES
WE'VE JUST SEEN VEHICLES BREAK
LAND MILES TRAVELED. FOR
HYDROGEN CARS. CHAU CLEARLY
THAT'S A VIABLE OPTION THAT'S
NOT BEING DISCUSSED ENOUGH
FRANKLY BUT BY THIS BODY BY OUR
GOVERNOR IN WE'RE NOT HEARING
ENOUGH ABOUT IT EVEN THOUGH WE
CLAIM TO LEAD THE WAY- WE DON'T
HEAR ENOUGH ABOUT. RENEWAL
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS THAT THEY
WERE GETTING FROM HARVESTING-
METHANE FROM DERRY DIED
GESTURES. IN WHAT THAT CAN DO
FOR LOCAL AND MEDIUM FLEETS IN
THAT SPACE AND HOW THAT CAN
REMOVE A LOT OF THE GREENHOUSE
GASES FROM R. OR MEDIUM SIZED
IN AND LOCAL FLEAS. IN REMOVED
THE DIESEL IN THAT PART. CHAU
WELL WHEN I SEE LANGUAGE THAT
THAT FINE TUNES SOMETHING IN
THIS SPACE AND A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES WE WE'VE ALL WORKED
VERY HARD ON THIS SOME OF US
HAVE GONE OUT OF OUR WAY-
BERMAN OF ENERGY HAS A
FANTASTIC SCHOOL FOR
LEGISLATORS IT'S- THE
LEGISLATIVE ENERGY HORIZON IS
TO DO THE REALLY DIES OF THE
NUTS AND BOLTS AND THE POLICY
ON THIS- SADLY THERE'S ONLY TWO
PEOPLE. IN THE HUNDRED TWENTY
OF US THE THAT I'VE ACTUALLY
GRADUATED FROM THAT SCHOOL THIS
MYSELF A LOT OF BURKE. AND WE
LEARN THE FIVE NIGHTS ON THIS
IS WHY WE WORK SO HARD ON THE
CAP AND TRADE BILL THAT'S WHY
WE STILL PUSH. TO ENSURE THERE
IS THIS DIVERSIFIED PORTFOLIO.
EIGHT IN. MY QUESTION FOR YOU
CENTERS WHY THAT ISN'T SPELLED
OUT HOW COME YOU HAVEN'T
SPELLED OUT. YOU SAY YOU WANT
TO MAKE SURE THIS IS THIS IS
DIVERSIFIED THAT WE'RE GONNA
INCLUDE HYDROGEN THAT WE'RE
GOING TO INCLUDE OTHER. ZERO
EMISSION FUELS. BUT IT'S NOT
SPECIFIED IN YOUR BILL SO WHY
IS THAT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AND
JUST FOR THE RECORD I'M A PORT
SENATOR SO I REPRESENT ONE OF
THE LARGEST PORTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFONIA. BEEN
REPRESENTING THEM FOR OVER A
DECADE WELL AWARE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY DIVERSITY THAT WE
WANT TO KEEP AND THIS BILL
BASICALLY STATES THAT IT IS
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL. THAT
STRATEGY THAT- THE OPPOSITION
WAS SAYING THAT IS TO THE
FOCUSED. WE ACTUALLY INCLUDED.
A LANGUAGE THAT INCLUDES NEAR
ZERO TECHNOLOGY AS ONE OF THE
STRATEGIES THAT SHOULD BE S. AS
IN THE TRANSPORTATION STRATEGY
THIS IS SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION STRATEGY SO IT'S
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL. AND THEN WE
ALSO INCLUDED AMENDMENTS IN
SENATE Q. R. THAT INCLUDED A
SPECIFIED THAT THEIR THEIR
RECENT SPORT RESOURCES BOARD
SHALL CONSIDER INCLUDING
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS GOALS
THAT'S NOT A REQUIREMENT. WELL
THAT IS OF THE DRESS THE
OPPOSITION CENTER THAT THAT'S
FANTASTIC WE DID THE POINT IS
YOU STILL HAVE CLEAR
OPPOSITION. FROM INDUSTRIES IN
THE RENEWABLE SPACE. SO THAT
TELLS US THAT THERE'S MORE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND MORE
AMENDMENTS THE NEED TO GET DONE
ON THIS. AND BEING THAT YOU DO
REPRESENT THE PARTS I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE THAT THE PORTS ARE
FRANKLY TERRIFIED THAT THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE A BILLION DOLLARS
COST. AND HAVING TO GO TO A
LECTURE FOR CATION- NGUYEN. IF
WE DO A BETTER JOB AT THE
LANGUAGE WE'RE PUTTING INTO OUR
LEGISLATION. WE CAN SHOW THEM
THAT YOU KNOW YES YOU CAN DO
SOME ELECTRIC HERE. YOU CAN DO
SOME HYDROGEN FUEL STUFF HERE.
IF YOU'RE IN ONE MORE IN. DO
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO THE
RENEWABLE. NATURAL GAS SITE
HERE. SO IT IS VERY IMPERATIVE.
THAT WE GET THESE THINGS RIGHT.
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
THE DETAILS MATTER. INSULA
INTEL I SEE THAT FINE I'D
LANGUAGE AND SEE THIS
OPPOSITION- THE THAT ANOTHER
RENEWABLE FUEL SOURCE THAT THE
FRANKLY IS ACTUALLY MORE
VIABLE- THEN GOING STRAIGHT
ELECTRIC VEHICLE- THE INTEL I
SEE THAT I'M GONNA STAY OFF
YOUR BILL. IN IN IF YOU'D LIKE
SOME HELP PUTTING THAT TOGETHER
A MORE THAN HELP HAPPY TO SIT
DOWN AND TAKE PERSONAL TIME TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT- BECAUSE
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE IS IMPORTANT. BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET IT
CORRECT. YEAH AND WE ARE
WORKING TOWARDS THAT SO THIS IS
AGAIN VERY TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
AND I WOULD JUST. RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH YOU KNOW SOME OF
YOUR COMMENTS BUT- WELL TAKEN
THANK YOU. HE NEXT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU
CENTER I- COMPLETELY- SUPPORT-
THE V. FOR ALL GOAL OF YOUR
BELL- BUT I DID HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AS SIMILAR TO A
MISTER MATHIS I REMEMBER. WHEN
I WAS INVITED VIçT TO THE
PORT OF LONG BEACH- WHERE-
TOYOTA AND MARY NICHOLS ROLLED
OUT- MODEL- HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AS PART OF
THE SOLUTION TO REALLY CLEAN UP
THE AIR QUALITY AND- NO IN IN
SOME OF THE HARDER NO THE MOST
IMPACTED TO. MOST PUT- POLLUTED
COMMUNITIES- IN IN YOUR
DISTRICT- AND SO I WAS JUST I
DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS A I
DON'T REALLY. UNDERSTAND WHY
THE- CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION IS IN OPPOSITION BUT
I WOULD THINK THAT- THAT
HYDROGEN THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT
DAY FOR THE QUESTION AND I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW
EVERYONE'S- I GUESS. QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHY IT'S NOT EXPLICITLY
pTECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO SAY IF THERE ARE
OTHER TECHNOLOGIES ASIDE FROM
JUST ELECTRIC THAT WE CAN DO
SOMETHING IN THE AND IN THE
INTERMEDIATE FOR WE ARE LOOKING
AT HYDROGEN FUEL CELL RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS WITH HAPPY. THIS IS
OPEN TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
OKAY- WE ACTUALLY HAVE HYDROGEN
USERS THAT ARE IN OUR SUPPORT
SUPPORT COALITION AS WELL SO
YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING HAVING DIESEL RIGHT
NOW ON THIS ON THE ROADS IT'S
JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE AND SO I
THINK- TO MR GAVIN'S POINT AND
TO- IS ALEXANDER'S POINT YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
WERE OPEN- BUT WE NEED TO START
MAKING THESE CHANGES. RIGHT
AWAY SO CAN'T. YOU KNOW WICKS
OF. IRAQ HELLO THANK YOU I LOOK
FOR TO- THAT CLARIFICATION.
ANOTHER POINT THAT WAS. RAISED
IN THE- COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SO.
YOU KNOW. UNDER THE HEADING OF
THE QUESTION MARK ERROR
DISTRICTS GIVEN SHORT SHRIFT IN
THE STRATEGY. THAT YOU KNOW-
MAKING THE POINT THAT THE OUR
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS LIKE THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. YOU KNOW
WE WHICH IS MUCH MORE- PLAYS A
MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
THE CAR MORE IT MORE YOUR
ANOTHER- CLEAN VEHICLE
PROGRAMS- IT IS THE IS THE
INTENTTO GIVE IT TO. LESS OF A-
OF A ROLE AS A CONSUL
CONSULTATION ROLE RATHER THAN A
COORDINATION ROLE. THAT WASN'T
THE INTENT AT ALL AND SO I'M
GLAD THAT THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTED THAT OUT WE'RE
HAPPY WE'VE BEEN ENGAGING WITH
THEM AS WELL. AND SO WOULD LOVE
TO YOU KNOW CONTINUE ENGAGING
THEM AND ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
PART OF THE PROCESS BECAUSE IT
WAS A GOOD CALL OUT SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT ARAFAT. WAS
DEFINITELY BUT IF MR MCCABE AND
I KNOW THAT HE'S HERE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING ELSE AS
WELL. I KNOW HE'S BEEN OUR
PARTNER- IN THIS AS WELL. WELL
THANK YOU I WOULD JUST SAY-
YOUR REITERATED THE CENTRE'S
POINT THAT THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL IS TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THERE THAT
SAYS IT'S GOING TO BE ALL
BATTERY ELECTRIC THAT DOESN'T
APPEAR IN THE BILL. IT INCLUDES
HYDROGEN HYDROGEN VEHICLES ARE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES SO I YOU
KNOW WE WOULDN'T SUPPORT IT
OTHERWISE. SO IT IT'S OPEN TO
THOSE TECHNOLOGIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA YEAH I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR. WORKING
IN THIS SPACE WE SURE THAT
CORRIDOR- AND- HEAVY POLLUTION
ISSUES WITH ALL OF THE SO THAT
WE HAVE OUT THERE SO THANK YOU
FOR. DOING THIS WORK. MY
QUESTION IS- ALL ALSO BASED ON
THE ANALYSIS- SOME OF THE
COMMENTS IN INDIA ANALYSIS AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT. I HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO GET TO
OUR GOAL TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES HEALTHIER. I GUESS
THE QUESTION ABOUT VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED AND GETTING
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS AND
RIGHT NOW THAT'S NOT. THIS IS
TO JUST FOCUS ON SAD'S- AND NOT
ANY OF THAT THE OTHER PART OF
THE STRATEGY SO JUST. WANTED TO
YOUR COMMENT ON THAT ARE YOU
LOOKING TO EXPAND AS THAT PART
OF THE DISCUSSIONS OR- IS THAT
A SEPARATE DISCUSSION IT'S ONE
OF YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION I THINK
IS ACTUALLY PART OF THE
DISCUSSION AS WELL BECAUSE IT
HISTORICALLY HASN'T BEEN
CERVANTES ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
METHODS. IN ADDITION TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THE MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY SPACE
ENSURING THAT WE'RE GETTING OFF
OF DIESEL TO ANOTHER TECHNOLOGY
THAT WILL REDUCE EMISSIONS AND
AIR POLLUTION SO. IT'S ALL PART
OF THE- OF THE STRATEGY. WAS
DEFINITELY. AND SO IS THAT IN
THAT. LANGUAGE AT THAT'S ALL
PART OF THE STRATEGY OR WE JUST
ASSUMING THE- AGENCIES. ARE
LOOKING UP WE'VE CALLED THAT
OUT IN THIS AND THIS BILL TO BE
A PART OF IT NOW THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE WE DON'T HAVE ANY MORE
QUESTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
YEAH I WOULD SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE QUESTIONS WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH MEMBER
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH US I
MEAN THE BOTTOM LINE IS. AGAIN
I'VE GOT SOME OF THE WORST AIR
POLLUTION AND- SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH. AND
BEING A PART SENATOR THIS IS A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT NOT JUST TO
MY REGION BUT TO THE WHOLE
STATE. SO WITH THAT RESPECT THE
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- ACTUALLY WE DON'T HAVE A
MOTION ON. KATE OF THE BILLS
MOVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA THE MOTION IS. TO PASS
TO TRANSPORTATION. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. NINE IN
TEN SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ. MEMBERS RIVAS
HI RIVERSIDE FLORIDA. CHAU CHAU
AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE
GARCIA. GARCIA I MATHIS MATHIS
NO MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO CHALLENGE
THEM TO NOT SAY OUR TOTAL STONE
STONE I WOULD. WOULD I. EIGHT
TWO EIGHT TWO WILL BE THAT OPEN
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE BILLS
LEFT NEXT IS ITEM. I DON'T
NUMBER TWELVE. SENATOR SKINNER
SB TWENTY SEVEN. I'M NOT A
READER I BELIEVE YOU HAVE THE
PHONE LINE ON CAN YOU PLEASE.
TURN THAT OFF. THANK. IT'S
GOING TO CHAIR MEMBERS- HERE 2%
SB TWENTY SEVEN FIRST THANK YOU
AND I'M ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SUPPORT IT'S ALL
JUST TURN RIGHT TO MY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT- ELLIE COHEN FROM
THE CLIMATE PLAN AND LUCAS
FRERICHS FROM THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THANK YOU SENATOR
WE'RE READY FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES MODERATOR CAME PLEASE
OPEN UP THEIR LINES. THANK YOU
BOTH FIND THEIR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE MEMBERS CHAIR
THE WITH YOU ANY MONEY THAT
DOESN'T WORK NOT JUST
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS MANAGER WITH
CLIMATE CENTER AND I'M FEELING
INCREDIBLY- WHERE I'M NOT
PROFIT THOUGH IS NOT CHEATING
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS THAT
SPEED NOT SCALE PROCLAIM IT YET
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN WHICH AIMS
TO ACCELERATE STATE CLIMATE
POLICY TIMELINE AND ACHIEVE
THAT NEGATIVE EMISSIONS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. QUICKLY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
SEVEN WHICH WILL SET URGENTLY
NEEDED GOALS FOR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION USING NATURAL
WORKING LANDS AND HELP CATALYZE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
JUST THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN U. N.
REPORT WHICH CALLED FOR CUTTING
EMISSION GET HAPPEN THERE
INCLUDING CARBON THAT IS
ALREADY IN THE ATMOSPHERE NEW
STUDIES SHOW THAT WE WILL PASS
DANGEROUS WOMAN THRESHOLD ONE
POINT FIVE DEGREES CELSIUS
WITHIN THE NEXT DECADE. MUCH
EARLIER THAN EXPECTED. TO HELP
ADDRESS. A GROWING NUMBER OF
SIGNED YOU STUDY SHOW THAT
NATURAL WORKING LANDSCAPES.
YOUR AMOUNTS. WITH THE ADDED
BENEFITS OF HELPING OUR STATE
THE MORE RESILIENT TOWARDS THE
EVER WORSENING DROUGHT WILDFIRE
AND SEA LEVEL RISE. AS SUCH THE
QUALITY CENTER SUPPORT SB
TWENTY SEVENTH FRAMEWORK OF
HAVING THE STATE PARTNER THE
PRIVATE AND STATE THEIR PROJECT
BUT HISTORY. WHAT THE GOAL OF
SCALING UP INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA BASED CARTOONIST
TRACING PROJECT ON NATURAL
WORKING LANDS. THIS PROGRAM
WILL BE AS ACCESSIBLE TO AS
MANY PRODUCERS AS POSSIBLE AND
WILL NOT BE USED FOR INITIAL
TALKS AT. THE PROJECT SHOULD
RESULT IN REAL PERMANENT AND
VERIFIABLE GREENHOUSE GAS
REMOVAL. THERE ARE ALSO NEW
TECHNOLOGIES EMERGING FOR
DIRECTLY CAPTURING CARBON FROM
THE ATMOSPHERE. WE SUPPORT
SMALL SCALE TESTING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES SO LONG AS THEY DO
NOT NEGATIVELY IMPACT.
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT DO NOT IMPACT
EXISTING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION EFFORTS. BUT
RAPIDLY WORSENING CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS AND CALIFORNIA
IN THE EARLY STAGES OF THE
SEVERE MULTI DECADE DROUGHT THE
CLIMATE CENTRIC THANK SENATOR
SKINNER THE CLIMATE LEADERSHIP.
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
PRIVATE ROUGHLY TWENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING- ACTUALLY
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT MY NAME'S LUCAS
MERRICK SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT OF S. TWO TWENTY
SEVENTHS I'M NOT FAR STATE
ACTION AND EFFORTS TO CONSERVE
RESTORE AND MANAGE NATURAL
LOOKING LANDS HAVE BEEN
DISTRICTS AND VERY AGENCIES
HAVE JURISDICTION OVER
DIFFERENT PASSAGE OF THE
NATURAL LOOKING LAND ISSUES.
MOST EFFORTS TO ENHANCE COMING
BENEFITS A NATURAL WORKING
LANDS ARE DONE ON A PROJECT BY
PROJECT BASIS EITHER BY
TARGETING A SPECIFIC CATEGORY
OF LAND SUCH AS GRASSLAND OR
FOREST OR AIMED AT PROMOTING
ONE TYPE OF EMISSIONS REDUCTION
OR SEQUESTRATION TECHNIQUES
SUCH AS ENHANCING SOIL CARBON.
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE WE'RE GOING TO NEED
EVERY TOOL IN THE TOOLKIT AND
ADDITIONAL DATA FROM THE SITE
THIS PROPOSED PROJECT REGISTRY
OF NEW TOOL WHICH WILL BE ALSO
IMPORTANT ATTRACTING ADDITIONAL
PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT FUND
CALIFORNIA BASED LAND
MANAGEMENT WORK WE KNOW WE NEED
TO DO IN ORDER TO PROTECT
OURSELVES FROMSEA LEVEL RISE
FOREST FIRES AND DROUGHT ND WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT.
CEMENTS IN ADDITION TO PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS IN THE STATE WE'D
LIKE TO THANK UNDER SKINNER
SKINNER FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THESE ISSUES AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU WE DON'T HAVE
ANY WITNESSES REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO WE WILL NOW OPEN
IT UP TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- WE'LL
START WITH THE HEARING ROOM WE
HAVE ONE WITNESS- MORE THAN ONE
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALEXA CHáVEZ OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WEIGHT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE DON'T
HAVE ANY WITNESSES AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE
LINES MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THIS BILL. OKAY OR
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AT B. TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT TEN LINES IN Q. WILL
GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE
PORT OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M ONE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
PAUL MASON AT THE SECOND
POOREST TRUST WE ACTUALLY HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND WHILE WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE GOAL OF THE BILL
RECONTEST NATURAL LAMB AND THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT ONGOING
CONVERSATION WITH THE CENTER'S
OFFICE WE REMAIN CONCERNED AND
I'LL BE BRIEF HERE. ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL CONFUSION OF HAVING A
STATE BACKED REGISTRY OF
CLIMATE PROJECT CEREMONIAL
WORKING UNDER NAME AFFILIATION.
AND POSITION ON THE BILL. ONE
ONE EIGHT EIGHT ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
TAYLOR OCEAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AND ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
AGRICULTURAL AND THEN JUST
BUSINESS INTERESTS WE'VE MOVED
TO THANK THAT NEUTRAL THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS SENATOR MUSHTAQ.
THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNINGOR GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM HAIR
MARK FENSTER BAKER FOR THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
AUTHORITY AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON OKAY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION AND LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YOU CAN ON
BEHALF OF- ARMED CONFLICT
LOCALE AND CLICK OUT. YOU TAKE
A SILICON VALLEY THREE FIFTY
ONE COUNTY CONNELL. IT HOBBLED
IN CONNECTICUT POLLUTION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RUN ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON HONESTLY SO WITH
THE WEIDEMANN GROUP ON BEHALF
OF BLUE PLANET IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS LESLIE VASQUEZ WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RYAN ONE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE FLAT. I'M SURE NUMBERS
ARE CLEARLY MADE BY USERS ON
BEHALF OF PROCTER AND GAMBLE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU AND NOW
WILL TAKE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT.
MORE FOR JUST A COMMENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD WE HAVE A HUGE
NUMBER WORKING LANDS IN MY
DISTRICT- AND HUGE POTENTIAL
FOR CARBON SEQUESTRATION WITH
GOOD LAND MANAGEMENT PRACTICES-
SHOULD THE BILL MOVE OUT OF
COMMITTEE I'D I'D LOVE TO BE A
CO AUTHOR IF YOU'LL TAKE ME.
HAPPILY ATTY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI DITTO TO WHAT MR
ONES JUST SAID I WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO REQUEST TO BE ADDED IS
CALLED EXCELLENT THANK YOU. HEY
I BELIEVE THERE ARE NO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN WALDRON THE
PARTY AT THE END OF THE AUTHOR
AS WELL- EIGHT FOUR WILL DO
THAT ANY OTHER MEMBERS WITH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS K. C.
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE-
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THERE'S-
THE GOOD SUPPORT THERE WAS
EXPRESSED IN THE- PUBLIC
COMMENT AND ALSO BY A MEMBERS
AND I THINK THIS WOULD REALLY
GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY THERE
ARE SO MANY PRIVATE SECTOR
ENTITIES THAT ARE NOW MAKING
COMMITMENTS TO GO CARBON
NEUTRAL AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN THEIR DOING SO.
THEY ARE INVESTING IN AN
ACTUALLY ACHIEVING REDUCTIONS
IN SEQUESTRATION AND STORAGE
RIGHT AND SO BY CREATING A
REGISTRY AND BY GIVING OUR
AGENCIES THE ABILITY TO PUT
SOME PARAMETERS ON THAT IT WILL
HELP US ACHIEVE IT IN WITHOUT
ASTEROID VOTE. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS SECOND IN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI. THE MOTION.
EXCUSE ME THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE ITEM TWELVE SB TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER. MEMBERS
RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLOOR. CHAU
CHOW HI FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I'D
GARCIA GARCIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO GI SAY
ARE TOO HIGH K. R. TWO I'S
STONE. JONES I WOULD WOOD I'D
TEND ZERO K. TEN ZERO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. HEY
OUR LAST PRESENTER IS SENATOR
STERN. SB. SIXTY THREE. BUT
OKAY SENATOR YOU HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND PLEASE GO AHEAD
OKAY I'LL TRY NOT TO TALK TOO
MUCH PASS YES HERE- BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT- THIS LEGISLATION- AS A
RESULT IT AT THE AS ARE
TRUNCATED IN CHAOTIC IN THE
SESSION LAST YEAR THE PRIOR
VERSION THIS MEASURE- DIED ON
THE FINAL DAY SESSION DIDN'T
MAKE IT THROUGH IN THIS BILL'S
BEEN NUMBER YEARS IN MAKING IT
A NUMBER OF OUR MEMBERS HERE
HAVE BEEN LEADING ON THESE
ISSUES IN THE NORTH COAST AND
OUT IN THE VALLEY AND- CENTRAL
COAST- WE'RE TRYING TO. APPLY
THE SAME BUILDING STANDARDS
THAT WERE CURRENTLY REQUIRING
AND VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
ZONES INTO THE INTO OTHER HIGH
RISK ZONES- AS WELL AS
EMPOWERING- COMMUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO START DOING MORE
VOLUNTEER TRAINING AND THE KIND
OF RESILIENCY WORK THEY NEED TO
BE DOING SO WE DON'T JUST RELY-
ONLY ON OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
BUT COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS GET
INVOLVED WITH THINGS LIKE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE- I THINK THIS
IS GOOD ECONOMICS THINGS LIKE
TO CREATE SOME JOBS AND WE WERE
REALLY UNIQUE COALITION HERE-
SUPPORTING THIS LEGISLATION I'M
VERY EXCITED ABOUT WHERE
EVERYONE FROM FIRE CHIEFS
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS-
ECOLOGICAL PRESERVATION TO THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY- THERE ARE
SOME THINGS I THINK WE CAN
AGREE ON I KNOW FIRE POLICY CAN
GET PRETTY CONTROVERSIAL BUT-
WE THINK THAT THE MAKES A
MEASURES IN THIS LEGISLATION.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL START TO- TURN
THE PAGE ON HOW WE FIGHT FIRES
AND MOSTLY HOW WE PREVENT FIRES
FROM HARNESSING LOCAL ECOLOGIES
IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND GIVING
PEOPLE A VOICE IN THIS PROCESS
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR- WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES REGISTERED.
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT- BOB BREMER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND J. SIEGLER FROM
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THEIR LINES. KEEP ALL FINES
ARE OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M BOB BREMER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE S. B. SIXTY
THREE AND FOR THE SAKE OF TIME
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION THE
BUILDING OWNERS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE
INTERNATIONAL COUNCIL OF
SHOPPING CENTERS- SB SIXTY
THREE WILL IMPROVE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND EXPAND THE
APPLICATION OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S FAR HERDING BUILDING
STANDARDS THE FIRE MARSHAL
STANDARDS HAVE A PROVEN HISTORY
OF SUCCESS IN THE PARADISE
FIRES BOMBS WITH THE FIRE
MARSHAL'S PARDONING STANDARDS-
AND HAD DEFENSIBLE SPACE HAD A
SURVIVAL RATE OF FOUR TO FIVE
TIMES GREATER THAN THOSE WHO
DID NOT AND REGARDING THE STATE
FARM MAPS CALIFORNIA ALREADY
HAS MAPS WERE VERY HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES SB SIXTY THREE
REQUIRES THE DIRECTOR OF CAL
FIRE. TO COMPLETE THE MAPS WITH
THE MODERATE AND HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES ONCE THESE MAPS
ARE COMPLETED AND CERTIFIED-
THE FARM MARKS ON THE
DEPARTMENT HOUSING WILL THEN GO
FORWARD TO DOCK BUILDING
STANDARDS EXPANDING APPLICATION
OF OUR VERY SUCCESSFUL FIRE
HARDENING STANDARDS TO THE HIGH
FIRE SEVERITY ZONES AND THEY
WILL ALSO CONSIDER EXPANDING
THEM TO THE MONARCH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES SO WITH THAT WE
URGE. YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. ADAM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JAY
ZIGGLER AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
POLITICS FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WHERE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF. SB SIXTY
THREE AT WITH THE CALIFORNIA'S
MAYOR MAKE A PRIOR TRENDS
CONTINUE TO WORSEN IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL- THAT WE
MAKE ALL COMMUNITIES MORE PRIOR
PRONE AND- PRIOR RESULTS THAT
ARE IN FIRE PRONE AREAS. MORE
RESILIENT TO BE INSPIRED
THREATS. NATURE CONSERVANCY IS
AN ACTIVE MEMBER THE FIRE DEPT
AT COMMUNITIES NETWORK ACROSS
THE NATION- WHICH IS FOCUSING
ON SUSTAINABLE WIRED COOPER
RESILIENCE STRATEGIES IN FIRE
PRONE COMMUNITIES- THIS
COALITION IS HELPING PEOPLE AND
WILDLIFE URBAN INTERFACE AREA
DOWN TO THE THREAT OF WILDFIRE
AND REDUCE FIRE THREATS AROUND
THEM. FOR COMMUNITIES IN THE
HIGHER RISK AREAS THAT MISTER
RAYMOND AND WE MUST MAKE THEM
MORE RESILIENT THREE STATE
BUILDING STANDARDS. DEFENSIBLE
SPACE SEPARATE EVACUATION
PLANNING AND PREVENTION OF
HUMAN CAUSED IGNITION- EVENTS-
SB SIXTY THREE MAKE IMPORTANT
CHANGES TO IMPROVE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE REQUIREMENTS- AND HELPS
BUILD CAPACITIES TO LOCAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS- PROGRAMS-
UNDER CAL FIRE'S MINISTRATION.
THIS WILL IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY
INCREASE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
ALONG ROADWAYS. AND PROVIDE
ACCESS TO FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
OUTREACH AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE
PROGRAMS- WE THANK SENATOR
STERN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
ADDRESSING THIS. OF FIRE WHICH
IS INCREASINGLY- ALARMING TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS- AND
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS BILL WILL
HELP ENSURE WE HAVE- THE
CAPACITY AND WORKFORCE NEEDED.
TO CREATE MORE FIRE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE-
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. WE WOULD AFTER
AYE BUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
WILL OPEN IT UP TO WAIT. IN
SUPPORT- OFFICE. PLEASE JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. ARE THERE ANY.
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM
SEEN NONE THERE ARE NONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION.
MODERATED Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS LINE AT TEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT SIX COMMENTS THANK YOU
WILL GO TO ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE IN THE
OLYMPIA REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU AROUND
ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS MARKED ENSURE
MAKER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIN
EVAN VAUGHN BEHALF OF THE TREE
CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M GOING OUT TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BALKANS OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AT THOUSAND OAKS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THANK YOU THIS ADVOCATE
DARKENED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEF COUNSEL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY DON'T
BE HALF OF PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU I'VE NEVER OPENED IT UP TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CENTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS- I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND IN
IN MY DISTRICT THAT THE FIRES
THAT I VISITED WHERE. YOU CAN
PHYSICALLY SEE WHERE A FIRE IS
JUST BROKE OFF A DRAWING
EXTREMELY HIGH HEAT AND HIGH
SPEED. AND THE BILL LITERALLY
SEE A HOUSE THAT MEETS THESE
REQUIREMENTS IT IS STILL
STANDING IT'S LIKE WITHOUT A
SCRATCH. RIGHT BY SAY THE- YEAH
IT'S YOU KNOW THE- IN THE
GARAGE THAT'S NOT ATTACHED WAS
IT IN THE GARAGE IS MELTED TO
THE GROUND. WHICH IS THE FRAME
OF THE CAR LEFT THE BUT THE
HOUSE IS IMMACULATE IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE STANDARDS- THEY
DO HAVE ONE QUESTION A I WOULD
LIKE FOR YOU TO ADDRESS AND
THAT IS THE CONCERNS OVER- YOU
KNOW KINDA. ROBBING PETER TO
PAY PAUL YOU KNOW IT'S A ARE WE
PULLING AWAY FROM. THE PLANE
THE DEAD TREES OUT IN
ADDRESSING THE BARK BEETLE
CRISIS AND EVERYTHING ELSE TO
PAY FOR THIS THAT'S A CONCERN
THAT'S BEEN OUT THERE AND I'D
LOVE FOR YOU TO ADDRESS THAT-
I. MIGHT MY PHILOSOPHY ON THIS
IS WE SHOULD. PAY PAUL AND
PETER AND- MANY OTHER PICTURE
APOSTLE- THAT- THAT THERE
SHOULDN'T BE INVESTMENT ALREADY
WERE UNDER DOING IT MAY FEEL
LIKE WE'RE THROWING EVERYTHING
WE GOT IT WHILE FIRE BUT IN
FACT THE RISKY TO CLIMBING IN A
RECENT STUDY SAID AT LEAST
THREE BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
SHOULD BE PUT INTO PREVENTION
FROM STANFORD- AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TO BILLION WHICH IS A LOT
TO MARSHALL IS A LEGISLATURE
BUT I DON'T INTENDED TO HAVE
THIS BE DIVERSION THIS IS ABOUT
ADDING FLEXIBILITY. AROUND THE
FIRE PREVENTION- PROGRAM
ESPECIALLY WITH CAL FIRE IN
THEIR LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS
TO MAKE SURE THEY CAN DO. FIND
WAYS TO GET INTO HARD TO REACH
TERRITORIES IN PARTS ORANGE
COUNTY L. A. COUNTY VENTURA
COUNTY A LOT OF COMMITTEES HAVE
BEEN TAKING ON THESE GRANTS
BECAUSE- THEY ONLY SEE IT IS
FUEL TREATMENT OR ITS
CLEARANCE. SO WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO SORT OF DISENTANGLE THOSE
POLITICS AND NOT MAKE PEOPLE
FEARFUL OF STATE FUNDING IN
THIS PLACE THAT IT'S JUST GONNA
BE ABOUT. CLEARING TREES IN
AREAS THAT HAVE SAY OAK
WOODLANDS AND NEED THOSE TREES
TO ACTUALLY BLOCK FIRES RIGHT
SO. EXPANDING TO INCLUDE THINGS
LIKE ROAD SIDE TREATMENT- TAKE
REDEFINING CLEARANCE TO
SOMETHING THAT IS MORE ABOUT
INVASIVE SPECIES. I THINK IT'LL
IT'LL HELP BUT I NO NO INTENT
FOR DIVERSION JUST- JUST KIND
OF. GET IN ESPECIALLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
CHAPARRAL ANY SORT OF
ECOLOGICALLY SENSITIVE AREAS
TO. TO BE PART OF IT TOO. SO
PROCEDURE CONNAUGHT'S. SHARE
YOUR ANSWER AND WOULD LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR- THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT. THANK YOU SENATOR-
IT'S A GREAT BEING ABLE TO
PARTNER WITH YOU ON A LOT OF
FIRE RELATED- AND PREVENTION
RELATED- EFFORTS- THERE'S A LOT
IN YOUR BILL THAT YOU DIDN'T
TALK ABOUT. AND I KNOW THAT
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE BUT I
WANT TO I WANT TO COMMEND YOU
ON WHAT YOU HAVE INCLUDED IN
THERE. I JUST HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF THOSE THINGS FOR THE
FOR THE MEMBERS HERE. I GUESS
REALLY APPROPRIATE FOR CAL FIRE
I TO DEVELOP AN UPDATE SOME
GUIDANCE AROUND- YOU KNOW THAT
WHAT'S- APPROPRIATE REGIONAL-
FUEL MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES.
WHERE YOU LIVE IS QUITE
DIFFERENT FROM WHERE I LIVE
AND- THE LANDSCAPE IS DIFFERENT
AND THE NEEDS ARE DIFFERENT.
AND THE FACT THAT WE SEEM TO BE
FOCUSING MORE ON THE NEEDS OF
THE FOREST AND THINGS THAT I
REPRESENT AND LESS ON THE
CHAPARRAL AND SOME OF THE STATE
THE LANDSCAPE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I THINK NEEDS TO BE
RECTIFIED- AND ALSO- ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR CALL OUT TO THE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S BE. SHOULD
GIVE US SOME REPORTS ON ON THE
IMPACTS OF THE SB NINE ONE
PROJECTS THAT THAT HAPPENED-
THAT WAS A BILLION DOLLARS A
BILLION DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT
THERE AND- THAT THAT AND WE
NEED TO KNOW DO. YOU KNOW HOW
TO GO AND WHAT WE WHAT WE DO
THERE SO THAT'S PART OF OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY- ARE OVERSIGHT
AND IN THE LEGISLATURE SO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING AND- GOOD FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND I. TOO WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS COOPER. THANK
YOU. SOME MEMBER MERCY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH INTEREST AND I
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR TO YOU'RE IMPORTANT
BILL HERE- BUT I BUT I DO HAVE
CONCERNS LIKE I THINK A- YOU
AND I. MAKE SURE THESE CONCERNS
BUT- THE AND THE ONGOING DRUG.
PUSH THROUGH THE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT-
REQUIREMENTS OF FOR HOUSING TO
BE BUILT AND VERY HIGH FIRE.
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES- IT'S IT
IS CONCERNING AND- I KNOW THAT
THAT IS AS A WHOLE A SEPARATE
SUBJECT BUT IT IS RELATED TO
YOU TO THIS BILL AND THAT THE
YOU KNOW THIS THIS COULD BE
SEEN IN THIS COULD BE. USED AS
A- AS A AS AN EXCUSE TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD MORE AND VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD. ZONES I
WANTED TO. SEE IF YOU CAN SHARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT. I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT-
CAUTIOUSNESS AND- I WOULD NOT
CERTAINLY WANT TO BE. PAVING
THE WAY FOR MORE RISKY
DEVELOPMENT IN THE STATE I. I
KEEP TRYING TO WRESTLE WITH-
WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THE PEOPLE
WHO ALREADY LIVE THERE. RIGHT
PEOPLE WHO LIVE WHERE I
WOULDN'T SILMAR DEEP INTO
PAYING- IN THE SAN GABRIEL
MOUNTAINS OR IN THE NORTH COAST
HER BRAIN OR WHATEVER IT IS
AND- I THINK WE GOT A HARD NOSE
COMMUNITIES. I THINK WE'VE GOT
A- SORT OF SURGICALLY DEAL WITH
EACH OTHER SYSTEMS BUT- WHAT I
DON'T SEE HERE IS THAT BY
EXPANDING THE BUILDING
STANDARDS TO SAY HI FIRE ZONES.
THAT THAT SHOULD THEN BE- SOME
INFORMATICA. GO IN AND HAVE
BREAKNECK BLIND GROWTH I THINK
WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON INFILL
AND- AND- AREAS WITHOUT. RISK
SO- I APPRECIATE THE
CAUTIOUSNESS AND- HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL BE. MAKING SOME PROGRESS
ON THAT THIS YEAR- MY BUILDING
MAKE IT OUT OF OUR HOUSE BUT
YOU HAVE ANOTHER ONE COMING
YOUR WAY. THANK YOU I BELIEVE
THERE ARE NO OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES THAT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
APPRECIATE THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE NORTH ALSO RAISING-
SOME OF THE OTHER ITEMS I
DIDN'T MENTION IN MY OPENING UP
IT'S A BIT OF AN OMNIBUS
MEASURE THAT THE SENATE AFTER
RESEARCHING WATER COMMITTEES
WORKING ON FOR THREE YEARS I
WISH WE HAD THIS BILL IN LAW
THREE YEARS AGO- BUT THINGS GO
SLOW WE'VE HAD OTHER IMPORTANT
MEASURES EMERGE FROM THIS
COMMITTEE OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS THAT STILL AREN'T LAWNS
SHOULD BE SO. HOPEFULLY THIS
YEAR WILL MAKE SOME PROGRESS
AND- AND FINALLY GET AHEAD OF
THIS THIS FIRE PROBLEM I THINK
WHICH WERE STILL BEHIND THE
EIGHT BALL AND CHASING IT- BUT
I SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE CALL
OUT TO SHIP N THE SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM THIRTEEN
SB SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR STERN
MEMBERS RIVAS. HI RIVERSIDE
FLORA. LARA I'D TRY. CHAU I.
FRIEDMAN I'D GARCIA. GARCIA AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MCCARTY HI
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI RATHER
G. SAY ARE TOO HIGH THEY ARE TO
AYE STONE STONE I WOULD I WOULD
I ELEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE
BILL ON CONSENT. THAT I NEED A
MOTION. HEY OF MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS SECOND
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
I'M NOT A MAY AS WE TO- IT BY
DOLLY MOTION IS TO PASS REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WITH CONTENT RECOMMENDATION
MEMBERS RIVAS. HI RIVERSIDE
FLORA FLORA CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
ALL RIGHT MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI ROAD TO GI SAY ARE
TOO HIGH. THEY ARE TO IS STONE
STONE. I WOULD. WHAT I LOVE AND
LEVY ZERO IF BILLS OUT OF. THE
FIRST BILL THAT WE HEARD- WE
WERE. YEAH WE WERE A SUB
COMMITTEE SO I NEED A MOTION
FOR SB FORTY FOUR SECONDS OKAY
MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS SECONDED BY SOME MEMBER
MCCARTY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ONE ITEM ONE SB FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED. AND
REFER TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLORA. FLORA CHAU CHAU AYE
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I'D GARCIA.
GARCIA NOT VOTING MATHIS MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY HI MCCARTY I'M
ABOUT TO CHANGE MURATSUCHI I'D
SAY OUR JOB RIGHT THERE ARE TWO
AYE STONE STONE NOW. WOULD WOOD
I. NINE ONE NINE ONE THAT BILL
IS OUT- NEXT WE CAN MOVE AHEAD
MOVE ON AND DO WHAT WE NEED ADD
ONS RIGHT TO. PROBABLY EVERY
BILL TO WANT TO GO IN ORDER
MEASURES STARTING WITH FILE
ITEM TWO YES. ITEM TO SB EIGHTY
THREE BY ALAN THE MOTION TO
PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA. FLOOR NOT
VOTING FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I'D
MCCARTY HI MCCARTY I. STONE SO
I. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT. ON ITEM THREE SB
THREE FORTY THREE BY SNATOR
ALAN TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO. ABSENT
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I.
MCCARTY HI MCCARTY I. EIGHT
ZERO EIGHT ZERO THAT BILLS OUT.
AN ITEM FOR SB FOUR THIRTY
THREE BY ALAN DO PASSED REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GARCIA GARCIA I
MCCARTY HI MCCARTY I. TEN ZERO
TEN ZERO THAT BILLS OUT. I DO A
FIVE SB SIX FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA TO PASS REFER
TO TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU CHOW I'D FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I'D GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE.
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO APPLE
IS ALSO. IDM SIX S. B. ONE BY
SENATOR ATKINS. TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS CHILD CHAU AYE
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA
AYE GARCIA AYE MCCARTY HI
MCCARTY I. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
APPLE'S OUT. FOR ITEM SEVEN SB
FIVE NINETY SIX BY SENATOR
BACKER TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TO
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU CHAU
AYE GARCIA GARCIA I WOULD.
WOULD I. ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN
ZERO THAT BLOWS OUT. I DO NINE
SB EIGHT OH FOUR BY GLAZER DO
PASS REFER TO PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA-
FLORA I CHAU CHAU AYE GARCIA
GARCIA I WOULD. WOOD I 11-3
LEVIN ZERO FILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
TEN SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX BUT
SENATOR GONZALEZ DO PASS AND
REFER TO TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE- VOTE. EIGHT TWO TWO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA FLORA NOT VOTING.
EIGHT TWO EIGHT TWO DOLLARS OUT.
I AM A LEVIN SB SIX NINETEEN BY
SENATOR LAYERED. DO PASSED
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE NINE TO
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS CHILD CHILD
HI FRIEDMAN. TEN ZERO TEN ZERO.
I DON'T TWELVE SB TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE TENDED
ZERO ABSENT MEMBER FLORA FLOOR
I'D. ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO.
WHAT'S IT K. BELIEVE THAT SET
UP ON ITEM ELEVEN- DID YOU NEED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN I'M
NOT I KNOW SHE WAS HERE. THE
FINAL VOTE WAS. TEN TO ZERO TEN
TO ZERO. I'M NOT SURE IF SHE
MISSED I JUST WANT TO LEAVE IT
OPEN IN CASE SHE WANTS TO ADD
ON- ME TOM. OKAY OR- I JUST
WANTED TO CONFIRM VISIT SURE IF
SHE WAS. I CAN. AT EXACTLY THE
SAME. YEAH ONE OF ALL YEAH. A
LARGE WITH ORGANIC FOOD FOR A
LIVING. DILLARD WENT YEAH. WE
GET ALL CONCERNED.
FIVE
EVERYTHING IF. YOU.